OKAY GOOD MORNING WHERE TO START
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
ON EDUCATION FINANCE.
TODAY RAINY HERE THE HIGHER READ
MAY REVISED PROPOSALS TODAY'S.
HEARING IS INFORMATIONAL ABOUT
THE MAY REVISED PROPOSALS WE
WILL NOT BE TAKING ANY ACTIONS
TODAY WE'LL BE.
WRAPPING UP OUR OUR OUR WORK
NEXT WEEK BUT TODAY WE HEAR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FROM THE
MAY REVISE -- HIGHER YOU SEE CSU
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN STATE
COMMISSION.
AS WELL AS AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM
RELATED TO THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH RELATED --
TO THE INNOVATION GRANTS SO
LET'S START WITH THAT ISSUE
NUMBER ONE OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH
.
REBEKAH KIRK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TEN MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ONE TIME TO SUPPORT GRANTS TO K.
TWELVE AND POST SECONDARY
INSTITUTIONS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
AND INLAND EMPIRE REGIONS.
IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT INNOVATIVE
EDUCATIONAL STRATEGIES.
THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDES MORE
DETAILED BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE ON
THIS PROPOSAL WHICH IN PART
SPECIFIES THAT CONSIDERATION FOR
THESE GRANTS WOULD PARTICULARLY
EMPHASIZE PROGRAMS THAT BETTER
ALIGNS SECONDARY AND POST
SECONDARY PROGRAMS.
ARE EXPECTED TO REDUCE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
AND ARE CAPABLE OF CREATING A
MULTI GENERATIONAL CULTURE OF
EDUCATIONAL ENTERTAINING.
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
CHASING CONCENTRA SALLY L. IF
YOU TURN TO PAGE TWO OF YOUR
AGENDA IT DESCRIBES IN MORE
DETAIL BOTH A PROPOSAL AND ALSO
THE SPECIFIC -- CHANGES THAT ARE
MADE IN A REVISION.
WE HAVE TO OVER ARCHING --
CONCERNS OF THIS PROPOSAL THE
FIRST IS THAT THIS PROPOSAL
APPEARS TO SHARE A LOT OF THE
SAME SHORTCOMINGS.
WITH PREVIOUS -- HIGHER
EDUCATION -- AB INNOVATION GRANT
INITIATIVES THAT HAVE BEEN
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE IN
PREVIOUS YEARS.
AS A REMINDER THOSE PROGRAMS
TENDED TO PROVIDE A LARGE SUMS
OF MONEY TO A RELATIVELY SMALL
NUMBER OF INSTITUTIONS. TO
INCOME IMPLEMENT LOCAL
INITIATIVES WITHOUT A CLEAR PLAN
FOR DISSEMINATING THAT THAT --
THOSE INNOVATIONS ARE ACROSS THE
STATE.
SECONDS THIS PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO
DUPLICATE MANY OTHER MORE
IMPACTFUL EFFORTS OF THE STATE
HAS UNDERTAKEN IN RECENT YEARS.
TO IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES IN
THE EDUCATION SYSTEM.
THOSE -- EFFORTS INCLUDE THINGS
LIKE ADOPTING THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA AND START
WISHING SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY --
CREATING -- A COMMUNITY COLLEGE%
PROGRAMS THAT ADDRESS STUDENT
SUCCESS IN INCLUDING STUDENT
SUCCESS AS A COMPONENT IN THE
APPORTIONMENT FORMULA.
pAUGMENTATIONS A TO CSU FOR ITS
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
IN EACH OF THESE CASES EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS HAVE SIGNIFICANT
FLEXIBILITY TO YOU TO ALLOCATE
THOSE FUNDS.
AND TO USE THEM TO FIND
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO ADDRESS AND
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES.
GIVEN THESE TWO CONCERNS WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
QUESTION FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- YOU KNOW ONE THING
THAT THAT WE NOTED IS THERE ARE.
EXISTING PROGRAMS IN THAT
STUDENT COMMISSION WHICH DO THIS
WORK THE CAL SO PROGRAM IT'S NOT
IN THE AGENDA WE WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS LAST.
YEAR'S I'M FAMILIAR WITH IT FROM
COUPLE DECADES BACK.
IN SO -- WANTED TO ASK IF YOU
WOULD RESPOND TO TO THAT AND WHY
THE DUPLICATION AND RICK
REINVENT THE WHEEL WHEN WE HAVE.
EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN BEEN DOING JUST
THIS -- TARGETING.
HIGH SCHOOL POPULATIONS WITH LOW
COLLEGE GOING RATES THAN HELPING
THEM NAVIGATE THE COLLEGE MAYES.
YES -- SO THE CAO ALSO PROGRAM
WE DEFINITELY RECOGNIZE THE
VALUE IN THAT PROGRAM AND THOSE
CONSORCIO THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
THIS PROPOSAL REVIEWING AS SORT
OF A A COMPLIMENTARY PROPOSAL TO
BOTH CAL SOAP IN THE OTHER
EXISTING PROGRAMS HIGHLIGHTED IN
THE ALLEY OWES COMMENTS.
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL IS A
LITTLE BIT UNIQUE IN THE SENSE
THAT IT'S PRIORITIZE FOR THE TWO
REGIONS INLAND EMPIRE.
AND THE SAN JOAQUIN REGION OF
THE STATE THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS AREAS WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATION -- IN WHICH WE
COULD REALLY USE SOME ADDITIONAL
INNOVATIVE EDUCATIONAL
STRATEGIES. ONE WAY IN WHICH
THIS PROPOSAL IS SOMEWHAT UNIQUE
AS WELL IS THAT IT'S REALLY
STIMULATING.
INNOVATIVE IDEAS IN THESE
PARTICULAR AREAS BOTH OF THE K.
TWELVE OR POST SECONDARY LEVEL.
AND WERE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
THESE CHALLENGES SUCH AS
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND CREATING A
MULTI CAR GENERATIONAL --
CULTURE OF COLLEGE ATTAINMENT.
THOSE ARE CHALLENGING ISSUES
THAT NECESSITATE A MULTI FACETED
APPROACH SO WE DON'T SEE THE
ADDITIONAL PROPOSAL IS
NECESSARILY BEING DUPLICATIVE OR
IN CONFLICT WITH THE OTHER
EXISTING APPROACHES.
I GUESS THE ONLY.
CONCERN IS THAT.
THIS IS AN OBVIOUS YET A BIG
ISSUE -- AND WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IT FOR A COUPLE DECADES IN.
THE WE STEPPED UP A FEW YEARS
AGO WITH THE UC WESTWOOD
ACADEMIC OUT REACH PROGRAMS AND
SAY PET PROGRAMS I GUESS THE
COLUMN.
AND WE PUT SOME MONEY IN THE
STATE COMMISSION PROGRAMS NOW
AND SO.
WE KIND OF KNOW WHAT WORKS AND
WHAT DOESN'T WORK AND THAT THIS --
YOU KNOW TEN MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME.
SO WE DIDN'T THIS PROBABLY NOT
WORTH EXPERIMENTING WITH ME NOW
BUT ACTUALLY WHAT WORK
ESPECIALLY IN THESE AREAS WHERE
WE HAVE.
THESE PROGRAMS AND SOME
SOMETHING THAT WILL CONSIDER
WITH THE FINAL ACTION SO THANK
YOU.
OKAY -- THANK YOU MUCH.
WELL THIS ISSUE OPEN MISTER DOT.
THANKS SO I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S TEN
MILLION DOLLARS A ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND.
DOLLARS -- FOR GRANTS TO
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN INLAND EMPIRE
REGIONS WHAT EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT.
SPECIFICALLY THEY COULD BE K.
TWELVE OR POST SECONDARY
EDUCATIONAL AND SO IT'S NOT EVEN
DEFINED YET AS TO WHO WOULD GET
THEM.
IT'S MORE FLEXIBLE CURRENTLY
ANYONE WHO WOULD BE THE LEAD
AGENCY.
AT THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCHWOULD BE ADMINISTERING
THE GRANT FUNDS.
WHY IS IT IN THIS IS FOR
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES?
YES RIGHT INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES
TO IMPROVE EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES.
OF THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
IDENTIFIES A FEW PRIORITIES SO
BETTER ALIGNMENT OF SECONDARY
AND POST SECONDARY PROP PROGRAMS.
REDUCTION OF ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
FURTHERING SUCCESS FOR ALL THE
AREA AND A LOT OF MONEY FOR THAT
NOW.
YES THERE ARE EXISTING PROGRAMS
SO JUST QUICKLY IS THAT WE HAVE.
L. C. F. F. AT K. TWELVE IN THE
NOW BEYOND THAT OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL WE HAVE A
SOMETHING THAT REFLECTS ALL SEE
OF HAVE SO WHY WOULD BE.
WHAT WOULD MORE MONEY DO?
MY ONLY CONCERN IS DOESN'T SEEM
REALLY DEFINED IT DON'T REALLY
SEEM.
THERE'S NO SPECIFIC AS TO WHAT.
WHAT WHAT WHAT THIS WOULD LOOK
LIKE ON THE GROUND OR EVEN EVEN
THE OUTCOMES?
IS A DEFINED HOW THE OUTCOMES
WOULD BE MEASURED.
AT THERE WERE THERE IS REPORTING
LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD HAVE.
THE GRANT RECIPIENTS REPORT BACK
TO THE PART OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATURE ON OUTCOMES THE
RECIPIENTS OF THE GRANTS -- AS
WELL AS SOME OUTCOME INFORMATION
FOR STUDENT OUTCOMES.
IT JUST SEEMS IS THIS SEEMS TO
ME.
MISTER CHAIR OF DISSOLVED ISSUE
MY OPINION US JUST DOES SEEM
CLEAR IS WHAT THE GOALS NUMBER.
ONE IT SHOULD BE MORE SPECIFIC
THE OUTCOMES.
AND I'VE BEEN JUST IT SEEMS LIKE
IT'S JUST TOSSING MONEY OTHERS
HE WANTS TO GRAB IT QUITE
FRANKLY.
SO IN IN IN IF K. TWELVE ARE YOU
REALLY LISTEN TEY COULD USE
MORE MONEY.
BE THE FIRST CHAMPION OF THAT IN
THIS BODY BUT IF YOU JUST CAN
OFFER A MONEY FOR SOMETHING
THEY'RE ALREADY DOING.
SHOULD WE OFFERED ACROSS THE
STATE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE THESE ISSUES
ACROSS THE STATE.
RIGHT SO THAT THE TWO AREAS FOR
THIS PROPOSAL THE INLAND EMPIRE
AND SAN JOAQUIN REGIONS WERE
IDENTIFIED AS PRIORITIES BY THE
ADMINISTRATION -- A FEW REASONS
THAT LED TO THAT PRIORITIZATION
INCLUDING REAL PERSONAL INCOME
BEING LOWER IN THOSE AREAS THAN
THEY ARE FOR THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE UNEMPLOYMENT BEING
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER IN THOSE
REGIONS THAN THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE.
AND THEN ALSO WHILE THEY SEE --
INCREASING NUMBERS OF HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES WERE SEEING
LOWER THAN STATEWIDE AVERAGE
NUMBER THAT MEET THE ADMISSIONS
CRITERIA FOR UC AND CSU.
SO THIS PROPOSAL IS REALLY AIMED
AT JUST GENERATING -- AND
INCENTIVIZING SOME INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES THAT K. TWELVE OR
POST SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS MAY
COME UP WITH IN CONJUNCTION WITH
OTHER ENTITIES AS WELL -- AIMED
AT AT ADDRESSING THOSE ISSUES SO
IT IS FOCUSED MORE AT
IMPLEMENTING INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES THAT ARE NEW IDEAS.
TO CREATE MORE OF A A MULTI
GENERATIONAL COLLEGE ATTAINMENT --
CULTURE IN THOSE REGIONS AND TO
GENERATE MORE COLLEGE ATTENDANCE
GOT IT GOT IT WELL LISTEN I WAS
FROM THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
OR FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE.
I UNDERSTAND WHY WOULD SUPPORT
THIS BUT ALTHOUGH I'M NOT.
I'M NOT SAYING THIS ISN'T A GOOD
IDEA AS MUCH AS I'M SAYING THIS
DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE FLUSHED OUT
TO ME.
AS SOON TO WHAT THE FULL INTENT
IS BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAVE A LOT
OF PROGRAMS THAT ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES NOW SO I'LL JUST LEAVE IT
AT THAT THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU AGAIN WE'RE GONNA
HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN.
LET'S PROCEED NOW WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND NAY
REVISED PROPOSAL STUFF SKEWS ME
FIRST.
STATE LIBRARY.
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES FOUR
ITEMS OUTLINED IN YOUR AGENDA
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY.
THE FIRST IS DIGITAL CONCIERGE
SERVICES AND CULTURAL HISTORIC
PRESERVATION.
MAY REVISION INCLUDES ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND ONE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND ON GOING. TO SUPPORT
THREE POSITIONS THAT WOULD
ESTABLISH A TEAM PROVIDING
DIGITAL CONCIERGE ARCHIVAL
SERVICES FOR STATE ENTITIES.
AND TO ALLOW FOR COMMISSION OF A
SURVEY TO INVENTORY CULTURAL
HERITAGE ASSETS.
WITH THESE FUNDS THE STATE
LIBRARY WOULD BE ABLE TO
PRESERVE IMPORTANT RECORDINGS
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS MAPS AND
OTHER ITEMS CULTURAL
SIGNIFICANCE.
AND CREATE A CENSUS OF RARE
ITEMS TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
HOUSING CARED FOR APPROPRIATELY.
WOULD YOU LIKE THE TO HEAR THE
OVERVIEW OF THE OTHER ITEMS OR
SHIRT ON RECEIPT OKAY.
AND THE MAYOR VISION ALSO
INCLUDES THREE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME FOR THE
STATE LIBRARY TO PROVIDE GRANTS
TO LOCAL LIBRARIES TO ACQUIRE
BOOK MOBILES AND COMMUNITY
OUTREACH VEHICLES.
THIS WILL BE PRIORITIZE FOR
LIBRARIES WITH LOW PER CAPITA
LIBRARY SPENDING AND IN NEED FOR
MOBILE SERVICES BASED ON
GEOGRAPHIC AND DEMOGRAPHIC
FACTORS.
AT THE MAY REVISION ALSO
INCLUDES FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME TO PROVIDE
GRANTS FOR LOCAL LIBRARY
JURISDICTIONS TO IMPLEMENT EARLY
LEARNING AND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
PRIORITIZE TO LIBRARY
JURISDICTIONS WITH THE LOWEST
PER CAPITA LACKEY SPENDING.
ANIME REVISION INCLUDES FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND GENERAL FUND
ONE TIME TO SUPPORT THE
PRESERVATION OF HISTORICAL LGBT
Q. SITES.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO.
SO REVIEWING THESE PROPOSALS ON
PAGE FOUR OF YOUR AGENDA.
FROM WHAT WE IDENTIFIED A FEW
CROSS CUTTING -- ISSUES TO
CONSIDER AND ALL ALL WALK
THROUGH A THREE OF THOSE ISSUES
RIGHT NOW.
THE FIRST ISSUE IS WHILE A
NUMBER OF THESE PROPOSALS ARE
ONE TIME -- THEY ARE
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE THEY
COULD THERE COULD BE SOME
ADDITIONAL COSTS IN LATER YEARS
ASSOCIATED WITH SOME OF THESE
PROPOSALS.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT WHAT THOSE POTENTIAL OUT
YOUR COSTS COULD BE.
A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THAT IS ONE OF
THE PROPOSALS WOULD BE TO
PROVIDE SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME TO START THE
INITIAL STAGES OF DEVELOPING A
STATE WIDE INVENTORY OF CULTURAL
HISTORICAL ASSETS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
A STEP FOR THE STATE LIBRARY
NOTED THAT THE FUNDING MAY NOT
BE ENOUGH TO FULLY COMPLETE THE
INVENTORY THIS COULD JUST SORT
OF BE THE FOR THE FIRST STAGES
OF OCT FOR MULTI YEAR EFFORT.
THAT WOULD NOT ONLY DEVELOP THE
INVENTORY BUT ALSO IDENTIFY LONG
TERM STRATEGIES. TO PROTECT.
RESOURCES DEEMED AT RISK OF
DAMAGE OR OR LOSS.
AND SO YOU MIGHT WANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE ADDITIONAL
OUT YOUR COSTS ARE AND WHAT THE
OVER ARCHING PLAN IS AS YOUR AS
YOUR WEIGHING WHETHER OR NOT TO
ADOPT THIS PROPOSAL.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF IT -- FOR ONE
OF THE GRANT LOCAL ASSISTANCE
GRANT PROGRAMS FOR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
ARE THIS IS FUNDING ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE THAT ARE PROVIDING THAT
LIBRARIES ARE PROVIDING AFTER
SCHOOL SERVICES TO STUDENTS.
AND SO THE QUESTION HERE IS --
HOW WITH THE LIBRARY SUSTAIN
THOSE -- ACTIVITIES ON AN
ONGOING BASIS IN LATER YEARS
GIVEN THAT THIS IS ONE TIME
FUNDING.
A SECOND CONSIDERATION OF THAT
WE RAISES THAT THE CURRENT
PROPOSALS.
WOULD HAVE.
SOMEWHAT LIMITED BUDGET BILL.
A LANGUAGE STATING HOW THE FUNDS
WOULD BE USED ANOTHER SORT OF
PARAMETERS -- YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THE LIBRARY WOULD ALLOCATE THOSE
FUNDS IF YOU HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THAT WE RECOMMEND THAT YOU.
STRONGER BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
THAT SETS PARAMETERS FOR EXAMPLE
HOW THE FUNDS WOULD BE
PRIORITIZED -- WHO WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE GRANTS?
AND THE THIRD FOR FOR EVERY
SINGLE ITEM WE RECOMMEND --
REPORTING LANGUAGE -- AFTER
APPROPRIATE IF YOU WERE TO
APPROPRIATE THE FUNDS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS A FACT OF
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT ARE YOU
COULD THE REPORTS COULD INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE HOW THE FUNDS WERE
SPENT.
ON THE OUTCOMES THAT WERE --
THAT RESULTED FROM THE FUNDING
AND WE WE CAN WE WE CAN WORK
WITH STAFF ON ON CLARIFYING THAT
LANGUAGE THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU STATE LIBRARY.
THANKS GREG LOCUSTS FROM THE
STATE LIBRARY -- MAIN CHASE --
NAY IS RIGHT THAT IF WE CONDUCT
OR BEGIN TO CONDUCT A SURVEY OF
CALIFORNIA'S CULTURAL ASSETS I
MEAN THE SIX THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED MSEUMS LIBRARIES
GALLERIES ARCHIVES.
HISTORICAL SOCIETIES IT'S LIKELY
THAT'S GOING TO AND COVER THE
SAME SORT OF ISSUES THAT ARE
ADDRESSED IN THE LAST BUDGET
ITEM TO HELP ARCHIVES FOR LGBT.
Q. -- MATERIALS MAKE CALIFORNIA
HAS. TWO OF THE THREE LARGEST
ARCHIVES -- LGBT Q. ARCHIVES AND
THEY FACE SIMILAR CHALLENGES TO
EVERY OTHER ARCHIVE AND THE
STATE -- REPORTING.
IF.
HAPPY TO DO THAT -- BUT INCLUDED
AS PART OF OUR ANNUAL REPORT AS
AS OPPOSED TO YOU KNOW MULTIPLE
DISCRETE REPORTS.
THANK YOU ALL WOULD BE MORE
LIKELY TO LOOK AT IT IF IT WAS
IN ONE DOCUMENT AS WELL.
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE'VE YET TO
HEAR FROM YOUR DAUGHTER'S AGE
AND ABOUT THAT PROMOTIONAL
CAMPAIGN FOR ZIP BOOKS OKAY
MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU ON THE CASE.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY HEARING NONE THANK YOU FOR
THE PRESENTATION WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OF IT THANK YOU.
PROCEED TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BUDGET PROPOSALS
.
GOOD MORNING JESS WALTER FROM
THE FINANCE -- IN ADDITION TO
THE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT MADE
IN THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAN A
REVISION INCLUDES SEVERAL KEY
INVESTMENTS.
IN THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA --
THE FIRST IS TWENTY FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
UC'S EFFORTS TO REDUCE UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES IN THE UC RETIREMENT
PLAN.
AT THE SECOND IS THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR DYSLEXIA SCREENING
PILOT OPERATED BY THE TO SO AT
UCSF DYSLEXIA CENTER -- THE
PILOT WILL LEVERAGE A A NEW
APPLICATION. TO IDENTIFY
LEARNING DISABILITIES EARLIER
AND INTERVENE -- WE ARE.
ALSO PROPOSING THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR
A RAPIDLY HOUSING AT THE
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA.
AND THE MAYOR VISION PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL CLARITY REGARDING THE
USEOF THE ONGOING FIFTEEN
MILLION -- GENERAL FUND TO
ADDRESS JUNE HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS.
THESE USES INCLUDE FOOD PANTRIES
CAL FEDERAL MEANT -- YOU'LL
DONATION AND HOUSING SUPPORT --
WE ARE.
ALSO PROPOSING LANGUAGE THAT
WILL ALLOW THE CITY USE. FIVE
MILLION OF THE ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND PROVIDED FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. TO CONDUCT
A PLAN FACILITIES ASSESSMENT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY ELIA.
PAGE SIX OF YOUR GENDER
DESCRIBES EACH OF THEM A
REVISION PROPOSALS THAT ARE
RELEVANT TO YOU SEE.
OF THESE PROPOSALS ARE OUR MOST
NOTABLE -- COMMENTS ARE ON THE
FIRST THREE PROPOSALS.
A RETIRED THE RIVER THE UC RP
PROPOSAL DYSLEXIA AND RAPID RE
HOUSING.
I'M GOING TO ADDRESS THE FIRST
TWO PROPOSALS ON IF IT'S IF IT
HELPS THE COMMITTEE.
ON THE RAPID RE HOUSING PROPOSAL
FOR YOU SEE IS VERY SIMILAR TO A
A LITTLE MUCH LARGER DOLLAR
AMOUNT PROPOSAL FOR CSU.
WE THOUGHT FOR THE SAKE OF TIME
WE COULD CONSOLIDATE OUR
COMMENTS ON THE CSU ITEM -- SAW
FOCUS MY MY COMMENTS ON THE
FIRST TWO ITEMS.
WITH REGARD TO THE FIRST
PROPOSAL FOR YOU SEE OUR P..
WE THINK THIS RAISES THREE KEY
ISSUES FOR CONSIDERATION.
THE FIRST ISSUE FOR
CONSIDERATION IS A FAIRLY BROAD
ISSUE THAT THE LEGISLATURE FACES
EACH YEAR AS IT'S THINKING ABOUT
ADDRESSING THE STATE'S.
A LONG TERM LIABILITIES.
ARE THE CITY CURRENTLY
CONTRIBUTES FUNDS INTO THREE
PENSION SYSTEMS CALPERS CASTERS
AND USE YOUR PC.
AND SO THE QUESTION IS.
GIVEN THAT ALL THREE OF THESE
SYSTEMS HAVE UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES WHAT'S HOW DO YOU
PRIORITIZE FUNDS TO ADDRESS
THESE UNFUNDED LIABILITIES.
WHAT APPROACH WOULD BE TO
ADDRESS THE UNFUNDED LIABILITIES
AND PERSON STIRS FIRST?
THE RATIONALE BEHIND APPROACH
WHERE THE LEGISLATIVE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE THAT
APPROACH WOULD BE THAT THE STATE
ALL UP LARGELY DETERMINES
PENSION BENEFITS FOR EMPLOYEES
IN THE SYSTEMS.
IT ALSO DETERMINES THE FUNDING
POLICIES.
BY CONTRAST THE REGION'S NOT THE
STATE LEGISLATURE DIRECTLY ADOPT
PENSION BENEFITS IN THE FUNDING
POLICY FOR YOU SEE OUR P..
SO THERE'S A SOMEWHAT LESS CLEAR --
STATES -- RESPONSIBILITY TO
ADDRESS ANY UNFUNDED LIABILITIES
RESULTING FROM UNDER FUNDING --
THE PENSION SYSTEM IN PREVIOUS
YEARS NOT SO THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT BE INTERESTED AND
ADDRESSING COST PRESSURES AT THE
UNIVERSITY.
IF I WERE INTERESTED IN DOING
THAT -- IT COULD A BIG COULD
APPROPRIATE THE ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR YOU SEE OUR P..
THAT SAID OUR SECOND ISSUE FOR
CONSIDERATION IS THAT ONE WAY
THE LEGISLATURE COULD SORT OF
GAUGE HIS QUESTION IS BY HAVING.
AN ASSET AND AN ESTIMATE OF THE
FISCAL SAVINGS ASSOCIATED WITH
PAYING DOWN THE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY FASTER.
RIGHT NOW THE ADMINISTRATION
HASN'T PROVIDED THAT ESTIMATES
THE LEGISLATURE'S LACKING A KEY
PIECE OF INFORMATION TO MAKE
THAT DETERMINATION THAT'S
SOMETHING YOU COULD REQUEST FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION BEFORE MAKING
FINAL DECISIONS ON THIS PROPOSAL.
THIRD.
WE RECOMMEND THAT IF THE
LEGISLATURE DOES DECIDE TO ADOPT --
FUND THIS PROPOSAL IT COULD
CONSIDER -- SOME SORT OF MATCH
BETWEEN THE GENERAL FUND IN UC'S
NON STATE FUNDING. FOR SOME
CONTEXT OF UC'S ABOUT TEN
BILLION DOLLAR LIVE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY THAT'S ROUTE
REPRESENTS THE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY ACROSS THE ENTIRE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
BOTH WITH ITS CORE ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS AND ITS NON CORE
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS SUCH AS ITS
MEDICAL CENTERS OF STUDENT
HOUSING PROGRAMS.
I'M A FIRM IN PROVIDING SOME
SORT OF MATCH WOULD ENSURE THAT
THE STATE IS PAYING FOR THE
PORTION THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH
THE ACADEMIC PROGRAMS AND THAT
THE NOT SAFE PORTION IS PAYING
FOR THE NON STATE FUNCTIONS OF
THE OF THE SYRUPY.
AND WE WOULD NOTE THAT THIS
CONCEPT OF OF SHARING BETWEEN
CORE NON CORE FUNDING.
IS ALREADY PRESENT USE YOUR P.
CURRENTLY THE UNIVERSITY MAKES A
CONTRIBUTIONS TO USE YOUR PC.
AND MAKES US CONTRIBUTIONS OF A
COMBINATION OF CORE FUNDING AND
AND NON CORE FUNDING.
SO THIS WOULD THIS THIS MATCHING
POLICY WOULD EFFECTIVELY
RECOGNIZE THAT WHAT WHAT HOW
IT'S ALREADY FUNDED.
REGARDING THE SECOND PROPOSAL ON
OF THE DYSLEXIA CENTER PILOT
PROGRAM.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION OUR UNDERSTANDING
OF THIS PROPOSAL IS THAT THE
PILOT WOULD BE PART OF A BROADER
EFFORT. TO SCALE ACROSS THE
STATE NEW WAYS TO TEST AND TO
INTERVENE. FOR STUDENTS WHO HAVE
DYSLEXIA OR OTHER FORMS OF
LEARNING DISABILITIES.
THE FIRST CONSIDERATION THE
LEGISLATURE COULD MAKE IS HOW
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD INTERACT
WITH THE STATE'S EXISTING
SPECIAL EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT HELPS US SCHOOLS IDENTIFY
IN SUPPORT STUDENTS HAVE
LEARNING DISABILITIES.
SECOND GIVEN THAT THE OVER
ARCHING ARE FULL OF THE PILOT IS
TO POTENTIALLY SCALE THIS STATE
WHY THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
UNDERSTAND.
OF THE THE THE PATH THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION SEES TO GET THERE
BEFORE PERFORATING FUNDING.
THIRD OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE CENTER HAS RAISED TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND PRIVATE
PHILANTHROPY DUE TO COVER COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH ITS PROGRAMMING
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
UNDERSTAND.
WHY THESE FUNDS MAY NOT BE
AVAILABLE IN WIDE STATE FUNDING
IS NEEDED TO CARRY OUT THIS
PILOT?
AND FINALLY WERE THE LEGISLATURE
INTERESTED IN ADOPTING -- THIS
PROPOSAL WE RECOMMEND THAT
INCORPORATE -- OF REPORTING
LANGUAGE ON HOW THE FUNDS ARE
SPENT ON THE OUTCOMES AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE NEXT STEPS
WOULD BE TO SCALE THE STATEWIDE.
THANK YOU.
YEAH THANK YOU -- FIRST UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK YOU SAVOR CANON
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FIRST
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT WE'RE
PLEASED THAT THE GOVERNOR
RECOGNIZES THE FUNDING NEED FOR
YOU SEE OUR P..
AS THE LA -- STATED YOU SEE OUR
P. CURRENTLY HAS AN UNFUNDED
LIABILITY OF APPROXIMATELY TEN
BILLION DOLLARS WE ANTICIPATE
THAT WE WILL PAY THAT -- WE WILL
MAKE THAT MONEY UP BY -- TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN UNDER THE CURRENT
ACTUARIAL ASSUMPTIONS -- HOWEVER
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN YOU SEE
DEPOSITED ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN TO USE THE R.
P. FROM EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS
OF WHICH ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION CAME FROM.
COR FUNDS -- AND WE ALREADY IN
NINETEEN TWENTY AN ADDITION TO
OUR EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS WERE
PLANNING AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR DEPOSIT.
FROM STEP BROTHER NEWS INTO YOU
SEE OUR PEACE SO WE DON'T THINK
THAT WE NEED YET ANOTHER MATCH
ON TOP WITH THE GOVERNOR'S --
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TO USE THE RPG -- THEN REGARDING
DE DYSLEXIA CENTER WE BELIEVE
THAT THE UC FACULTY CAN CREATE
UP AN EFFECTIVE PROGRAM THAT
TEACHERS STATEWIDE COULD USE. TO
IDENTIFY STUDENTSWITH DYSLEXIA.
IT IS -- TYPE OF LEARNING
DISABILITY THAT CAN BE EASILY
MISUNDERSTOOD BECAUSE THE
STUDENT HAS TROUBLE READING AND
SPELLING.
AND WITH UC FACULTY USING THEIR
RESEARCH AND LEARNING
DISABILITIES AND ARE COMBINING
TALKED WITH OTHER FIELDS THAT
THEY STUDY WE BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN EFFECTIVELY.
CREATE POSITIVE CHANGE FOR THE
STATE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
IN REGARDS TO THE FACILITIES
NEED STUDY UC'S SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE LANGUAGE
AND CHANGING THE FUNDING SOURCE
FOR OUR FACILITY STUDY.
I HAVE -- CHECKED IN WITH OUR
CAPITAL OUTLAY FOLKS AND THE
BOND SALES -- WILL NOT BE
INTERFERED WITH BY CHANGING THE
FUNDING SOURCE OF THIS STUDY.
IN TERMS OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR RECOGNIZES THE NEED FOR
YOU SEE LEGAL SERVICES FOR ARE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS STAFF AND
FACULTY -- BACK IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN YOU SEE PRESIDENT APOLLO
TANO BEGAN FUNDING A LEGAL
SERVICES CENTER AT UC DAVIS FROM
THE U. C. O. P. FUNDING.
AND FROM ITS OPENING IN --
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE CENTER SO A THREE
HUNDRED AND 40% INCREASING CASES.
IT STARTED WITH THREE HUNDRED
ELEVEN CASES AND IT HAS GROWN TO
OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED ANNUALLY --
IMMIGRATION CASES ARE EXTREMELY
COMPLEX AND EXPOSURE WITH
STUDENTS TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE
TURNING TWENTY ONE CAN MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BEING ABLE TO
LEGALLY STAY IN THE COUNTRY AND
NOT BEING ABLE TO STAY IN THE
COUNTRY -- WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
LAWYER AT EVERY CAMPUS ACCEPTED
UC BERKELEY WHICH CONTRACTS OUT
CHOOSE THE CONTRACT OUT BUT WE
HAVE A UC LAWYER AT EVERY CAMPUS.
ASSISTING OUR STUDENTS AND WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL THAT THE GOVERNOR
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS PROGRAM AND HOW THE
STUDENTS CAN CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES UPON GRADUATION AND
WE REQUEST THAT YOU APPROVED OF
EARNERS ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT LEGAL
SERVICES -- NOW I'M GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE WHO
WILL DISCUSS RAPID RE HOUSING
EFFORTS.
YEAH.
WELL TO MIKE'S [inaudible]
OKAY BACK.
TURN INTO A DJ BOOTH OKAY HI
GOOD MORNING WE PRAYED -- SOME
OF THE MATERIALS THAT YOU
REQUESTED FOR US TO GO INTO THE
DATA WAS THE LAST TIME SO.
AS PART OF THE COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO STUDENT WILL BEING
YOU SEE HAS PRACTICALLY BEGUN TO
EXAMINE THE HOUSING CHALLENGES
STUDENT FACE.
CURRENT DATE IN THIS AREA ARE
LIMITED AT BOTH THE STATE AND
NATIONAL LEVEL NEVER THE LESS
YOU SEE TOOK A FIRST INTERNAL
STEP A PRELIMINARY ASSESSING
HOUSING CHALLENGES BY INCLUDING
ONE QUESTION OF HOMELESSNESS.
IN OUR LARGEST STUDIES THE UC
UNDERGRADUATE EXPERIENCE SERVING
THE GRADUAL BEING SURVEY -- THE
U. CUES IS A CENSUS SURVEY AND
AS SUCH EVERY MEMBER OF UC'S
UNDERGRADUATE POPULATION IS
ASKED TO COMPLETE THE SURVEY THE
LARGE SAMPLE SIZE AND GOOD
RESPONSE RATE OF 33%.
OF YOU KEY SURVEY ALLOWS
RESEARCHERS TO PRODUCE MORE
ACCURATE ESTIMATES OF FOOD
INSECURITY WITHIN THE
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT POPULATION
AS MUCH AS THE HOMELESSNESS.
THE GRADUAL BEING SERVICE A
LARGE SCALE SAMPER SERVER WITH
50% RESPONSE RATE ALSO PRODUCE A
ROBUST ENOUGH SAMPLE TO CREATE
ACCURATE ESTIMATES ABOUT THE
PREVALENCE OF HOMELESSNESS
AMONGST OUR POPULATIONS.
SO THE STUDY IN TERMS OF
HOMELESSNESS -- SHOWCASE AT 5%
OF BOTH YOU SEE UNDERGRADUATE
GRADUATE STUDENT POPULATIONS SAY
THAT HAD EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
AT SOME POINT DURING THEIR
ENROLLMENT WITH VARIOUS DEGREES
ACROSS THE DIFFERENT CAMPUSES
WARRING COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
HOUSING MARKETS.
AND THE DEFINITION OF
HOMELESSNESS AND YOU SEE
QUESTION PROVIDED MULTIPLE
EXPONENTIAL CIRCUMSTANCES FOR
PEOPLE TO IDENTIFY WITH BEYOND
JUST HOMELESSNESS SUCH AS COUCH
SURFING -- AT A FRIEND'S PLACE
OR LIVING ON THE STREETS OR
SLEEPING OVERNIGHT AT LIBRARIES
WHAT WE LEARNED HERE IS THAT
LGBT PLUS STUDENTS TRANSFER
STUDENTS LOW INCOME STATUS
STUDENTS.
AND FORMER FOSS YOUTH EACH HAVE
HIGHER RATES AS COMPARED TO
THEIR COUNTERPARTS -- AND THE
IMPACT ON ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
IS THAT FOR STUDENTS ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR
HOUSING IN SECURITY THE
CONSISTENTLY OUTPERFORM LOWER
THAN THEIR COUNTERPARTS WHO ARE
HOUSING SECURE AND OUR FOOD ARE
AND OR FOOD TO CARE.
SOMETHING THAT'S NOTABLE IS THAT
STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING BOTH
FOOD AND SECURITY IN HOMELESS
LANCE IN THEIR FIRST YEAR SECOND
YEAR AND THIRTY YEAR ALL ARE
BELOW THREE POINT OH GPA.
WHICH MAKE SIX SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO FIND
ON AND OFF CAMPUS JOBS AND THEN
IMPACTS THEIR TRANSITIONS TO
GRADUATE SCHOOL AFTER THE FACT.
SO WHEN IT COMES TO THIS RAPID
RE HOUSING STRATEGY WE'RE VERY
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT THE POINT
MILLION DOLLAR OF ONGOING
ALLOCATION FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISED. FOR RAPID RE
HOUSING SERVICES.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO UTILIZING OUR
CAMPUS BASIC NEEDS COMMITTEES
THE SYSTEM MIGHT COMMITTEE AND
ARE CALIFORNIA HIGHER ADD BASIC
NEEDS ALLIANCE. TO LAUNCH
HOUSING NAVIGATION AND RENTAL
SUBSIDIES AND INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
THE STUDENTS OF THE
AFOREMENTIONED POPULATION THAT
HIGHER RATES OF HOMELESSNESS
WILL POWER TIES THOSE
POPULATIONS AS WE MOVE EQUITABLY
TOLL WORDS.
A BETTER HOUSING EXPANDS OR
STUDENTS DON'T HAVE TO
EXPERIENCE THIS CHALLENGE THE
FUNDING ALLOCATION WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED EQUITABLY AND FORM
BY THE CAMPUS HOMELESS RATE
IDENTIFIED IN THE STUDY ABOVE --
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ALL FOR
THOSE MEMBERS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN KNOWING THE
SPECIFIC AMOUNT PER CAMPUS --
WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR ON
GOING BELIEVING COMMITMENT TO
OUR BASIC NEEDS EFFORTS OF ALL
THREE OF OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS.
THESE FUNDS FOR CCCC ISSUING YOU
SEE WILL ALLOW US TO SERVE OUR
STUDENTS IN NEED AND LEARN WITH
EACH OTHER HOW TO BETTER SERVE
OUR STUDENTS.
AND MOVE TOWARDS ERADICATING
ECONOMIC FOOD AND HOUSING
CHALLENGES THE BETTER THAT WE
CARE FOR OUR STUDENTS TODAY THE
BETTER THEY WILL CARE FOR OUR
STATE TOMORROW AND THAT'S PRETTY
MUCH IT.
GO TO MIKE'S.
OKAY NICE JOB THANK YOU.
MR O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA BE CLEAR-WE COVERED ISSUE [inaudible]
THREE AND WAS JUST THREE THERE
WHAT WE DO. FORTY WE COVER FOR
THEIR AS WELL.
NOT YET NO OKAY.
I WAS LISTENING MOSTLY.
THANK YOU NO I JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS -- WITH REGARD TO THE
THE THE USE RETIREMENT PLAN
WHO'S THAT GOVERNED BY WE HAVE
KßT WE HAVE STIRS WE A PERSON
I KNOW THE GOVERNING STRUCTURE
THERE.
WHO GOVERNS THE UC RETIREMENT
SYSTEM THAT WILL BE THE UC
REGENTS UC REGENTS?
ARE THEY TODAY WHEN WE DID THE
THE PEPPER CHANGES TO THE
RETIREMENT SYSTEM MAYBE SIX
YEARS AGO OR SO TODAY IT UP THE
SAME CHANGES TO THE TO THE UC
SYSTEM.
YES WE DID UP A DOCTOR PEPPER
CHANGES NOW THERE ARE EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE GRANDFATHERED INTO THE
OLD SYSTEM.
BEGAN IN -- TWENTY THIRTEEN THE
PEPPER CHANGES WERE ADOPTED FOR
TO USE YOU HAVE NOW OFFERED TO
FIND IN AND AND I FOUND IT.
A DEFINED AN UNDEFINED PLAN
CORRECT YOU CAN CHOOSE AS YOU.
THAT'S CORRECT SO WE IDENTIFY A
WE OFFER TO TRADITIONAL PLAN AND
THEN WE OFFER WHAT'S CALLED A
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLAN WHICH
IS MORE OF A FOR A ONE CASE
STYLE PLAN SO IS THAT ALL
EXASPERATING.
THE PENSION PROBLEM.
WE DON'T THINK SO WE ACTUALLY
THINK THE FOUR ONE CAPE STYLE
PLAN IS CREATING SAVINGS WITHIN
YOU SEE OUR P. WE DO TAKE -- 6%
OF EVERY EMPLOYEE'S SALARY -- OR
SORRY AND EQUIVALENT OF 6% OF
EVERY EMPLOYEE'S SALARY AND
DEPOSITED INTO THIRD TRADITIONAL
PLAN WHETHER OR NOT THAT
EMPLOYEE CHOOSES TRADITIONAL OR
THE FOUR OH ONE K. STYLE PLAN.
THAT IS USED TO PAY DOWN THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY OF THE
TRADITIONAL PLAN -- WHAT MAKES
THE FOUR ONE CASE STYLE PLAN
OTHER DEFINED CONTRIBUTION
ATTRACTIVE FOR OUR EMPLOYEES?
IS WE FIND THAT THE YOUNGER
WORKFORCE MOVES -- IN AND OUT OF
THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM QUITE
RAPIDLY THEY COME FOR A COUPLE
YEARS AND THEN I UNDERSTAND THAT
I JUST IN THE THE THINKING THERE.
AGAIN I'M NOT QUESTIONING THAT I
JUST WANTED MY QUESTION WAS
REALLY POURED INTO WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S EXASPERATING.
THE ANY LIABILITY -- IMPACTING
ANY LIABILITY AND YOU RESPONDED
SO THANK YOU AND THEN IT SAYS
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS -- FOR YOU
WANT TO SHIP FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS APPEARS OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDS TO CONDUCT A
FACILITY NEEDS STUDY.
THAT'S CORRECT WE WERE GOING TO
USE FIVE MILLION OF OUR A. B.
NINETY FOUR CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROCESS. FOR THE FACILITY STUDY
THAT'S BOND DEBT AND DELAY --
HAD RECOMMENDED WE INSTEAD USE
ONE TIME MONEY SO WE'RE SAYING
YES WE CAN DO THAT.
SO WHY IN THE WORLD WILL COST
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
FACILITY NEEDS STUDY -- SUCCESS
I AM I GONNA BE US THAT IS JUST
CRAZY HOW MANY CAMPUSES. TEN
CAMPUSES HOW MANY MODERN LOT OF
SQUARE FOOTAGE WHEN I WAS TEN
CAMPUS SEVEN CAMPUSES SO IT'S
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
TO DO A FACILITIES ASSESSMENT
STUDY FOR EACH CAMPUS I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT I THINK THAT'S
CRAZY.
I I JUST THERE IT'S BEEN CANNOT
CONVINCE ME THAT IT'S FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WERE THE WORK TO
SAY WELL WE NEED THIS MUCH SPACE
WE WE HAVE TO HAVE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS WHO HAVE A LOT OF
TECHNICAL KNOWLEDGE.
AND THE COST AND I DON'T.
I DON'T BUY IT I JUST YOU KNOW
YOUR COST PER QUARE FOOT IN
YOUR BILL IS ALONE A PRETTY OUT
OF THE NORM AND MAYBE THIS IS
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY BUT I I
JUST DO NOT BY THAT -- BUT LET'S
MOVE ON THERE'S FOR HIM IS AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS CORRECT IS
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION TO INCREASE --
INCREASE TO THE UC LEGAL
IMMIGRATION SERVICES PROGRAM
IT'S NOT FOR HER MILLION ISN'T
NO NO IT'S NOT FOR MY NUMBERS
WRONG FOUR HUNDRED IT'S LESS
THAN FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND IN
THE FIRST YEAR.
ONE THOUSAND YES AND OKAY
INCREASING DOES A LOT DIFFERENT.
OKAY MY NUMBER WAS INCORRECT
THANK YOU -- GREAT -- AND AND I
KNOW THAT --UNDER GOVERNOR
BROWN.
WE ALLOCATED ONE TIME FUNDS THE
UC I THINK IT WAS. SEVENTY
MILLION THAT WAS USED FOR
ENROLLMENT SO YOU THEN NOW HAVE
A WHOLE CORRECT BECAUSE THAT WAS
FUNDED ON A ONE TIME BASIS.
THAT'S CORRECT WE OWE LESS GOING
FOR A REFUND YOU ON A ONE TIME
BASIS OR WE WE WE ARE BY
SOMETHING ON A PERMANENT BASIS
YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
THIS WHOLE.
THAT'S CORRECT SIR WE ARE
REQUESTING -- THAT THE PRIOR
YEAR ONE TIME FUNDS BE MADE
PERMANENT AND THE GOVERNOR'S ME
REVISED HAS NOT DONE THAT YET SO
IN THE NUMBER FOR THE ONGOING IS.
OF WE'VE WE WOULD LIKE HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO POINT SIX MILLION
ONGOING BUT THE ONE TIME MONEY
IS. NINETY FIVE RIGHT OKAY SAID
DON'T SPEAK TO THE ONE TIME
RIGHT NOW YEAH SO I I THINK IT'S
IT'S INCOME ON THIS BODY MISTER
CHAIR TO REALLY LOOK AT WHAT WE
CAN DO TO MAKE THAT MONEY ON
GOING -- SPECIALLY THAT THAT
NINETY FIVE MILLION.
IN A BILL THAT IN ON ON GOING
BASIS AS WE CONSIDER WHAT WE
FORWARD OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
WITHOUT A TURN ABOUT YOU YEAH
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL GOOD
QUESTIONS ON A FOLLOW UP ON
THOSE IN IN A BIT -- FIRST
THOUGH MISTER MURATSUCHI THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR -- MS
SO.
THE PART IN IT.
YES.
I WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR PROVIDING THIS.
TELEPHONE BOOK OF THE
INFORMATION ON TO SUPPORT THE
UNIVERSE A CALIFORNIA -- BUDGET
REQUEST AND I YOU KNOW.
I I'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET A OF A
MORE HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE ON
THE DECLINING STATE -- SUPPORT
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I
THAT I HAD THIS INFORMATION --
CORRECT -- HI I SHOULD HAVE
ASKED.
YOU.
TO BUT I BRING YOUR COPY BUT
PERHAPS YOU KNOW THE SOUTH THE
TOP YOUR HEAD -- FIRST OF ALL --
IN THIS REPORT THERE'S A SECTION
THAT TALKS ABOUT HISTORICAL
CHANGES TO STATE FUNDS SUPPORT
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IT TALKS ABOUT HOW -- IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND ONE THE
STATE DEDICATED FOUR POINT ONE
OF THE STATE GENERAL FUND TO THE
UNIVERSITY TODAY FUNDING FOR THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS
JUST TWO POINT FIVE IN THE STATE
BUDGET THAT.
IS AT THE SOUND ACCURATE YES
OKAY.
AND THEN -- IN THAT SAME SECTION
IT TALKS ABOUT -- IT OUT USE
EITHER I KNOW THAT THERE IS --
AN EMPHASIS ON THE CORE FUNDS --
FOR THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AS
DISTINGUISHED FROM SOME OF THE
OTHER MAJOR SOURCE OF REVENUES
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM LIKE THE MEDICAL CENTERS.
BUT THE CORE FUNDS IS IS KIND OF
LIKE YOUR GENERAL FUND THAT THAT
PROVIDES THE PRIMARILY THAT THE
SALARIES AND BENEFITS FOR THE
OPERATIONS FOR THE EDUCATION OF
THE MISSION OF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S CORRECT AND THE REASON WE
FOCUS ON THE CORE FUNDS AS WE
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO TRANSFER
FUNDING BETWEEN THOSE VARIOUS
POTS THEIR LEGALLY RESTRICTED SO
THE CORE FUNDS PAY FOR THE
INSTRUCTORS THE FACULTY.
ALL THE STUFF ON THE CAMPUSES.
OKAY SO -- IN THIS -- SECTION
TALKING ABOUT.
THE HISTORIC DECLINE IN STATE OF
SUPPORT FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA.
THERE IS A SECTION THAT TALKS
ABOUT STATE SUPPORT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY'S BASE BUDGET.
DECLINED BY 56%.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND
ONE IS THAT.
I'M SON RIGHT A MINIMUM READING
FOR A FROM THE REPORTS I ASSUME
THAT THAT'S CORRECT YES THAT
WOULD BE CORRECT OKAY
[inaudible]
AND IT SAYS THAT IN TWO THOUSAND
TWO THOUSAND ONE STATE FUNDING
FOR YOU TO UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA.
CONTRIBUTED ABOUT SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED PER
STUDENT OR ABOUT 72% OF THE
TOTAL COST -- WHEREAS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
STATE'S SHARE DECLINE --
270-007-0030 OR ABOUT 37% OF THE
TOTAL COSTS YES THAT'S CORRECT
THERE'S BEEN A RAPID DECLINE IN
THE STATE FUNDING COMPONENT FOR
YOU OKAY FOR STUDENTS.
SO SO IN OTHER WORDS -- YOU KNOW.
WHEN WHEN WE LOOK AT THE -- THE
HISTORY AT LEAST SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND IT SEEMS LIKE.
WE HAVE HAD DRAMATIC DECLINES
AND THE STATE GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA -- ESPECIALLY DURING
THE THE TWO RECESSION SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND AND WE NEVER.
RECOVERED -- THE LOSSES FROM
THOSE TWO RECESSIONS IS IS THAT
A FAIR DESCRIPTION OF THAT'S
CORRECT SIR AND ONE OF THE WAYS
TO UNIVERSITY MADE UP.
FOR THAT REVENUE WEST BY
ADMITTING OFF MORE NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS WHICH IS WHAT YOU'RE
ABOUT TO DISCUSS NEXT OKAY SO --
YEAH.
EXACTLY SO SO THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA FELT LIKE IN ORDER TO
MAKE UP FOR THE THE DRAMATIC
DECLINE IN STATE.
A SUPPORT FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA GOING TO HEAD TO MAKE
IT UP WITH THE WITH THE REVENUES
FROM THE NON RESIDENT TUITION.
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY AND AND THAT
HAS LED TO RESULTS LIKE. 25% OF
OUR UNDERGRADUATE POPULATION ADD
TO OUR MOST -- POPULAR --
CAMPUSES -- BERKELY UCLA AND UC
SAN DIEGO ONE OUT OF FOUR OF THE
UNDERGRADS LOTS GOING.
TO NON CALIFORNIA KIDS.
THAT'S CORRECT THOSE CAMPUSES
ARE ABOUT 2423% OKAY SO YOUR
POSITION IS IS THAT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA'S POSITION
IS THAT.
AS THAT -- THE THE FACT THAT ARE.
YOU KNOW ONE OUT OF EVERY FOR
UNDERGRAD SLOTS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA GOING TO
NON CALIFORNIA KIDS IS.
A REFLECTION OF OR OR OR IN IN
IN YOUR OPINION A INEVITABLE --
WAVE IT WAS A IT WAS A RESPONSE
TO THE DRAMATIC DECLINE IN STATE
FUNDING FOR FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS A RESPONSE AND DURING
THAT TIME WE HAD A LOT OF NEW
COST PRESSURES WE JUST DISCUSSED
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RETIREMENT PROGRAM -- TO
UNIVERSITY HAD HAD NO
CONTRIBUTIONS INTO THE
RETIREMENT PROGRAM BETWEEN THE
LATE EIGHTIES AND TWENTY TEN AND
THEN IN TWENTY TEN WHEN -- THE
GREAT RECESSION HAVE COST A
COLLAPSE IN THE VALUE OF THE
PLAN WE HAD TO START UP --
CONTRIBUTIONS AGAINST THOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM THE
UNIVERSITY ARE NOW AT 14% OF
EVERY EMPLOYEE'S SALARY.
SO THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT COST
PRESSURE FOR THE UNIVERSITY IN
ADDITION -- TO ALL THE OTHER
COST PRESSURES ANOTHER FACTOR
THAT OCCURRED IS BECAUSE THE
STATE HAS HAD NO GEO BONDS FOR
THE UNIVERSITY SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SIX YOU GAVE US THE
AUTHORITY TO FIND -- BOND
FINANCING OUT OF OUR OWN BUDGET
AND WE STARTED DOING THAT IN
ORDER TO RESPOND.
TO CREATING MORE SPACE HOWEVER --
THAT BOND DEBT IS NOW CREATING A
PRESSURE ON THE UNIVERSITY'S
OPERATING BUDGET ON THE COR
FRONT SIDE AS WELL -- AND
BECAUSE OF THESE COST PRESSURES
AND INFLATION.
THE THOUGH THE STATE HAS
RESTORED OUR FUNDING FROM BILL
ONE BILLION DOLLAR CUT IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE TWENTY TEN WHEN
THAT OCCURRED.
BECAUSE OF THESE ADDITIONAL
PRESSURES AND INFLATION AND
HAVING TO PAY OUR FACULTY MORE --
WE HAVE FEWER DOLLARS AVAILABLE
PER STUDENT AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
BUT A I I'M JUST TRYING TO KEEP
OUR FOCUS I MEAN I I I
APPRECIATE BASICALLY COST
PRESSURES -- HAVE GONE UP AS A
AS IT'S GONNA FOR ALL OF OUR
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS BUT I
IN IN TERMS OF THE THE HIGH
LEVEL BIG PICTURE IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT.
THEY GOING FROM THE FROM THE THE
THE STATE LEGISLATURES.
US SUPPORT FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA FROM ABOUT 70% 72% TO
ABOUT 37% I MEAN THAT KIND OF
CAPTURES THE THE ESSENCE OF OF
THE DRAMATIC DECLINE RANK.
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY -- DOES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AGREE WITH --
THOSE NUMBERS.
MISTER TUCCI OUT AND LOOKING AT
THE TRANS IN STATE GENERAL FUND
SUPPORTED THE UC FROM TWO
THOUSAND TO TO THE CURRENT YEAR --
YOU KNOW YOU DO WE DO HAVE.
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN PER
STUDENT SUPPORT BUT I THINK IT'S
NOT CAPTURE HERE'S THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM WHICH HAS
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY SINCE
THAT TIME PERIOD.
BECAUSE IN ADDITION TO INCREASE
NONRESIDENT ROLE MEANT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED.
BASED TUITION DURING THIS TIME
SO NOT ONLY ARE THEY TAKING AN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FROM SUSAN
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES FROM OUT OF STATE
AND OTHER COUNTRIES.
THEY'RE ALSO LEVERAGING
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND THROUGH
CAL GRANT PROGRAM AND THE LAST I
CHECKED I THINK THAT'S ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES THAT THE UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA WITH A SIZEABLE CHUNK
OF MONEY AS WELL.
SO WHILE THOSE PARTICULAR GRAPHS
AND FIGURES TELL ONE STORY I
THINK THERE'S A BROADER LOOK AT
HOW THE FUNDING SOURCES OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA'S CHANGE
OF THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
OKAY SO THE A FAIR ENOUGH SO --
FOR THE CAL GRANT -- STATE.
FUNDING AS WELL AS THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP -- WHAT DO YOU
DO YOU KNOW APPROXIMATELY HOW
MUCH IS GOING TO THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA -- WELL A THROUGH.
THE STATE GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
FOR FINANCIAL AID I EXITED THE
EXACT FIGURE I DON'T HAVE -- THE
S. WHEN I COULD GIVE YOU BASED
ON NUMBERS I'VE SEEN PREVIOUSLY.
THAT'S HONOR MILLION.
I'M SURE A LOT SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
OKAY SEVEN PLUS THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP WHICH IS MAYBE CLOSE
TO A HUNDRED MILLION YEAH LET ME.
GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT I WOULD
SAY THREE QUARTERS OF A BILLION
DOLLARS IS IS WHAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT LAST COUPLE YEARS.
SO YOU SO GET GIVEN THAT -- THE
THE THE THE STATE TO IN MY
OPINION SHOULD BE CREDITED -- I
MEAN THAT THAT THAT IS A SUPPORT --
FOR A YOU SEE -- STUDENTS -- IN
IN TERMS OF THIS -- THIS THE
PICTURE THAT THE THE STATE
FUNDING AT LEAST SAID AS THE
UNIVERSE A CALIFORNIA PRESENTS
AT THE STATE FUNDING FOR THE UC --
DROPPED FROM 72% 237%.
IF IF YOU WERE TO TAKE IN
ACCOUNT -- THE STATE'S FINANCIAL
AID CONTRIBUTION -- HOW WOULD
YOU ADJUST TO THAT THAT DECLINE
IN STATE FUNDING?
WELL I'M NOT SURE I HAVE THAT
ANNOUNCES PREPARED BUT THE STATE
BUDGET IN THE CURRENT YEAR IS IS
IN THE STATE ECONOMY IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN.
TWO THOUSAND AND OF THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS FAN A STRUGGLE
BUDGETARY LEE PARTICULARLY IN
THE INTO THE PAST RECESSIONS.
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO MAINTAIN OUR
COMMITMENTS BOTH NOW IN THE
FUTURE.
AND STRUCTURALLY TRYING TO
RETURN.
TO AREAS OF OF FUNDING WHERE WE
HAD A MUCH STRONGER.
REVENUE BASE -- WOULD BE TRUE
DIFFICULT TO O CURRENTLY.
IS IN A FACT THAT. FOR THE LAST.
EIGHT YEARS WE'VE HAD.
DISTRAUGHT BAKED CONSISTENT
ECONOMIC GROWTH RECOVERY WITH
POSITIVE BUT BUDGETS IN THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS.
THAT IS TRUE AND THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S IS HAS RECEIVE
SIGNIFICANT REINVESTMENT
INCLUDING THIS YEAR WHICH IT'S
RECEIVED.
LIKELY THE LARGEST INFUSION OF
ONGOING GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND I GUESS I'M I'M
TRYING TO YOU KNOW I I'M I'M
HEARING.
YOU KNOW NOT ONLY IN CALIFORNIA
BUT BUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY THIS
THIS NATIONAL TREND IN DECLINING
STATE FUNDING FOR FOR PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION -- AND AM
SEEING THESE THESE NUMBERS BEING
PRESENTED BY THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA.
DOES THE GOVERNOR HAVE A PLAN AS
TO HOW -- TO YOU KNOW GET US
BACK AT LEAST TO TO WORRY WERE
IN TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND ONE
OR WE'RE CERTAINLY OPENING UP A
LONG TERM CONVERSATION WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
FOCUS ON LONG TERM FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF THEUNIVERSITY.
ACCESS FOR STUDENTS SAND --
FISCAL CERTAINTY FOR STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES.
OKAY BUT IN TERMS OF THE OVERALL --
INSTITUTION THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA I MEAN YOU KNOW I I
CONSIDER THE UNIVERSE OF
CALIFORNIA TO BE.
YOU KNOW -- AMONG THE THE BEST
THINGS THAT WE HAVE GOING FOR US
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I'M
ALWAYS BRAGGING ABOUT HOW.
YOU KNOW NOT ONLY UC'S BUT THE
CSU SECOND COLLEGES THAT WE HAVE
THE BEST PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY --
AND AND AND YET I MEAN I'M
HEARING.
YOU KNOW.
A ONE THAT IT'S GETTING HARDER
AND HARDER FOR CALIFORNIA KIDS
TO GET INTO OUR SCHOOLS AND INTO.
THAT WE MAY BE AT RISK OF OF OF
YOU KNOW -- DAMAGING THE THE THE
THE THE REPUTATION AND AND AND
THE THE QUALITY THE FUNDAMENTAL
QUALITY OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM I I WOULD JUST
ASK ME -- MISTER CHAIR THAT THAT
WE THEY SAID THAT WE KEEP --
THIS BIG PICTURE IN MIND THAT AS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
DYSLEXIA EARLY INTERVENTION
PILOT PROGRAMS AND RAPID RE
HOUSING AND YOU SEE LEGAL
IMMIGRATION SERVICES.
WITH THAT WE KEEP THE BIG
PICTURE MIND ABOUT HOW THIS IS
PART OF WE WE HAVE WE HAVE WE'RE
FAR FROM -- RESTORING -- THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT THEY
THAT THEY HAD.
TO THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE -- NOT YET
RESTORED.
TO A FROM THE LAST TWO
RECESSIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER.
MARTUCCI.
I THINK THAT YOU.
A RAISED THAT A FEW ISSUES THAT
WE NEED TO ALWAYS KEEP.
KEEP OUR EYES ON THE PRIZE ABOUT.
AND THAT'S JUST THE OVERALL.
HIGHER EDUCATION FUNDING AND IT
IS SOMEWHAT.
FRANKLY HONEST WITH THE U.
DEPRESSING THAT IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS SEVEN YEARS AND FIVE FIVE
SEVEN CAM FUNNY -- TRACK RECORD
FOR YOU IT TEARS UP A YOU'VE
BEEN HERE -- IN THE ERA WHEN
WE'VE INVESTED OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS MORE. FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND IT'S OBVIOUSLY
NOT NEARLY ENOUGH AND I THINK
ONE OF THE REALITY CHECKS IS
THAT WE DO MOST LIKELY HAVE A
DOWNTURN COMING.
AND AND EVEN DURING THESE GOOD
TIMES WE HAVEN'T KEPT UP THE
THIS YEAR THERE'S NOT.
MONEY AND THE BUDGET TO ENROLL
ONE NEW CALIFORNIA STUDENT I
KNOW THIS MONEY TO FOR PRIOR
YEARS COMMITMENTS BUT THAT'S
WHAT WE GET IN OUR COMMUNITIES
ALL THE TIME WE TALK ABOUT THE
NEXT ITEM THAT.
PEOPLE COME OUT SAY MY KID MY
NEIGHBOR MY NEPHEW SOMEBODY WE
NOW AS A FOUR POINT THREE GPA
PLAYED UCLA YOU SEE IRVINE UC
BERKELEY AND THEY CAN'T GET IN
THEY HAVE TO GO OUT OF STATE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO EXPAND
ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIA KIDS
CALIFORNIA KIDS?
AND WE DON'T HAVE A REALLY GOOD
ANSWER FOR THEM.
AND SO THESE THE WHOLE NOTION
ABOUT THESE COST DRIVERS WHICH
GOVERNOR BROWN TALKED ABOUT FOR
YEARS IS SOMETHING WE NEED TO GO
BACK TO BECAUSE THIS CURRENT
MODEL IS NOT SUSTAINABLE IT'S A
HOUSE OF CARDS.
I CAN 1100% THAT WERE NOT.
STEPPING UP WHEN IT COMES TO TO
FUNDING HIGHER ED LIKE WE USED
TO AS FAR AS THE PERCENT OF OF
THE BUDGET -- YOU CAN'T JUST GO
BACK IN TIME ALL WE CAN DO IS GO
FORWARD.
AND AND WITH THAT I THINK THAT
WE HAVE TO REALIZE THAT WE DO
PUT OTHERS AS YOU SAID -- JACK
I'M SORRY LAST IMMIGRANTS
FORGETS WALLED SWELLED YES -- WE
DO HAVE TO CHECKS THAT WE GIVE
THE UC ESSENTIALLY WE GIVE THE
GENERAL FUND JACK AND THEN.
THE CHECK ITS WAY TAXPAYER MONEY --
FROM THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM WHICH
IS YOU KNOW THREE QUARTERS OF
BILLION DOLLARS SO I DON'T THINK
WE CAN IT DOLLARS IT TAKES A NOR
THAT.
BUT EVEN THOSE THE COMBINED I
WOULD I WOULD -- PROBABLY SEE
PLATE YOU SAID MR MURATSUCHI
THAT THE PERCENTAGE THEY WERE
PUTTING INTO OVERALL HIRED
FUNDING THROUGH UC'S PROBABLY AS
A PERCENTAGE OF OF OF THE BUDGET --
NOT WHERE WE WERE NOT WHERE WE
WE'RE WHERE WE SHOULD BE -- BUT
WE HAVE A REALITY -- LIMITED --
FOUGHT FUNDS HERE FOR US ALL
THIS PROPOSALS RIGHT HERE THERE --
IT'S ONE TIME IN THE MAY REVISE.
SO WE NEED TO GO BACK TO THIS
THIS NOTION OF THAT THE COST
DRIVERS BECAUSE THE YEAR AFTER
YEAR PROPOSAL FROM THE
UNIVERSITY I'M NOT DIMINISHING
IT BUT WHEN YOU WANT THREE AND%
4% -- GROWTH EVERY YEAR IT JUST
COVERS THE BASICS YEAR.
YOUR COST FOR FACULTY IN YOUR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND YOU AND
JUST THE THE COR STUFF AND
DOESN'T EVEN GET TO THE ISSUES
THAT.
ARE CONSTITUENTS TALK TO US
ABOUT -- AND YOU KNOW THAT
DOESN'T ADD UP AND IT'S INTO A
SHOULD BE A STARK WARNING THAT
AGAIN WHO HAD FIVE YEARS IN A
ROW.
OF A COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR AND AS YOU
SAID.
THIS YEAR THE LARGEST INCREASE
IN GENERAL FUND.
IN THE LAST -- SINCE TWO
THOUSAND YOU SENT.
YEAH YEP ROUGHLY ALMOST TWENTY
YEARS.
SO -- WE NEED.
TO HAVE THAT AS A REALITY CHECK
AS WELL -- I DID WANT TO ASK
ABOUT THE THE ENROLLMENT.
SO THAT THE UNIT AT THE
UNIVERSITIES -- COMMITMENT IS
THE THE THE MONEY YOU GOT LAST
YEAR ONE TIME USE THAT TO BRING
IT IN AT TO FOCUS ON A IN A NEW
INCOMING CLASS OF TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS.
AND THAT GOING TO CONTINUE --
WITH OR WITHOUT THAT THE NEW --
ONGOING CAME IN THE BUDGET SO
YOU'RE SAYING.
THAT'S CORRECT -- IN FALL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE'LL LET IN OVER --
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED NEW
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADS WE
RECEIVED ONE TIME.
A FUNDING FOR THEM AND THOSE
KIDS WILL STILL BE HERE IN FALL
TWENTY NINETEEN AND WE'VE HIRED --
LECTURES T. A.'S WE'VE HIRED
SOME PERMANENT FACULTY TO TEACH
THE CLASSES AND WE'RE HOPING TO
GET THOSE FUNDS ON GOING.
SO REALLY YOU GOT MONEY TO FUND
THEM FOR TWO YEARS RIGHT BECAUSE
IF IF IF IF IT'S IT'S ABOUT
FIFTY MILLION.
ISN'T IT FOR TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS -- UNTIL WE RECEIVE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR THEM.
TWENTY FIVE MILLION [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO SERE YOU RECEIVED A HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME IF THEY ARE
GRADUATE FOR YEARS.
YOU SPEND THAT OVER FOUR YEARS
AS AN THAT ADD UP TO COULD KICK
CARRYING THAT COURT.
I KNOW THE THE SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR TO TUITION BUYOUT
HAS ALSO.
OPENED SPENT ON CAMPUS COSTS IT
THERE TO USE THE HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME FOR OTHER PURPOSES AS
WELL.
WE WE USE IT -- FOR YEAH
INSTRUCTIONAL PURPOSES ON THE
CAMPUSES STUDENTS SERVICES
CAPITAL OUTLAY YES.
OKAY AND AS YOU KNOW WE WE DO
HAVE ANOTHER IDEA THE WILL GONNA
BRING BACK NEXT WEEK. FOR FOR
FUTURE ENROLLMENT GROWTH I'M NOT
SURE WE SETTLED IT AS FAR AS
LAST YEAR'S COMMITMENT IN THE
DECISION THAT THE THAT THE
PRESIDENT MADE WHICH WE SUPPORT
AND SHE SAID PASSED THE CAMPUSES
TO STEP IT UP IN A ROLE -- MORE
STUDENTS AND SO THAT WAS THAT
WAS THE RIGHT CALL THAT WAS IT'S
A DECISION THAT YOU ALL MADE
WITH THAT. ONE TIME -- THE MONEY
AND I KNOW YOU'RE MAKING YOUR
CASE TO HE TO THE GOVERNOR
UNSUCCESSFULLY BUT YOU'RE
CONTINUE TO DO SO -- YES.
AND AND THEN -- LASTLY AS FAR AS
THE DID THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ISSUES.
GO -- I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH IT
COSTS TO GET A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING ON IT BUT I WILL
SAY THAT IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING
WHEN.
WE HEAR THESE CAMPUSES COME IN
AND TALK ABOUT THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND I AGREE WITH THE
MALL AND SEEN THE THE ISSUES AND
SEISMIC ISSUES CERTAINLY AT THAT
UC BERKELEY AND HERE DAVIS AN
AGING CAMPUS AND SANTA BARBARA
WOULD HAVE USE THAT.
WE ALWAYS GET APPLES AND ORANGES
AS FAR AS THE INFORMATION WHO IS
THE WHO HAS THE MOST AND SEISMIC
IS THE MOST AND DEFERRED HOW
MUCH WE NEED HERE HOW MUCH NEED
THERE AND SO -- AND EVERY YOU
KNOW WE ASK ABOUT THIS WEEK CAN
I GET A PHONE BOOK AB SPREAD
SHEETS OF THE PROJECTS WHICH IS.
INTERESTING I'M AT SHIRT HELPFUL
FOR US INTO FIGURING OUT THE
MAGNITUDE AND TO PRIORITIZE. TO
PRIORITIZE THIS ISSUE -- AND YOU
KNOW I THINK THAT WE NEED TO GET
A HOLD OF THIS AND HAVE COME UP
WITH A PLAN I THINK WE'RE VERY.
AGGRESSIVE OUR HOSPITAL SYSTEM
ACROSS CALIFORNIA INCLUDING ARE
YOU SEE HOSPITALS BUT SHE WAS
SEISMIC.
WE KNOW THAT HEY IF YOU DON'T
HAVE THESE -- IMPROVEMENTS MADE
BY BY THIS YEAR YOU CAN'T
OPERATE IN THE STAKES ARE SUPER
HIGH OF COURSE FOR OUR HOSPITALS
AROUND CALIFORNIA -- YOU KNOW
WITH A SERVE DON'T HAVE THE SAME
URGENCY FOR OUR UNIVERSITY --
SYSTEM AND YOU KNOW WE DON'T
WANT THAT A TRAGEDY TO HAPPEN TO
TO MAKE US WAKE UP TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT SO.
THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT --
THAT -- WE WE ARE INTERESTED IN --
I KNOW WE HAVE SOME.
KIND OF A MATCHING ISSUE COMING
UP ON ENROLLMENT SO WON'T DIG
INTO THE WEEDS TOO MUCH SO WAIT
FOR THAT.
BUT WITH THAT -- AND GO BACK TO
MISTER MARTZ SEARCHING THANK YOU
I WANTED -- TO AS MISS VIRGIN
AND WHEN OTHER -- ITEM.
THE I I I I KNOW YOUR YOUR
REQUEST WAS -- TO TO KEEP THE
COMMITMENT THAT WE HAD MADE.
IN THE LAST BUDGET YEAR -- TO TO
COMMIT ONGOING FUNDS THAT GUY
GOVERNOR BROWN -- AND MADE ONE
TIME FUNDS THAT AT THAT'S THE
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
TO ADVISE REQUEST OKAY AND AND
COULD YOU WERE.
A EXPLAIN TO ME AGAIN LIKE.
WHY THE GOVERNOR IS -- ALSO DOES
NOT ADDRESS THE NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR ON GOING GENERAL
FUND.
I REQUEST.
I'M NOT CERTAIN WHY THE GOVERNOR
DIDN'T INCLUDE THOSE FUNDS IN
HIS YOU SEE AND SEVENTY MILLION
OF THAT WAS FOR A TUITION BY OUT.
OF WHICH HAS BEEN PARTLY USED TO
FUND OF PERMANENT FACULTY AT
SEVERAL CAMPUSES -- AND WE WE
VERY MUCH HOPE THAT THE
UNIVERSITIES NEED WILL BE
RECOGNIZED THE GOVERNOR AND HIS
BUDGET.
OF FUNDED MANY OF OUR MANDATORY
COST INCREASES IN LABOR AND
HEALTH COSTS SO IT APPEARS THAT
HE PUT HIS EMPHASIS IN THAT AREA
[inaudible]
HOWEVER [inaudible]
OF THE FUNDING THAT THE GOVERNOR
PROVIDED TO US IS NOT SUFFICIENT
TO BOTH PAY FOR OUR NEW
MANDATORY COSTS.
ARE DEBT SERVICE CAPITAL OUTLAY
DOT SERVICE INCREASES AND TO
FUND THE FACULTY TO HAVE BEEN
HIRED WITH THE NINETY FIVE
MILLION SO.
IF WE DON'T GET THE NINETY FIVE
MILLION WILL ACTUALLY BE IN A
POSITION TO HAVE TO DO CUTS ON
OUR CAMPUSES DESPITE THIS
HISTORICAL INCREASE THAT WE
RECEIVED.
SERVICE OF THESE ARE THERE ARE
NEW ON GOING COSTS THAT -- THAT
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIANS
TAKEN ON WHERE THERE IS NO.
LINE ITEM IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS THOSE
ONGOING COSTS IS THAT.
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROVIDED US
WITH THE FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE
LABOR CONTRACT INCREASES AND THE
UC OUR P. AND THE HEALTH.
INCREASES BUT WE DID NOT GET THE
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR CAPITAL
OUTLAY BOND DEBT SERVICE
INCREASE.
AND WE DIDN'T GET THE OF FUNDING
FOR THE WE DIDN'T GET THE NINETY
FIVE MILLION FROM THE CURRENT
YEAR ON GOING WHICH WE WERE
HOPING. TO RECEIVE BECAUSE IT'S
PAYING FOR PERMANENT INSTRUCTORS
AND STUDENTS WHO ARE HERE SO.
WE'RE WE'RE USING IT FOR
ACADEMIC QUALITY TO ENSURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS HAVE THE CLASSES
AVAILABLE SO THEY CAN GRADUATE
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
DIZZY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OF
RESPONSE YES THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET MAY REVISIONS INFORMED BY --
THE FIRST ADDRESSING THE MOST
PRESSING NEED TO THE UNIVERSITY
WHICH IS AGAIN WHY.
ARE PROPOSAL -- COVERS THEIR
MASTER LABOR COSTS -- HEALTH
COSTS AND OTHER FACTORS THE
SECOND IS THAT THE HUNDRED FIVE
MILLION THAT WAS PROVIDED TO YOU
SEE IN THE CURRENT YEAR WAS
IDENTIFIED AS BEING A SOURCE OF
ONE TIME FUNDS.
THE THIRD IS THAT YOU SEE HAS A
MULTIPLE FUNDING STREAMS BY
WHICH IT CAN IT CAN ADDRESS IT'S
CASA MAKE PRICE YOU SHIFT ITS
PRIORITIES INCLUDING NON
RESIDENT TUITION IDENTIFIED
SAVINGS IN ITS PROCUREMENT.
AND OTHER SOURCES THAT IS --
THAT ARE IDENTIFIED AND AND THAT
TELEPHONE BOOK SO THOSE THREE
FACETS ADDRESSING THE MOST
NECESSARY COSTS --CONTINUING
THAT THE EXPECTATION THAT THOSE
FUNDS WERE PROVIDED ONE TIME AND
A LINE YOU SEE TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT WHAT A PRIVATE WHEN IT
NEEDS TO PRIORITIZE.
BASED ON ITS MULTIPLE FUNDING
STREAMS IS ALL OF THE THIS IS
SERVICE SEVERAL PIECES THAT
INFORMED.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS PACKAGE.
BUT AGAIN WE'RE RELYING ON AS
YOU INDICATED IN PART. ONE OF
THE MEASURE ALTERNATIVE SOURCES
OF FUNDING -- FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE. TO CONTINUE
RELY ON THE NON RESIDENT TUITION
REVENUES ONE REVENUE SOURCE OF
THE IDENTIFIED IN THE CLASS OF
PLAN FOR CURRENT OPERATIONS WAS
AN INCREASE IN NON RESIDENT AND
ROMAN.
I EXCUSE ME WE ARE RESIDENT
TUITION.
AND THOSE FUNDS -- I BELIEVE THE
REGION'S WILL BE VOTING ON THIS
WEEK.
IN TERMS OF INCREASING THE TO IT
THE NON RESIDENT TUITION THAT'S
RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YEAH.
ALL I WILL ASK QUESTIONS OF THAT
THE SECOND TWO BUT I DID JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY -- WE WE JUST
GOT A NOTE FROM THE LA YOU KNOW
THAT.
THE AMOUNT FOR CAL GRANT AND
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP FROM
THE GENERAL FUND THREE CITY
COMMISSION BACK TO YOU SEE IS
ONE POINT ONE BILLION.
SO IT'S SEVERAL HUNDRED MILLION
SO GRANTED I'M NOT SAYING THAT
GIVES US A PASS BUT I'M SAYING
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE THAT INTO A
TALLY IN EVERY TIME YOU SEE
COMES UP HERE AND SAYS -- IT
BASICALLY THAT THAT'S HALF TRUTH
AND SO I THINK WE NEED. TO TO
FOCUS ON THE TOTAL PICTURE OF OF
THE STATE MONEY.
GOING TO HELP OURGREAT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
THANK YOU MISTER CARR EVAN OFF A
BUDGET FOR A COUPLE YEARS THAT'S
KAY.
THANK YOU -- BUT THAT.
WINDOW -- HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
AND HAVE A FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
YOU SEE ENROLLMENT AND
SPECIFICALLY THE NON RESIDENT
ISSUE.
WITH THE NON RESIDENT IN ROMAN
REPORT WHICH WAS SUBMITTED TO
THE LEGISLATURE -- A FEW --
WEEKS AGO -- WHICH WAS
PREDICATED ON LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
ACTION ASKING THE SEATED TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT COULD BE DONE. TO
TO GO BACK IN AND LOWER THE
AMOUNT OF NON RESIDENT STUDENTS
AND CONVERSELY ENROLL MORE.
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DAVID ALCOCER.
AND THE ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT
FOR BUDGET ANALYSIS AND PLANNING
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY
TO DISCUSS THE REPORT SUBMITTED
BY THE UNIVERSITY IN RESPONSE TO
A REQUEST.
IN THE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT IF
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT.
DESCRIBES THE IMPACT OF REDUCING
THE ENROLLMENT OF NON RESIDENT
FRESHMEN STUDENTS TO NO MORE
THAN 10%.
OF THE FRESHMAN CLASS AT EVERY
UC CAMPUS BY THE TWENTY TWENTY
NINE THIRTY ACADEMIC YEAR.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A HAND UP
TODAY THAT'LL BE REFERENCING --
ON SLIDE TO MY COMMENTS TODAY
WILL FOCUS ON THE ESTIMATED
FINANCIAL IMPACT OF REDUCING NON
RESIDENT ENROLLMENT.
I DO NOT MEAN TO DISCOUNT THE
EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS OF LEARNING
AND LIVING ALONGSIDE STUDENTS
FROM OTHER STATES COUNTRIES AND
CULTURES.
BUT THE FINANCIAL ASPECTS OF THE
PROPOSAL SEEM MOST RELEVANT TO
THIS COMMITTEES DISCUSSIONS
TODAY.
AND REALLY ARE THE FOCUS OF THE
REPORT.
WE LOOK AT FOR AREAS A FINANCIAL
IMPACT.
FIRST THE ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDING THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO SUPPORT HIGHER LEVELS OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT ENROLLMENT.
TO FILL THE SEATS THAT WOULD
BECOME VACANT.
AS NON RESIDENT ENROLLMENT
DECLINES.
WE ASSUME THAT'S KEY TO THIS
PROPOSED POLICY THAT THE GOAL IS
NOT TO REDUCE NON RESIDENT
ENROLLMENT FOR ITS OWN SAKE.
BUT TO DO SO IN ORDER TO ENROLL
EVEN MORE CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
STUDENTS.
SECOND WE ESTIMATE THE REVENUE
FROM NON RESIDENT TUITION THAT
WOULD NEED TO BE REPLACED UNDER
THE SCENARIO.
AFTER TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THAT I JUST
MENTIONED.
WE ALSO EXPECT INCREASED DEMAND
FOR FINANCIAL AID FROM UC'S ON
INSTITUTIONAL IN PROGRAM.
SINCE NON RESIDENTS WERE
INELIGIBLE FOR YOU SEE GRANTS
WOULD BE REPLACED BY NEW
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
WHO LIKE OUR CURRENT STUDENTS
OFTEN RELY ON YOU SEE GRANTS TO
FINANCE THEIR EDUCATION?
FINALLY IN ROLLING MORE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WITH
FINANCIAL NEED WOULD ALSO
INCREASE AWARDS FROM THE STATE'S
CAL GRANT PROGRAM.
I DISPLAY THREE SHOWS THE
COMBINED MAGNITUDE OF THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF REDUCING NONRESIDENT
ENROLLMENT.
IN EACH OF THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
IN THE FIRST YEAR AS YOU CAN SEE
THE COMBINED IMPACT WOULD BE
RELATIVELY SMALL.
ABOUT EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
BUT WOULD QUICKLY GROW AND WOULD
ADD ABOUT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
NEW FUNDING NEEDS BY THE YEAR --
TWENTY NINE TWENTY TWENTY NINE
THIRTY THE CUMULATIVE COST OF
THE TEN YEAR PERIOD WOULD EXCEED
FOUR POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
I WANT TO NOTE THAT THESE
FIGURES ARE IN ADDITION TO THE
STATE FUNDING NEEDED FOR CATS
Và HORNET RESIDENT ENROLLMENT
GROWTH.
THAT WE ARE ALREADY ASSUMING
EVEN WITHOUT THIS POLICY CHANGE.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY AS YOU KNOW
WE ARE REQUESTING TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS A TREATABLE TO
CALIFORNIA ENROLLMENT GROWTH OF
TWENTY FIVE CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATES NEXT YEAR THAT'S
BUILT INTO A NINETEEN TWENTY
PLAN.
I'D LIKE TO NOW DESCRIBE SOME OF
THE PROJECTIONS FOR ENROLLMENT
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND FUTURE
YEARS THAT UNDERLIE THESE
ESTIMATES.
TURNING TO SLIDE.
FOR A TO DEVELOP THE ESTIMATES
THAT YOU SEE HERE -- WE COMPARED
ESTIMATED IN ROMANS AGAINST A
BASE CASE ENROLLMENTS AREA.
THAT WE THINK REPRESENTS A
REASONABLE LEVEL OF ENROLLMENT
GROWTH TO EXPECT OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS.
IT IS BY NECESSITY AN ESTIMATE
SINCE CAMPUS DO NOT HAVE FULLY
DEVELOPED TENURE ENROLLMENT
PLANS.
SO WHAT WE DID WAS WE ASSUMED AN
ANNUAL INCREASE OF ABOUT 1% IN
CALIFORNIA AND ROMAN ACROSS THE
SYSTEM EACH YEAR.
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS CAMPUS IS
BASED ON RECENT GROWTH TRENDS.
WE ALSO SING THE CAMPUSES WOULD
MAINTAIN A TWO TO ONE FRESHMEN
TO TRANSFER RATIO AMONG NEW
STUDENTS.
AND THAT NON RESIDENT ENROLLMENT
WOULD INCREASE GRADUALLY AMONG
CAMPUSES THAT HAVEN'T ALREADY
HITTHEIR NON RESIDENT
ENROLLMENT CAP UNDER A REGION'S
POLICY.
WE CAN COMPARE THAT BASE CASE
SCENARIO AGAINST A 10% SCENARIO
WERE NEW NONRESIDENT FRESHMAN
GRADUALLY FALL 210% OF INCOMING
FRESHMEN BY.
TWENTY NINE DISPLAY FIVE SHOWS
THE ROMAN PROJECTIONS THAT
RESULT UNDER BOTH AREAS.
UNDER THE BASE CASE SCENARIO
FROM FIRST YOU CAN SEE THAT
TOTAL RESIDENT ENROLLMENT.
PROS FOR ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED NINETY NINE THOUSAND AND
TWENTY NINE THIRTY A GROWTH OF
ABOUT SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
YOU'RE ON THAT DISPLAY FIVE
DISPLAY FIVE THAT'S RIGHT YOU'LL
SEE THE THAT THE TOP PART BASE
CASE THERE'S A SECTION THERE FOR
TOTAL ENROLLMENT.
AND YOU CAN SEE THE CATTLE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT CORRECT
COMING FROM.
ONE NINETY TWO TO ONE NINETY
NINE UNDER THE 10% IN ARE YOU
FROM BELOW.
NON RESIDENTS DECLINE FROM 19%.
OF THE INCOMING FRESHMEN CLASS
IN. 2021210% AND TWENTY NINE
THIRTY UNDER THIS SCENARIO TOTAL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT CLOSE BY
ABOUT THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND OVER
THIS PERIOD.
BUT AS WE SHOULD EARLIER THAT
HIGHER GROWTH COMES AT A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL POSSIBLE TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MORE
[inaudible]
DISPLAY.
SIX FOCUSES ON THAT CHANGE IN
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND ROMAN
UNDER BOTH SCENARIOS AND THE
COST THE INCREMENTAL COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THE 10%.
ONE HERE YOU CAN SEE THE IMPACT
OF THE 10% SCENARIO ON
CALIFORNIAN ROMAN EACH YEAR
COMPARED TO THE BASE CASE.
SUGG THE BASE CASE IS GOING UP
BY TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED A YEAR.
ACTUALLY THE THE BASE CASES BYE
BYE OVER THIS PERIOD WE SAID 1%
A YEAR.
WHAT'S THAT WHICH IS ABOUT
NINETEEN HUNDRED OR SO ON
AVERAGE.
AND AGAIN THESE ARE BASED ON A
REASONABLE PROJECTION NOT NOT ON
CAMPUS SPECIFIC PLANS ADDRESS
THOSE DON'T ACTUALLY EXIST.
SO THAT'S THE BASE CASE -- THEN
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ADDITIONAL
AROMA THAT YOU SEE UNDER THE 10%
SCENARIO -- YOU'LL SEE THAT IT
GROWS EACH YEAR IT'S DROPS OFF
RELATIVELY MODEST BUT IS A MUCH
LARGER BY THE TIME YOU GET.
TWENTY NINE THIRTY WE ALSO SHOW
THEM THE ADDITIONAL COSTS OF
THAT 10% SCENARIO AND IT HERE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT.
THIS IS THE COST IN ADDITION TO
THE ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
AND BASS BUT ADJUSTMENTS THAT
ARE ALREADY BUILT INTO THAT BASE
CASE.
THIS IS ON TOP OF THAT.
ARE THE STATE WOULD NEED TO
INVEST AND AND WE CAN BE
BASICALLY LOOK AT WHAT IS THAT
INCREMENTAL CALIFORNIAN ROMAN.
THE FOUR HUNDRED FORTY THREE
STUDENTS IN THE FIRST YEAR WHICH
THEN GROWS. TO THE INCREMENTAL
COST UNDER THE PLAN.
AND YOU'LL SEE THAT THE STATE
WOULD NEED TO INVEST ABOUT FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER STUDENT AT
THE START OF THE PLAN.
RISING TO ALMOST FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND BY THE END.
THAT'S THE COMBINED IMPACT.
OF THE MARGINAL COST OF IN
ROWING ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
OF REPLACING THE LOS NONRESIDENT
TUITION.
AND FUNDING THE ADDITIONAL UC
GRANTS AND CAL GRANTS TO
PRESERVE AFFORDABILITY FOR THE
STUDENTS.
IF THE COST WERE NOT FULLY
COVERED BY ADDITIONAL STATE
SUPPORT THERE WOULD BE REAL
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES TO
CAMPUSES AND STUDENTS.
AS NOTED IN THE REPORT ITSELF
NOT REPLACING THE LOST INTEREST
HE REVENUE AT BERKELEY FOR
EXAMPLE WOULD LEAVE THAT CAMPUS
WITH ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO MILLION DOLLAR SHORTFALL.
IN TWENTY NINE THIRTY ALONE.
THAT'S EQUIVALENT TO THE SALARY
AND BENEFITS FOR SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE FULL TIME FACULTY
POSITIONS.
IF FUNDING WERE NOT PROVIDED FOR
YOU SEE GRANTS FOR CAL GRANTS
THE IMPACT WOULD BE FELT ON
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT STUDENTS
THROUGH HIGHER LEVELS OF STUDENT
DEBT.
I HOPE THAT PROVIDES A
SUBCOMMITTEE WITH SOME HELPFUL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE REPORT AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
OKAY.
SO ON THE SCENARIO OF COST PER
STUDENT.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT IN A FOR
EVERY STUDENTS THAT WE DO THIS
CHANGES ADDITIONAL. FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ROUGHLY THAT'S
RIGHT YEAH.
SO YOU SOMEONE SOMEONE PROBABLY
THE FLIP SIDE THAT HE BE.
YOU WOULD ARGUE BE BETTER OFF TO
FOCUS ON THE EXISTING.
KAPOR RATIO AND FUN ADDITIONAL
CALIFORNIAN ROMAN CROSS YOU GET
MORE BANG FOR YOUR BUCK YEAH I
THINK THE QUESTION THIS THIS
BEGS IS EXACTLY THAT SORT OF
WHAT'S THE THE BEST USE FOR
THOSE FUNDS -- IS IT TO FULLY
FUND -- BETWEEN SURE THAT WE CAN
FIND -- ADEQUATE LEVELS OF
CALIFORNIAN GROWTH EVEN WITHOUT
TO THIS REDUCTION AND NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS -- IS IT TO
HELP RESTORE SOME OF THE
INDICATORS OF ACADEMIC QUALITY
THAT WE'VE SEEN WHICH I KNOW
HAVE BEEN PRESENTED TO THIS
COMMITTEE BEFORE -- THINGS LIKE --
DECLINING A STUDENT SATISFACTION
WITH THEIR EXPERIENCE THAT YOU
SEE INCREASED DIFFICULTY IN
GETTING TO THE MAJORS THAT THEY
WANT.
OTHER ISSUES WAS RELATED TO
ACADEMIC -- SUPPORT AND
THROUGHPUT AND STUDENT SUCCESS
SO THERE'S ONE I THINK FLYING
ALL THIS IS WE NEED AS WE KNOW.
WE DO HEAR FROM EXISTING YOU SEE
STUDENTS COME UP HERE AND SAY
HEY IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT GETTING.
MY LITTLE SISTER IN THE SEATS
ABOUT MAKING SURE I HAVE A PLACE
TO GO STUDY AND I CAN GET MY
COURSE OFFERING AND I HAVE A
PLACE TO LIVE AND ALL JUST TO
JUST THE BASICS AND SO.
THE CURRENT POLICY WE HAVE THIS --
SO CALLED CAP IT'S REALLY A
RATIO SO IT'S THAT ONE TO FOUR
RATIO FOR EVERY. 20% REQUEST
RATIO SO FOR EVERYONE -- NON
RESIDENT YOU NEED TO ENROLL --
FOR CALIFORNIA KIDS RIGHT CENTER
THAT'S THE MATH RIGHT YEAH AND
SO -- THAT DIDN'T DIDN'T THE
NOTION.
OF THAT IN IN YOUR ARGUING FOR
THE UC I WOULD THINK THAT NOW WE
SHOULD JUST CONTINUE THE CURRENT
POLICY.
AND FIND MORE ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
BUT THAT -- ASSUMES THAT THERE
IS CAPACITY TO CONTINUE TO GROW
AND AND AND THIS POLICY.
WOULD WOULD WOULD DEAL WITH THE
PHYSICAL SPACE ISSUE RIGHT
BECAUSE THE REGARDLESS OF MONEY
THERE'S A DOES THAT JUST A NOTE
HOW MNY SEATS YOU HAVE IN THIS.
IN THIS ROOM RIGHT NOW RIGHT.
AND SO.
DOES THAT TAKEN TO CONSIDER THAT
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THAT
ISSUE.
WELL YES I THINK IT DOES SORT OF
RAISE THE QUESTION OF WHAT'S THE
MOST EFFECTIVE LONG TERM WAY TO
DEAL WITH SPACE CONSTRAINTS AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
IS IT TO ADDITIONAL NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS AND THEIR BY CREATING
SOME SPACE WITH AN EXISTING
FACILITY.
WITH THEIR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ISSUES WITH THEIR SIZE MATTRESS
AT CETERA UP OR IS IT TO INVEST
IN LONG TERM GROWTH OF
FACILITIES THROUGH WHETHER IT'S
A GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND OR
JUST SUPPORT FOR THE UNIVERSITY
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SOME OF ITS
OWN CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS AND
EXPANSION.
USING THE AB NINETY FOUR PROCESS
UP IF IF WE THINK SORT OF
STRATEGICALLY NOT JUST DURING
THIS TEN YEAR PERIOD BUT EVEN
BEYOND UP WHAT'S THE RIGHT LONG
TERM WAY TO ADDRESS WHAT WILL BE
LONG TERM NEEDS AROUND CAPACITY
AT THE UNIVERSITY.
AND THEN I REALIZE THAT -- YOU
KNOW I I WOULD LIKE NOTHING MORE
THAN TO TO DO THIS TO GO BACK TO
THE POLICY.
THAT WE HAD IN -- BASICALLY IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WE HAD ABOUT
A 10% NON RESIDENT GROWTH AND I
FLATLY REJECT THE NOTION THAT
WE'RE DOING THIS FOR MORE.
DIVERSITY BECAUSE FOR A HUNDRED
FIFTY YEARS YOU SEE WAS TOTALLY
GREAT WITH EXISTING GREAT
DIVERSITY FROM.
FRANKLY THE CALIFORNIA DIVERSITY --
SO THIS IS ALL ABOUT SIMPLE MY
SIMPLE NOT ECONOMICS IN OUT YOU
HAD TO DO THIS TO KEEP.
THE LIGHTS ON DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION AND WE GET THAT AND SO
I THINK ONE OF THE THE GREATEST
PUSH BACKS THAT THE WILL THE
WITH THE WILL PUT OUT IS THAT.
EVEN AFTER WE STARTED GIVING.
EIGHT SUMS OF MONEY THE LAST
FIVE YEARS -- MAYBE AS MUCH AS
YOU SEE WAS ASKING FOR YOUR
BUDGET REQUEST BUT WELL WELL
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS.
THESE NON RESIDENT NUMBERS KEPT
GOING UP AND UP AND UP AND I
THINK AT SOME POINT THE POLICY.
WAS -- WAS ENOUGH AND AND THAT'S
KINDA -- THE FOCUS ON BUT BUT
THE ISSUE HERE THOUGH IS THAT
YOU KNOW EVEN IF WE DID GO BACK --
AND SOMEHOW MANAGED TO TO
LEVERAGE AT THE HIGH LEVERAGE
SITUATION IN THE NEXT LET'S SAY
FOUR YEARS TO GET UP TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION A YEAR.
IF WE DID THAT THAT'S THAT'S AT
THE EXPENSE OF SOMETHING ELSE
RIGHT THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE WE WOULDN'T HAVE THAT.
TO TO FOCUS ON OUR DEBT FREE
COLLEGE PLAN TO DRESS FINANCIAL
AID TO POTENTIALLY MAKE SURE WE
ADDRESS THE USE THE UC ISSUE SO
THERE IS A RISK INVOLVED HERE WE
WE WE OUGHT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED.
TO CERTAINLY -- EVALUATE --
WELCOME BACK IN A SEC BUT FOR
NOW MISTER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- MISTER OCT OFFICER
YES.
SO -- BOTTOM LINE IT IN THIS
REPORT YOU'RE YOU'RE SAYING THAT --
IN ORDER -- FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO ENGAGE IN A TEN
YEAR PLAN.
TO GET US BACK -- TO NO MORE
THAN 10%.
SYSTEM WIDE OF A NON RESIDENTS
THEY WOULD COST FOUR POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S CORRECT -- NAY BUT THAT.
BUILT INTO THAT NUMBER ARE YOUR
ASSUMPTIONS THAT YOU STARTED OUT
WITH -- THAT -- NG INCLUDING THE
THE ADDITIONAL COSTS OF YOU SEE
FINANCIAL AID AND INCREASED
COSTS OF CAL GRANTS AS WELL AS A
LOSS OF NON RESIDENT TUITION.
AND FUNDING ADDITIONAL
CALIFORNIA GROWTH THAT'S CORRECT
OKAY -- A A YOU KNOW I MEAN I I
I HAVE TO ADMIT I I I ALWAYS
FEEL THAT.
I OFTEN FEEL THAT WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA --
BUDGET REQUEST THAT YOU KNOW
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY MOVING
PIECES THAT IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S
HARD FOR ME TO GET A YOU KNOW.
MM MM PERHAPS I YOU KNOW I I
NEED TO HEAR -- YOU KNOW AND AND
PERHAPS HAVE HAVE A SEPARATE
MEETING IN TERMS TO TRY TO DIVE
INTO.
POTENTIAL ALTERNATES INTO THESE
NUMBERS BUT I'M I'M LOOKING AT
THE THE STAFF A AND NOW SAYS FOR
TODAY'S COMMITTEE HEARING AND
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT THERE
THERE'S TO SISTER CAN HEAR THAT
KIND OF JUMPS OUT TO ME THAT --
THAT IN AS RECENTLY AS JUST TEN
YEARS AGO 200-082-0009 ACADEMIC
YEAR.
SYSTEM WIDE THE NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS WERE ONLY ABOUT 5%.
OF OUR OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND AND AND TODAY -- WORK OR
ABOUT 18%.
AND SO I I JUST HAVE A HARD TIME.
YOU KNOW.
UNDERSTANDING WHY WE WOULD.
YOU KNOW IT NOT IN THE NOT EVEN
TO GET BACK TO WHERE WE WERE TEN
YEARS AGO BUT BUT TO GET. 210%.
OF NON RESIDENT STUDENTS THAT IT
WOULD COST A FOUR POINT TWO IT
WILL BE A FOUR POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLAR OBLIGATION ECLIPSING THE
ENTIRE -- YOU KNOW STATE GENERAL
FUND BUDGET FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM ME JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME.
SO REMEMBER SOMETHING ARE MEANT
CITY THE AMONG THE FOUR POINT
TWO MILLION FIGURE IS NOT.
THE ANNUAL INCREASE IN THAT LAST
YEAR IT'S THE IT'S THE SOME OF
THE ANNUAL INCOME SAYS ALONG THE
WAY THANK YOU -- SECONDLY YOU
KNOW WE THIS ACTUALLY -- HARKENS
BACK TO A COMMENT YOU MADE
EARLIER. ONE WAY TO THINK ABOUT --
WHY EVERYONE IN THE CLOCK IN
SUCH A SENS IS SO EXPENSIVE IS
BECAUSE AS WE DISCUSSED EARLIER
PART OF THAT GROWTH AND NON
RESIDENT ROMAN I THINK A LARGE
PART OF IT WAS?
AS CHAIR MCCARTY MENTIONED IN
RESPONSE TO FUNDING SHORTFALLS
AT THE CAMPUSES.
AND SO ON DOING THAT.
INCLUDES NOT JUST FUNDING THE
COST OF EDUCATING A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT IN LIEU OF THAT NON
RESIDENT BUT IN ESSENCE.
UNDOING THE SUBSIDY FROM NON
RESIDENTS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING SINCE THEN RIGHT SO
IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S ESSENTIALLY
DOING WHAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER -- BUYING RULING A
DIFFERENT MIX OF STUDENTS -- AND
IT IS PRICEY BECAUSE WE'RE
ESSENTIALLY -- REDUCING THE
SUBSIDY THAT THE UNIVERSITY IS
ALREADY GETTING FROM NON
RESIDENTS AND ESSENTIALLY
REPLACING THAT WITH STATE
TAXPAYER SUBSIDY.
YEAH THERE IS SO AND SO I I I
GET THE BASIC PICTURE THAT --
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO REDUCE
OR INCREASE THE PROCESS THE THE
PROPORTION OF CALIFORNIA KIDS
ATTENDING A UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM THAT IT WOULD.
TAKE GREATER -- STATE GENERAL
FUND INVESTMENTS -- YEAH I I'M
I'M JUST.
TO A LITTLE HEALTHY SKEPTICISM
ABOUT THIS FOUR POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR -- PRICE TAG TO
TO COMP CYCLE -- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION.
YEAH I JUST THINK THAT
ILLUMINATES HOW MUCH WE WE
CHARGE FOR NON RESIDENT ROMAN
AND I SUPPORT THAT MEASURE FOR
THE REGION'S THIS WEEK I THINK
IT'S THAT THE SOUND ONE I THINK
THERE'S YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY.
MORE -- YOU KNOW -- MORE ANGST
FROM YOUR STUDENT POPULATION
ABOUT THIS BUT THAT'S PROBABLY
BECAUSE YOU KNOW TEN YEARS AGO
YOU SAID IT WAS ONLY 5% NON
RESIDENTS NOW IS 20% OF MORE THE
STUDENTS ARE PART OF YOUR
CONSTITUENCY.
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT IS
THAT EVEN AS WE'VE INCREASE
ENROLLMENT -- I'M SORRY EVEN AS
WE MAKE CREASE THE NON RESIDENT --
TUITION A NUMBER OF THE NUMBER
OF APPLICATIONS FROM THE UC.
INTERNATIONALLY AND ACROSS THE
THAT THE THAT THE US CON
CONTINENTAL UNITED STATES -- HAS
INCREASED CORRECT.
THAT IS CORRECT YEAH WHAT WHAT
ARE THE NUMBERS ON ON THAT AS
FAR AS THE THAT THE STUDY --
CLIP OF NON RESIDENT SUPPLYING.
OUT WELL WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
TRENDS BOTH IN APPLICATIONS AS
WELL AS IN YIELD RATES.
WE DON'T SEE MUCH CHANGE OVER
THE COURSE OF THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS EVEN WHEN WE DID HAVE --
INCREASES IN ON RESIDENTS OF MEL
TUITION -- RE ANECDOTALLY WE WE
KNOW THAT CAMPUSES ARE CONCERNED
AS TO AT WHAT RATE COULD WE
CONTINUE TO INCREASE -- NON
RESIDENT TUITION WITHOUT SAYING
A DROP OFF IN APPLICANTS.
AND AS YOU KNOW IN ORDER TO BE
ADMITTED TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CAP FROM THE CAMPUS OF THOSE NON
RESIDENTS NEED TO COMPARE
FAVORABLY TO THE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS WERE AT THAT CAN SO
IT'S A IT'S A HIGH BAR -- WE DO
THINK THAT THE PLAN THAT'S BEING
PRESENTED TO THE REGENTS A
TOMORROW.
AT WHICH IS TO ESSENTIALLY KEEP
THAT INCREASE PEGGED GENERALLY
TO THE RATE OF INFLATION WHICH
BASICALLY HOLES AT FLAT AND
CONSTANT DOLLARS -- BOTH
PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED REVENUE
WITHOUT PROVIDING A MATERIAL A
BARRIER TO ENROLLMENT OR TO
SUCCESS FOR THOSE NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS WE ALREADY HAVE.
AND THAT KIND OF AN INFLATION
BASED ADJUSTMENT IS BUILT INTO
THE LONG TERM FUNDING PLAN THAT
WE SHARED WITH THE REGION'S IN
MARCH.
WE WE HAVE -- INCREASED IT BY A
GREATER RATES IN THE PAST.
WHEN WE LOOKED TO SEE AND THIS
IS MENTIONED IN THE REPORT --
WHAT KIND OF INCREASES WOULD BE
NECESSARY -- AMONGST OUR SMALLER
POPULATION OF NON RESIDENTS IF
WE WERE TO REDUCE IT.
IN ORDER TO COMPENSATE FOR THE
LOST NONRESIDENT REVENUE IT
WOULD REQUIRE YEAR OVER YEAR
INCREASES OF ABOUT 7% -- FOR
THIS THE TEN YEAR PERIOD.
IT WOULD MAKE THE TUITION
INCLUDING NOT JUST NON RESIDENT
TUITION BUT BASS TUITION A
BECAUSE THE SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FOR NON
RESIDENTS.
RIDLEY ALREADY WHEN YOU LOOK AT
OUR TUITION AS WELL OF COST OF
LIVING -- MANY OF OUR CAMPUSES
ARE AMONG THE MOST EXPENSIVE FOR
NON RESIDENTS IN THE COUNTRY A
MERCED RIVERSIDE SEVERAL OTHERS
ARE MORE EXPENSIVE THAN THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN.
THEN THE UNIVERSITY OF VIRGINIA --
SO WE ARE MINDFUL OF AT WHAT
POINT DO WE TIP THE SCALES AND
AND SEE THAT.
WE IN FACT ARE DRIVING STUDENTS
AWAY AND WE CAN'T ACTUALLY SO
THE THE 10%.
PROPOSAL FOR TOMORROW. 10% NON
RESIDENT TUITION INCREASE EVERY
SENSE IT'S A IT'S A NO IT'S A
IT'S A TWO POINT 6%. TO POINTS
RIGHT IT'S AN INFLATION BASED
INVESTMENT THAT YOU'RE AN
EXTRINSIC DALY SAID WHAT WHAT
WAS IS WHAT YOU SAY 10% THEN.
I'D I'D A DID I I DON'T OKAY I
DIDN'T MEAN TO IF I DID I HAVE
YET [inaudible]
OKAY AT SO YES IT WOULD I
SUPPORT THAT WE THE WAY I THINK
WE SUPPORT THAT -- THE
CONSCIOUSNESS WE'VE HAD WAS YOU
KNOW LEADERSHIP HERE AND
LEGISLATURE ON THIS ISSUE -- IN
THE SUMMER SAID OF COURSE.
CAN SPEAK FOR THE SENATE. ONE
THING THAT THAT I WOULD YOU WANT
TO RAISE THE NOTION OF THE
FINANCIAL AID.
AND THE YOU KNOW.
A FEW YEARS AGO WE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION AS FAR AS THE THE
UC.
THE RETURN THE RETURN EIGHT ON
TUITION A THIRD OF THE TUITION
GOES BACK FOR FOR FINANCIAL AID.
AND YOU'RE USING SOME OF THAT
FOR TO GET FINANCIAL AID FOR NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS AND YOU KNOW
WE THOUGHT THAT WAS.
INAPPROPRIATE SO DID -- THAT THE
CONCLUSION WITH WITH THAT YOU
YOU SEE LEADERSHIP AND YOU'RE
LOOKING TO TO GO BACK AND AND
UNRAVEL THAT ARRANGEMENT SO CAN
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT -- YES I
WOULDN'T CHARACTERIZE IT THAT
WAY BUT IT WOULD BE HEARD LOUD
AND CLEAR FROM THE LEGISLATURE
WAS THAT -- TUITION THE BASE FEE
PAID BY ALL STUDENTS INCLUDING
NON RESIDENTS A PORTION OF THAT
WAS BEING USED TO REDUCE --
FINANCIAL BURDENS ON NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS AND THAT THERE
IS A HIGHER BETTER USE FOR THOSE
DOLLARS WHICH IS TO SUPPORT
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
AND WE MADE THAT -- CHANGE AND
HAVE BEEN PHASING OUT THE
STUDENTS ELIGIBILITY FOR THAT --
EVER SINCE THE ENTERING CLASS OF
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THE ISSUE
THAT'S ON THE TABLE NOW IS ONLY
ABOUT THE MARGINAL.
NONRESIDENT TUITION REVENUE NOT
THE BASE TUITION AVENUE BUT THE
MARGINAL WE CALL AND R. S. T..
THAT WOULD BE DERIVED FROM THE
PROPOSED INCREASE.
FROM FROM FROM THIS SMALL TWO
POINT 6% ACCESS.
AND 7% OF THIS 2% INTEREST SO
NOT A DIFFERENT BEFORE BECAUSE
THAT WAS THE FINANCIAL AID
OVERALL FOR EVERYBODY YOU'RE
USING SOME OF THAT TO FOCUS ON
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS THAT'S
CORRECT SO ONE WAY TO THINK
ABOUT THIS IS THAT -- UNIVERSE
ACTUALLY PROPOSING AT A SEVEN
HUNDRED SIXTY DOT TWO DOLLAR
INCREASE FOR A NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS -- IN TO A SMALL EXTENT.
SOME OF THOSE NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS WILL BE CONTRIBUTING A
LITTLE BIT OF THAT A TO HELP
OFFSET THE COSTS FOR OTHER NON
RESIDENTS DID YEAH AND WHAT ARE
THE WHAT'S THE RATIONALE FOR
THAT WHAT.
WELL OUR CONCERN WAS EXPRESSED
YOU MIGHT GIVE ME COULD PAINT A
PICTURE OF THE STUDENTS AND IT'S
I KNOW THAT.
I WANT TO GET TO THIS THE SECOND
THERE ARE SOME HYPOTHETICALS
ABOUT SOME -- SEVEN UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO WERE PAYING NON
RESIDENT TUITION AND I'M NOT
SURE IF THAT WAS JUST A BLABBER
THAT WAS A GREAT NUMBER.
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT WAS REYES
WE THINK THOSE ARE ACTUALLY VERY
FEW STUDENTS BECAUSE YOU'RE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND YOU
DON'T QUALIFY FOR AN INTEREST
EXEMPTION FOR UNDER EIGHTY FIVE
FORTY IT WOULD BE EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING TO FINANCE.
YOUR EDUCATION EITHER ACTS OUT
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT WE DO HAVE
THE STATUS OF THAT WAS
INACCURATE AND THAT'S THAT'S
THAT WE IT PROBABLY THOUGHT THAT
IT WOULD BE VERY UNLIKELY THAT
YOU WOULD SEE THAT TO HAPPEN YES
I THINK THERE WAS. ONE
UNDERSTANDING AS TO THE MAGNET
BUT WAS THERE A EXAMPLE OF IN
THAT SCENARIO I DON'T MEAN TO
SUGGEST THAT THE I DON'T WANNA
SAY THAT THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
UNIVERSITY BUT YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT THE NUMBER IS LIKELY TO BE --
WITHIN THE LOW DOUBLE DIGITS BUT
SAY OKAY -- TO NOW THE OTHER
ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED THAT WAS
THAT THERE ARE A NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS WHO -- WHETHER THEY'RE
FROM OTHER STATES OR FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT MAY FOR WHATEVER
REASON FIND THEMSELVES IN
FINANCIAL DISTRESS -- IN THE
CASE OF AN INTERNATIONAL STUDENT
MIGHT BE THE EXAMPLE RAISED IF
THERE'S A ECONOMIC TURMOIL AT
THEIR HOME COUNTRY -- ARE
UNKNOWN RESIDENTS TO FOR
WHATEVER REASON THERE'S THERE
THERE THERE REALLY STRETCHING
THEMSELVES TO BE ABLE TO ATTEND
YOU SEE ALREADY.
I'M WE WE DON'T THINK THERE'S A
THAT THAT NUMBER IS A
PARTICULARLY LARGE AND WE SAY
THAT BECAUSE WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF NON RESIDENT TO TAKE
OUT A STUDENT LOAN.
YEAH IT'S ABOUT 10%.
AND SO THAT'S ONE GOOD
INDICATION THAT IT IS OUT OF
LESS NEEDY POPULATION THAN THAT
THE POPULATION AT LARGE BUT
NEVER WAS THERE IS INTERESTING
IT OPEN IN HAVING AT LEAST A
PORTION OF THIS REVENUE
AVAILABLE TO HELP THE STUDENTS
AND TIRED.
AND THEN -- LASTLY THAT THE THE
REVENUE THAT WHICH BE GENERATED
BY THIS INCREASE -- WHERE WOULD
I GO WHAT IT GOT HELP IN ROME
MORE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS?
NO IT IS ALREADY IN THE SENSE
ACCOUNTED FOR IN OTHER PARTS OF
OUR BUDGET REQUEST AS AS MR
SALTED MENTIONED.
IN OUR BUDGET PLAN WE DO HAVE
OTHER REVENUE SOURCES INCLUDING
AND RST -- BUT THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO THE FUNDING WE'RE
SEEKING FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH
BECAUSE THERE ARE OTHER.
EXPENDITURE INCREASES ON THE
LEFT SIDE OF THE OF THE LEDGER
YEAH WELL THE REASON I ASK THAT
IS BECAUSE IT HAD YOUR ANSWER IS
YOUR ANSWER BUT IT'S SOMEWHAT
UNSATISFACTORY TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE ARGUMENT
THAT YOU'VE MADE.
OVER THE YEARS AS BY ENROLLING
MORE NON RESIDENTS WE'RE GOING
TO HELP AND MORE.
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS SEE WOULD
THINK THAT.
ADDITIONAL REVENUE WOULD GO NOT
TO MAKE IT EQUAL OUT FOR THAT
POPULATION BUT HELP.
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS GROW WE HAVE
ABSOLUTELY SAID THAT IS HELP
SUPPORT IN ROMAN OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AND I'LL SHOW YOU ONE
WAY IN WHICH IT WILL HELP -- IF
HE WOULD LOOK FOR EXAMPLE AND
THIS IS KIND OF A A DISTURBING
TREND BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
AMONG CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AT
NEARLY EVERY UC CAMPUS.
THE PERSISTENCE RIGHT AFTER ONE
YEAR HAS DECLINED.
SO IN OTHER WORDS WE'VE HAD A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE AND IT'S NOT
HUGE BUT IT'S WE FEAR THAT IT'S
SORT OF LIKE THE CAMEL'S NOSE
UNDER THE TENT.
OF OF A CHANGING OUTCOMES THAT
WE FIND DISTRESSING AND THAT WE
THINK IS AN INDICATOR FOR JUST
THAT RATE OF NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS IN OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS TO CALIFORNIA'S MISTER.
THAT IS THE PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS WHO.
REMAIN ENROLLED IN CALIFORNIA
THERE TO RE ENROLL IN CALIFORNIA
THE SECOND YEAR AFTER BEING HERE
THEIR FIRST YEAR.
YOU SEEN OTHER INDICATORS OF
DISTRESS AROUND THE STUDENTS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO GET LETTERS OF
RECOMMENDATION OR A LESS ABLE TO
GET INTO THEIR OWN MAJORS THIS
IS YET ANOTHER ONE THAT WERE NOW
SAYING AND IT'S AS I SAID IT'S
FOR TWO CONSECUTIVE YEARS.
AND WE THINK IT IS A CONCRETE
INDICATOR THAT -- THAT THOSE
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED AND SO THIS
FOR SOLDERING IRONS ALL THAT ALL
THAT STUFF.
WHETHER IT'S ACADEMIC ADVISING
WHETHER ITS COURSE OFFERINGS I
MEAN ALL OF THESE PLAY INTO --
WHAT MIGHT CAUSE A STUDENT -- TO
TO NOT PERSIST AND SO THESE YOU
KNOW THESE ARE IMPORTANT I THINK
COMPELLING REASONS.
IF WE IF WE WAIT TOO LONG WE
WILL SEE THIS AND FOR YOUR
GRADUATION RATES AND ANOTHER
LONGER TERM INDICATORS OF
STUDENT SUCCESS SO I THINK IT'S
IT'S SOMETHING THAT.
WE WOULD LOVE TO PARTNER WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP ADDRESS AND
RATHER THAN LATER AND AND MAKE
SURE THOSE RESOURCES FOR THEIR
OKAY -- I DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON MESSAGING.
OKAY THANK YOU THIS IS FOOD FOR
THOUGHT.
ALL RIGHT -- THEY'RE GONNA DO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES NOW SO JUST
DO THAT THE WORD WE CAN JUST
KEEP GOING OKAY YEAH OKAY SO NOW
WE'RE GOING -- TO GO.
TO THE CSU.
HOUSE OF THIS [inaudible]
CSU [inaudible]
YEAH.
AND WE JUST JUST GOING TO NOTE
THAT FOR THE I KNOW WE DO HAVE
THE HASTINGS REPRESENTATIVE HERE --
YOU WE HEARD YOUR BUDGET A FEW
WEEKS GOT A ROBUST CONVERSATION
THERE'S A SLIGHT ADJUSTMENT HERE.
AND THAT WILL BE TAKE ACTION ON
THAT NEXT WEEK BUT WE'RE WE'RE
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO DISCUSS
THAT THIS MORNING SO.
YOU MAY BE DISPENSED
[inaudible]
THE COURT [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
REBEKAH KIRK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OF THERE ARE THREE
ISSUES FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND TODAY'S AGENDA.
FOR MAY REVISION PROPOSALS THE
FIRST IS RAPID RE HOUSING THE
MAY REVISION INCLUDE SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT RAPID RE
HOUSING OF HOMELESS AND HOUSING
AND SECURE STUDENTS.
THIS PROPOSAL BUILDS UPON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INVESTMENT OF
FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR THE CSU TO ADDRESS
STUDENT FOOD AND HOUSING AND
SECURITY.
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
ONGOING GENERAL FUND TO INCREASE
SUPPORT FOR PROJECT REBOUND
WHICH WAS INCLUDED AT THE LEVEL
OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
FOR NOW A TOTAL OF ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING GENERAL FUND
PROPOSED FOR THE PROGRAM.
AS DISCUSSED IN A PREVIOUS
HEARING PROJECT REBOUND IS A
PROGRAM PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE EITHER
SEEKING TO ENROLL IN A CSU.
OR ATTENDING PARTICIPATING CSU
CAMPUSES.
THE THIRD PROPOSAL IS THAT THE
MAY REVISION INCLUDES SEVEN
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
A FIRST STAR FOSTER YOUTH.
PROGRAM COHORT AT CSU SACRAMENTO.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD ENABLE A
HORDE OF APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
FOSTER YOUTH TO ENGAGE IN A
VARIETY OF ACTIVITIES SUPPORTING
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
SUCH AS ACADEMIC COURSES FOR
COLLEGE CREDIT SOCIAL AND
CULTURAL ACTIVITIES SERVICE
LEARNING AND OTHER RECREATIONAL
ACTIVITIES.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
LA UP.
AUSTIN HOUSE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE PAGE FIFTEEN OF
YOUR GENDER LISTS THE MAIN MAY
REVISE PROPOSALS FOR CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY.
THE PROPOSAL TO FIND A RAPID RE
HOUSING PROGRAM AT C. S. U. AS
WELL AS AT UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
RACES SEVERAL ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION.
RAPID RE HOUSING IS A WIDELY
USED APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS IN THE COUNTRY BUT
IT DOES TEND TO BE COSTLY MODEL
COMPONENTS INCLUDE PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE. FOR RENT. FOR UP TO
TWO YEARS AS WELL AS A PERSONAL
CASE MANAGER.
BECAUSE THE PROGRAM IS COSTLY
AND THERE ARE SO MANY STUDENTS
AT UC AND CSU REPORTING.
HOUSING AND SECURITY.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL --
PROPOSE LEVEL FUNDING LIKELY
WOULD ONLY SERVE A SMALL
PROPORTION OF HOMELESS AND
HOUSING AND SECURE STUDENTS AT
AT THOSE SEGMENTS -- SO
APPROVING FUNDING FOR THE
PROPOSAL COULD CREATE LARGE OUT
YOUR COST PRESSURES ON THE STATE.
IT'S JUST SOMETHING A KID KEEP
IN MIND AS YOU CONSIDER THIS
PROPOSAL YEAH.
IN ADDITION AS THIS COMMITTEE
HEARD IN HEARINGS EARLIER THIS
SPRING THE ADMINISTRATION HAS.
BASIC NEEDS PROPOSALS FOR UC AND
CSU.
SO LEGISLATURE IN ASSESSING THE
RAPID RE HOUSING PROPOSAL THE
LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW THOSE PROPOSALS
IN JANUARY IN THIS NEWS THESE
NEW SET.
SETS A PROPOSALS IN MAY WILL.
WILL INTERACT AND SO YOU
LEGISLATURE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
THE PROGRAMS WILL WORK IN A
COHESIVE WAY RATHER THAN A
SEPARATE SILER PROGRAMS.
IF THE LEGISLATURE DECIDES TO
FUND RAPID RE HOUSING THE
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO NEED A
LOT MORE INFORMATION DETAIL ON
THE PROPOSAL AS PROPOSED IN MAY
JUST LAST WEEK.
THERE IS NO DEFINITION OF RAPID
RE HOUSING HOW THE MONEY WOULD
GO OUT TO CAMPUSES HOW CAMPUSES
WOULD IDENTIFY THE STUDENTS HOW
THE RESULTS WOULD BE SHARED WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND SO ALL THAT
INFORMATION WILL BE IMPORTANT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE -- IN FRONT
IF.
THE LEGISLATURE TO FUND THIS
PROGRAM.
THE COMMITTEE DISCUSSED THE
SECOND ISSUE ON PAGE FIFTEEN OF
THE AGENDA PROJECT REBOUND JUST
LAST MONTH AS WE NOTED THEN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL --
PROVIDES FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN BASE AUGMENTATIONS TO
SEE ISSUES GRADUATION INITIATIVE
WHICH IS INTENDED TO HELP
STUDENTS PARTICULARLY AT RISK
STUDENTS.
COMPLETING THEIR DEGREES FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS REPRESENTS
A 23% YEAR OVER YEAR INCREASE --
BRINGING TOTAL FUNDING FOR THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TO MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE PROVE THAT --
JANUARY PROPOSAL. TO RATHER THAN
PROVIDING A RELATIVELY SMALL
AMOUNT FOR PROJECT REBOUND THE
LEGISLATURE COULD INSTEAD
ENCOURAGE CSU TO PRIORITIZE
USING THIS MUCH.
LARGER POTOF MONEY THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE MONEY TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM.
REGARDLESS OF HOW THE
LEGISLATURE CHOOSES TO FUND
PROJECT REBOUND IN THE BUDGET
YEAR WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE.
CONSIDER REQUIRING THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO REPORT
REGULARLY ON THE PROGRAM
INCLUDING THE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THAT CAMPUS IS SPEND ON THE
STUDENTS GRADUATION OUTCOMES AND
RECIDIVISM RATES.
WITH REGARD TO THE THIRD ISSUE
LISTED ON PAGE FIFTEEN OF YOUR
AGENDA.
LIKE THE MAY REVISED PROPOSAL IN
THE RAPID RE HOUSING -- THIS
PROPOSAL -- TO FIND A COHORT OF
HIGH SCHOOL FOSTER USE THIS --
FIRST STAR PROGRAM WOULD ONLY
SERVE A SMALL SUBSET OF STUDENTS.
AS YOU HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ABOUT THIRTY STUDENTS
TOTAL OVER A FOUR YEAR PERIOD
AND ONLY IT.
IN SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY.
SO THE PROPOSAL DOES RAISE
EQUITY QUESTIONS AND EQUITY
ISSUES FOR FOSTER YOUTH LIVING
OUTSIDE OF SACRAMENTO.
AS WELL AS FOSTER YOUTH LIVING
IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA THAT THAT
ARE NOT SELECTED -- AS PART OF
THE THIRTY THAT WERE CHOSE.
THEY COULD BE CHOSEN.
SO WHERE THE LEGISLATURE TO WANT
TO PROVIDE MORE ACCESS TO FOSTER
USE THROUGHOUT THE STATE COST
OBVIOUSLY WOULDN'T BE MUCH
HIGHER THAN WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL SO IT'S JUST THIS COST
PRESSURE ISSUE SOMETHING AGAIN
TO KEEP IN MIND FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IS YOU DELIBERATE ON
THIS ISSUE.
THAT HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
OKAY THANK YOU CSU.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE C.
ISSUES THOUGHTS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AS WELL AS
THE NEW PROPOSALS IN THE MAY
REVISION MY NAME IS RYAN STORM I
REPRESENT THE OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR.
SO FIRST I WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THE CSU APPRECIATES
OBVIOUSLY THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
IN THE C. ISSUES -- OR THE
TRUSTEES BUDGET REQUEST.
SO ITS CONTINUED SUPPORT OF HIS
JANUARY PROPOSAL AT THAT MAY
REFER AGE AT THE MAY REVISION --
WILL WILL CERTAINLY GO A LONG
WAY -- BUT I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S REVISED
PROPOSAL WOULD -- AS BEST
MENTION AN AS IDENTIFIED ON PAGE
SIXTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA -- THAT
THAT PROPOSAL WOULD FUND ABOUT
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF
THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST. FOR THE SEIZURE
GRADUATION IT SHOULD HAVE.
I JUST TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
OF CONTEXT ABOUT WHAT A FULLY
FUNDED GRAD MISSION OF WILL DO.
WILL PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL THREE
THOUSAND COURSE SECTIONS
APPROXIMATELY.
IN THE UPCOMING YEAR AND SERVE
ABOUT NINETY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS OFFERING ADDITIONAL
SEAT AT IN A CLASS.
ALSO -- THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WOULD SUPPORT A 2% ENROLLMENT
INCREASE -- VERSES THE 5%
INCREASE THAT WE HAVE PROPOSED
THAT'S A DIFFERENCE OF ABOUT
ELEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS -- SO
WE STAND READY TO BETTER SERVE
OUR CURRENT STUDENTS THROUGH THE
GRAD MISCHIEF.
AND SERVE PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS
WITH THE DISH ON ENROLLMENT
FUNDING -- SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR --
DECIDE FULLY FUND THOSE
COMPONENTS OF THE REQUEST -- MY
SECOND SET OF COMMENTS RELATES
TO THE NEW MAY REVISION ITEMS
DESCRIBED IN ISSUE SIX IN
ARTICULATED BY THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE IN LA -- THE GOVERNOR'S
MADE IT CLEAR -- THAT A PRIORITY
FOR OF HIS IS TO INVEST MORE IN
HELPING STUDENTS WITH THEIR WITH
THE LARGEST.
WITH LARGE CHALLENGES.
AND WE AGREE THOSE GOALS ARE
LAUDABLE.
HOWEVER THERE IS A CHALLENGE
HERE AND I THINK IT THIS GOES TO
YOUR POINT EARLIER DURING THE UC
IN THE C. ISSUE JUST AREN'T
DURING THE UC ITEM.
IN IN KEY IN THE IDEA OF KEEPING
THE EYE ON THE PRIZE OR THE IDEA
OF OF SPORTING UNIVERSITY.
AND NOT BEING DISTRACTED BY A
NUMBER OF OTHER ITEMS THAT.
THAT COULD BE GOOD AND BE
BENEFICIAL TO OUR STUDENTS BUT
REALLY DO NOT FIND THAT THE CORE
FUNCTIONS OF THE UNIVERSITY.
AND SO WE BELIEVE THE BEST
APPROACH IS A FIRST FOR FIRST
FOR THOSE COMPONENTS OF THE
TRUSTEES BUDGET REQUEST TO BE
FUNDED -- LIKE I MENTIONED GRAN
ISSUED IN ROMAN -- EVEN CAPITAL
IF THAT'S A POSSIBILITY -- WHEN
THIS ISACCOMPLISHED MAKES SENSE
TO PERSON AFTER THAT'S
ACCOMPLISHED AND MAKE SENSE
PURSUE THESE OTHER TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THANK YOU?
YES SO ARE YOU SAYING MR STORM
THAT Q. YOU DON'T -- WELL YEAR
PRIESTS OF THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PUTTING SOME OF THESE MONIES TO
CSU YOU'D RATHER.
A RE DIRECT THAT TO GENERAL CSU
SUPPORT WELL I THINK THE IDEA
HERE IS THAT YOU WOULD WANT TO
FILL THE BUCKET OF THE BUDGET
REQUEST FIRST FROM THE TRUSTEES
AND AND AND THAT AND THEN ATTACK
SOME OF THESE ISSUES THEY ARE
YOU KNOW AS AS POINT OUT THERE.
ARE SOME ISSUES ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER
IS.
IF YOU DO ESTABLISH A CERTAIN
POPULATION OF STUDENTS RECEIVING
EMERGENCY HOUSING OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE A HUGE AMOUNT A NEED RIGHT
ON THE UNIVERSITY CAMPUS WE HAD
A SURVEY DONE BACK IN BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND LATE SEVEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND INTO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REPORTING.
THAT ABOUT 10% OF OUR STUDENT
POPULATION DEALS WITH A HOUSING
AND SECURITY WILL EXTRAPOLATE
THAT ACROSS THE SYSTEM AND
YOU'RE LOOKING AT FIFTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
SO ONE OF THE POINTS IN IN IN IN
CONSIDERING THESE SORTS OF
INVESTMENTS IS IF YOU DO CREATE
AN ONGOING COMMITMENT THAT MIGHT
REPRESENT YOU KNOW ONE TENTH OF
THAT POPULATION.
THEN IT CREATES A PRESSURE FREE
IN THE FUTURE ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF THE COMMENTS MADE
EARLIER ABOUT UPCOMING RECESSION.
OF OF ESTABLISHING MAYBE A GOAL
OF TRYING TO TO HOUSE EVERY
SINGLE STUDENT EVERY SENSE EVERY
SINGLE WAY NOT HAVING TO THE
ABILITY TO FUND THAT AS WELL AS
MAYBE THE FOOD COURT TENANTS OF
THE UNIVERSITY YEAH.
JUST SOMETHING TO CONSIDER.
WELL SURE I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT -- IS KIND OF A
RESPONSE THAT -- WE'RE SEEING
FROM OUR COMMUNITIES AS FAR AS
THE BASIC NEEDS THAT IF IT'S
CRAZY TO THINK THAT.
THEY HAVE A BEAUTIFUL FOOD
PANTRY AT SAC STATE YOU KNOW WE
YOU WOULD NOT THINK THAT TWENTY
YEARS AGO WALKING INTO SEX STATE
MAYBE THAT HAVE SOME TYPE OF
PROGRAM BUT IT LOOKS LIKE
SOMETHING FROM A YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT -- FOOD
PANTRIES AND IT'S FOR STUDENTS
AND YOU KNOW WHEN I WENT INSIDE
RECENTLY.
I KIND OF SMILED THE LIKE WELL
IS PRETTY COOL I ALSO WALKED
AWAY PRETTY GUARD PRETTY DARN
DEPRESSED LIKE WHY DO WE NEED
THIS AT ISSUES YOU CAMPUS NOT
JUST SHOWS.
AT THE REALITIES AND SO.
I THINK THAT WE CAN'T WE CAN'T
IGNORE THAT AND AND ONE OF THE
THINGS TO WHERE I THINK THIS.
RAPID RE HOUSING.
AND THE PROPOSAL IS IT ISN'T
HOUSING PER SE IT'S LIKE HOW DO
YOU GET SOMEBODY WHO'S.
YOU KNOW ON THE VERGE OF
DROPPING OUT.
YOU KNOW WALKING AWAY TO GIVE
THEM SOME TEMPORARY STABILITY.
LIKE THESE YOU KNOW TEMPORARY
MATTEL VOUCHERS TAKE TO GET
SOMEBODY.
YOU KNOW A BRIDGE TO GET TO
SOMETHING ELSE AND I I THINK
THAT'S HOW WE NEED TO VIEW THIS
WE CAN'T THINK OF THIS AS
HOUSING.
CSU STUDENTS BUT PROVIDING YOU
KNOW LACK OF BETTER TERM LIKE A
BANDAID ON A SITUATION TO JUST
HELP.
STUDENTS IN CRISIS BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WE KNOW THAT.
IT.
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES ANXIETY --
IN A FOOD ISSUES HOUSING THOSE
ARE ALL REAL FOR OUR CSU
POPULATION MANY COME FROM
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME BACKGROUNDS
YOU KNOW TO TWO THIRDS OR MORE
ARE ON SOME TYPE OF FINANCIAL
AID CELL.
IT'S NOT THAT THAT THE OTHER
STUDENT POPULATION WERE SAYING
THAT YOU SEE YOUR SOME OF THE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS PER SE.
SO I I THINK THERE IS THERE IS A
NEED -- FOR AT SOME TYPE OF
STATE INVESTMENT HERE LIMITED
AND REALIZING THAT WE CAN'T
TACKLE TACKLE EVERYTHING.
I DID WANT AYE AYE MR DISCUSSION --
LAST MONTH AND FORTUNATELY ON ON
PROJECT REBOUNDS AND I AM A
SUPPORTIVE OF OF THIS.
PROGRAM -- YOU KNOW IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AS WE FOCUS ON
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
IN TRYING TO RE INTEGRATE PEOPLE
BACK INTO.
SOCIETY THAT THAT FOCUSES ON
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING AND BEING
GATED COMMUNITY BUT AS FAR AS
EMPLOYMENTS WITHOUT KNOW THAT
THE JOBS OF TODAY AND TOMORROW
ACQUIRED HIGHER EDUCATION AND
HAS SOME GREAT EXAMPLES OF
STUDENTS.
A LOCAL EVEN PARTICIPATING IN
THIS IN THESE PROGRAMS OBSCENE
SOME HERE AT THAT SEX STATE SO --
WANT I KNOW WILL HAVE SOME
PUBLIC COMMENT PROBABLY ABOUT
THIS IN A BIT AND SO I DO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO IT TO GO UP -- FROM TWO FIFTY
TO I'M A MILLION WITH AN
ADDITIONAL SEVEN FIFTY THOUSAND
I REALIZE THAT'S NOT THE FULL
REQUEST I KNOW THEY HAD SOME
ONGOING MONEY THAT WENT AWAY AND
IT'S A GRANT PROGRAM FOR SAYING
SO.
YOU KNOW WE ARE EVALUATING THE
NOTION OF OF OF OF THEIR THEIR
TOTAL REQUEST BUT WANTED -- TO
ASK YOU IF YOU WANTED TO COMMENT
ON THIS PROGRAM.
I THINK GENERALLY SPEAKING --
YOU KNOW WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
PROJECT REBOUND -- AND I AND I
WANT TO GO BACK TO SOME OF THE
EARLIER POINT YOU MADE OBVIOUSLY
WE HAD AS YOU AS UNIVERSITY ARE
VERY STE.
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO BE
SUPPORT OF A RIVER STUDENTS IN
TERMS OF HOUSING AND FOOD
PANTRIES THAT SORT OF THING.
OBVIOUSLY BY YOUR ATTENDANCE AT
SEX STATE DEMONSTRATES THAT
THERE IS AN EFFORT THEIR
CHALLENGES THERE'S LIMITED
RESOURCES RIGHT IN THE STATE AT
THE UNIVERSITIES.
AND SO YOU HAVE TO PRIORITIZE I
THINK WHEN IT COMES TO PROJECT
REBOUND I THINK -- THE POINT TO
BE MADE WITH WITH THIS IS THAT
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT GRANTS --
PHILANTHROPIC GRANTED IS
EXPIRING.
AND LARGELY WHAT THE I DON'T
WANNA BUT WORDS MY MOUTH MY
COLLEAGUE HERE FROM FINANCE BUT
I THINK LARGELY THE INTENT HERE
IS SYSTEM.
IS TO BACK FILL THAT LOSS OF
THAT GRANT FUNDING IN THAT
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM PERMANENTLY.
I THINK WE SEE THE VALUE IN
MAINTAINING THE PROGRAM THERE'S
A FANTASTIC I'D NEWS FROM THAT
PROJECT.
MANY OF THE STATE MANY OF YOUR
STAFF HAVE BEEN ON ON VISITS --
TO TO EXPERIENCE BRIEFINGS ON
THAT ANSWER VERY GOOD PROGRAM SO --
WE ARE DEFINITELY SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT PROGRAM.
AND THEN LASTLY THE PROGRAM AT
THAT CSU SACRAMENTO THE FIRST
STAR FOSTER YOUTH ON I BEYOND
CITY I I HADN'T HEARD OF THIS
PROGRAM BEFORE IT WAS THAT.
WRITTEN UP IN THE MAY REVISE
LAST WEEK BUT WE DONE SOME
RESEARCH AND YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
ANY PROGRAMS THAT.
SUPPORT OUR OUR OUR FOSTER YOUTH --
SCHOLARS IS THAT IS THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT -- ENDEAVOR FOR
CALIFORNIANS SO.
I APPRECIATE THIS PROPOSAL FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- MR
MURATSUCHI.
SO -- MISTER STRONG MY I WANTED --
TO AS FOR A LITTLE CLARIFICATION.
YOU YOU YOU YOU INDICATED THAT --
THAT -- WE SHOULD FOCUS ON ON
FUNDING THEY THEY THEY THEY DID
THE CORE MISSION -- THROUGH THE
REQUEST.
PROVIDED BY THE THE THE TRUSTEES
BEFORE WE START FOCUSING ON
THESE -- INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS --
SO.
I MEAN THEY THAT THAT KIND OF
GOES -- TO MY MY MY GENERAL
CONCERN ABOUT.
WHENEVER WE HIGHLIGHT THE
SPECIAL PROGRAMS -- IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'RE LOSING SIGHT OF THE
CORE MISSION AND AND WERE FOR
WE'RE SPENDING SO MUCH TIME
[inaudible]
ON YOU KNOW.
SPECIFIC ISSUES I AND AND YOU
KNOW GRANTED.
WE WE'VE WE'VE HEARD FROM SO
MANY STUDENTS TALKING ABOUT --
TO HOMELESSNESS HOUSING AND
SECURITY FOOD AND SECURITY --
THAT YOU KNOW WERE TRYING TO
RESPOND TO THAT.
AND YET.
IT'S NOT AS CATCHY TO FOCUS ON
THE CORE EDUCATIONAL MISSION --
IN AND THEN SO.
I I GUESS YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW THERE MAY BE POLITICAL
REASONS WHY PEOPLE ARE FOCUSING
ON SPECIFIC PROGRAMS TO BE ABLE.
TO YOU KNOW SAY WELL WE PROVIDED
YOU KNOW THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY TO
TO TO YOU KNOW AND RESPONSE TO
T. T. YOUR DEMANDS -- AND AND
AND TRYING -- TO MAKE A
DIFFERENT CONSTITUENCIES HAPPY --
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND YOU KNOW
IT'S THERE IS ALSO THE CONCERN
THAT IF WE DON'T.
SPECIFY THE ALLOCATION OF FUNDS
FOR SPECIFIC PROGRAMS LIKE.
HOUSING AND SECURITY THEN IT
WON'T BE A WILL BE ADDRESSED SO
GET GET CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT I
MEAN LIKE YOU KNOW HOW HOW CAN.
HOW WOULD WE BE ASSURED THAT
THAT IF WE?
FOCUSED ON ON FUNDING THE THE
CORE -- MISSION THAT THAT THESE --
YOU KNOW SPECIFIC NEEDS WOULD
NOT BE -- YOU KNOW AT ADDRESSED
WELL I DON'T THINK WE I DON'T
THINK THERE WE'RE IN A POSITION
ANYBODY IN THE STATE NOR THE
UNIVERSITIES ARE IN A POSITION
TO MEET EVERY SINGLE NEED OF
EVERY SINGLE STUDENT I MEAN
THAT'S JUST THE REALITY OF IT.
I THINK WHAT I'M WHAT I'M TRYING
TO SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE HERE
IS THAT.
ULTIMATELY OUR OUR GOAL AS AN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS TO
EDUCATE STUDENTS.
AND ONE THING THAT WE HAVE
NOTICED -- IN MANY YEARS AND
HAVE DONE THROUGH THE GRAD
INITIATIVE LAUNCH IS TO REALLY.
STATE CENTRALLY FOCUSED ON THE
NOTION OF HAVING STUDENTS
PERSIST AND GET THEIR DEGREE AT
THE SAME TIME BEING ABLE TO GET
THE COURSES THAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO GRADUATE.
AT THE TIME THAT THEY WANT TO
GRADUATE.
IDEALLY IF THEY WANT TO GRADUATE
IN FOUR THEY AT GRADUATE FORTY
ONE GRADUATE THREE THREE IF IT'S
IF THEY'RE ON THE SIX YEAR PLAN
INTENTIONALLY.
THERE IS WELL.
NOW THE GRANITE SHOULD HAVE DOES
A NUMBER OF THINGS IN TERMS OF
FUNDING IT LIKE I MENTIONED IT
IT ADDS ADDITIONAL COURSES SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE MORE STUDENTS.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
MORE THAN THE AVERAGE WHICH IS
ABOUT THIRTEEN POINT THREE UNITS
PER TERM NOW IF YOU DO THE MATH
YOU NOT GONNA GRADUATE IN FOUR
YEARS IF EVERYBODY WAS IN THAT
SITUATION.
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE MAJOR
TENANTS THE OTHER PIECE OF IT.
IS.
ARE THESE OTHER PIECES RIGHT
IT'S MEETING BASIC NEEDS.
RIGHT IT'S BEING ABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO FOOD PANTRIES AND TO
BE ABLE TO OFFER EMERGENCY
HOUSING VOUCHERS.
SO WE ARE TRYING TO DO SOME OF
THAT AND CAMPUSES HAVE PLANS IN
ACTION SO THAT THEY CAN.
DO ALL OF THIS TRY TO ATTEMPT TO
DO ALL OF THIS THE KNOCKING AT
THE NOT GONNA MEET EVERY SINGLE
NEED THOUGH THAT'S JUST NOT THE
REALITY THAT'S NOT.
THAT'S THAT'S NOT THE WORLD WE
LIVE IN.
BUT I THINK WE WE WILL GET THERE
THE OTHER THING TOO THAT IF YOU
IF YOU ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
THAT HAS BEEN PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION WHICH IS.
COMPLETELY DOVE TAILS AND WHAT
THE TRUSTEES REQUEST.
IT'S FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME
FOR BASIC NEEDS INITIATIVES.
AND SO THAT'S ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY IN WHICH WE ARE
TRYING TO IT ATTEMPT. TO MEET A
LOT OF THESE NEED SO IT'S IT'S
ALSO HOUSING BUT IT'S ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT STUDENTS HAVE
HAVE AN AWARENESS AND HAVE THAT
CONNECTION. TO A LOT OF OTHER
SOCIAL SERVICES THAT WE HAVE.
ESTABLISHED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND IN THE PHILANTHROPIC
WORLD -- WE ARE PERFECTLY
ALIGNED WITH EVERY SINGLE ENTITY
THAT THAT CAN HELP STUDENTS WITH
EXISTING MONIES THAT ARE ALREADY
BUDGETED OUT THERE AND IN THE
STATE BUDGET.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF THAT
FIFTEEN MILLION WILL DO IS
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE MORE OF
THAT.
CAN ACTIVITY.
OF OUR STUDENTS WITH THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED IN
PARTICULAR.
SO I THINK.
ADOPTING THE THE BUDGET REQUEST
AS WE'VE LAID OUT IS A LONG IS
IS IS MILES AHEAD OF WHERE WE
WOULD BE.
BECAUSE YOU'RE ADDING MONEY ON
GRANITE SHOULD BE ADDING MONEY
ON BASIC NEEDS.
AND THEN IF YOU DO WANT TO
CONSIDER ADDITIONAL FUNDS LIKE
PROPOSED BY THE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S IN ADDITION TO IN WOULD
BE BE SUPPLEMENTAL TO AND AND
ULTIMATELY WOULD BE WOULD BE --
SATISFIED WITH THAT AS WELL.
ANY OTHER ON QUESTIONS MISTER
GALLAGHER TO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
SO WHAT I'M SORRY I MISSED SOME
OF THIS DISCUSSION -- BUT YOU
KNOW ONE I I DO WANT TO AND I
CREDIT. FOR WHAT THEY HAVE
ALREADY DONE YOU KNOW AND BEING
AHEAD OF THIS ISSUE IN TERMS OF
DEALING WITH HOMELESS.
AS STUDENTS AND COMMISSION IN
THEIR STUDY AND SO IN A LOT OF
WAYS I FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW IN
THIS DISCUSSION.
IN IN FIGURING OUT HOW WE HOW WE
DO THE FUNDING AND NOW WE DO THE
BUDGET ON THIS WE SHOULD SAY
LOOK THERE'S ARE A LOT THAT CSU.
HAS ALREADY DONE AND IS DOING ON
THIS FRONT.
AND I AND I THINK WHAT I'M
HEARING IS SAY YOU KNOW.
I KINDA DON'T DON'T DON'T --
HAND CUFF AS BY SAYING HEY THIS
IS JUST ONLY THIS MONEY AND AND
KIND OF MAKING THIS.
MONEY SORT OF JUST ATTACHED TO
THAT PROGRAM MEAN.
WHEN THEY'VE KIND OF ALREADY
ESTABLISHED AND PROGRAMMING
RIGHT -- AND AND THEN I ALSO
HERE OBVIOUSLY THERE'S THERE'S
NO.
MORE NEED TO THEY NEED FOR THEIR
CORE MISSION -- WORK -- IS KIND
OF WHAT I'M HERE AND SO I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE US AS A COMMITTEE --
SEE IF WE CAN GIVE THEM SOME OF
THAT FLEXIBILITY HERE BASED ON
THE FACT THAT.
THEY HAVE BEEN ADDRESS IN THIS
YOU KNOW IT'S AND I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY ANOTHER A WEATHER.
AHEAD OF YOU SEE -- IN SCENE YOU
KNOW THIS ISSUE IN AND TRYING TO
ADDRESS IT -- I THINK THE OTHER
ISSUE THAT I WOULD.
I THINK ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT HAS YOU KNOW HOW OUR THE
LIMITED NUMBERS OF FOSTER YOU
SIR BY THIS -- BY THIS PROGRAM
SELECTED TO PARTICIPATE.
UNDER THE CURRENT PRO YOU ARE
THE THE FIRST OUR PROGRAMS AT
CSU SAMBAR ENDINO -- FOR EXAMPLE --
HOW ARE THOSE?
YEAH HOW ARE THOSE FUNDED AND
THEN YOU KNOW HOW DO WE SELECT
WHO GETS TO PARTICIPATE IN THOSE
PROGRAMS [inaudible]
SO.
WE'VE SPOKEN WITH A FIRST OUR
STAFF.
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM AND THERE ARE
TWELVE ACADEMIES CURRENTLY
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
THERE'S ACTUALLY TWO IN
CALIFORNIA U. C. L. A. AND CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY SAMBAR DINO.
UNIVERSITY UTAH HAS WON THIS ONE
YOU CONNECTICUT NOW THERE'S
UNDERSTANDING FROM THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE FIRST OUR
STAFF IS THAT THE UNIVERSITIES.
HIRE A DIRECTOR AND THAT
DIRECTOR WORKS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY IS AN AND CHARTS AND
IS IN CHARGE OF SELECTING.
FOSTER USED TO BE IN THAT
PROGRAM.
AND FIRST ARE ACTUALLY HAS A
SUGGESTED RUBRIC FOR CHOOSING --
THE FOSTER USE BUT BASICALLY
THAT THE DIRECTORS WORK WITH
THAT CHILD WELFARE WELFARE AND
OTHER AGENCIES TO TO TRY TO
IDENTIFY.
INDIVIDUALS MIGHT BE SUITABLE AN
APPROPRIATE SUCCESSFUL IN THE
PROGRAM.
IT'S FUNDED THROUGH VARIOUS
MEANS AS WELL BRUCE LOCAL MONEY
SERVICE IN SOME STATES SOME
STATE MONEY VARIOUS
PHILANTHROPIC SO VARIOUS FUNDING
SOURCES.
AND THEN HAS AND MAYBE YOU
ALREADY ANSWERED THIS RATE HAS
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
ALLOCATED IN THE ON GOING FUNDS --
FOR THE SUPPORT OF THIS PROGRAM.
ARE THESE PROGRAM IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE -- NOT FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE PER SE --
I'M NOT AWARE THAT PERHAPS IN
BERNIE DINO HAS CONTRIBUTED SOME
OF THEIR OPRY BUDGET FROM THEIR
CAMPUS BUT I'M UNAWARE
SPECIFICALLY WHAT IF ANY WHAT
ABOUT FOR PROJECT REBOUND I
THINK THAT WAS OF THAT THOSE
MEXICO YEAH YEAH THERE'S WHAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE IS ABOUT.
I THINK IT'S ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE
COMMITTED ON A MULTI YEAR BASIS --
TO PROJECT REBOUND -- FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ALSO --
THERE'S INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES ARE
ARE CONTRIBUTING VERY SMALL.
AMOUNTS IN THE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS.
ON THEIR FROM THEIR PARTICULAR --
OPERATING BUT SUPPORT THE
PROGRAM I THINK OVERALL -- THE
THE PROGRAMS ABOUT ONE ONE
MILLION ONE POINT TWO MILLION
PER YEAR -- THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THAT MONEY THOUGH IS IS HAS BEEN --
HAS BEEN FROM -- THIS PARTICULAR
PHILANTHROPIC ENTITY.
THAT MONEY IS EXPIRING SOON AND
SO WHAT YOU HAVE HERE IS YOU
HAVE IN ESSENCE BACK FILL OF
THAT THE PHILANTHROPIC SIDE.
AND MAYBE SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WHEN THAT WHEN WE DO THE
MATH ON THAT THEY MADE YOU KNOW
TURN OUT THAT IT'S YOU KNOW.
A LITTLE BIT MORE MONEY THAT
COULD BE INVESTMENT PROGRAM.
I THINK WE HAVE ABOUT EIGHT
CAMPUSES IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN OF
THAT PARTICIPATE IN -- PRIDE
AGREE ABOUT AT THIS POINT -- THE
LARGEST PROGRAM IS AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE AND THERE ARE
OTHER CAMPUSES THAT OR I JUST
GETTING OFF THE GROUND WITH THAT
PROGRAM -- AS WELL AS FOLKS
OTHER CAMPUSES THAT ARE
DEFINITELY INTERESTED BECAUSE OF
THAT.
THE GREAT SUCCESS THAT THAT HAS
BEEN SHOWN AT SEVERAL SCHOOLS
STATE OTHER EXISTING PROGRAMS.
IN THIS ROOM REALLY QUICKLY.
SO MY EYES OF INITIAL COMMENTS
THERE IS THAT IS THAT A PRETTY
GOOD.
SYNTHESIS OF WHAT YOU GUYS HER
SANE WITH REGARD TO TAKE
COMPLIMENTS ANY DAY.
YEAH BUT I MEAN BUT AS A AS AT A
SYNTHESIS OF WHAT YOU GUYS ARE
ASKING ESSENTIALLY THAT HEY
DON'T.
WE ARE ALREADY DOING THIS.
DON'T TARGET THIS MONEY IF IF WE
COULD HAVE SOME MORE FLEXIBILITY
AND HAVE THIS MONEY GO TOWARDS
OUR CORE PROGRAM I THINK I THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY ARE OUR POSITION
IS THAT THE MORE FLEXIBILITY
PROVIDE THE UNIVERSITY OF MORE
WE CAN PIVOT AND DO THINGS THAT
ARE.
UNIQUE NOT ONLY FROM A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE BUT ALSO COULD BE
MORE COST EFFECTIVE POTENTIALLY --
SO I WOULD SAY ONE EXAMPLE IS TO
THE GRAD THE GRADUATION ISSUED
OF WHAT WHAT CAMPUS IS DO AS
THEY ESTABLISH A PLAN.
AT THEIR LEVEL OF WHAT THEY ARE
INTENDING TO DO.
AND WHAT HAPPENS IS SOMETIMES --
AND WE'VE ALREADY SEEN THIS
HAPPEN WHERE THEY HAVE ACTUALLY
PIVOTED.
AND HAVE DECIDED WELL WE HAVE WE
HAVE INVESTED IN THIS SO FAR AND
WE ARE NOW WANTING TO PAY THAT
AND AND INVEST A LITTLE BIT MORE.
FOR EXAMPLE ON ONE CAMPUS THAT
THE REAL DETRIMENT AT ON THE
CAMPUS WAS A LACK OF ECONOMIC
COUNSELING.
RIGHT A GRAND ISSUED IF THE
FUNDING THAT YOU PROVIDED
BASICALLY SO HERE'S A BUNCH OF
MONEY CAMPUS IS YOU DECIDE
WHAT'S THE BEST NEED ON YOUR
CAMPUS SO THIS PARTICULAR CAMPUS
SAID WE HAVE WE WE NEED MORE
ACADEMIC COUNSELORS TO ADVISE
STUDENTS ON THE BEST PATH TO
DEGREE.
OKAY FIRST YEAR THEY PUMP IT ALL
INTO THEIR QUE ALL THEIR MONEY
GOES INTO ECONOMIC COUNSELING.
SECOND YEAR GRAD MISSION OF
FUNDING.
THEY INVESTED ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY
IN ADDITIONAL FACULTY SO NOW WE
HAVE CANCERS IN PLACE WHICH IS A
IN AN INCREDIBLE.
LACK ON OUR CAMPUS AND NOW WE'RE
GOING TO ADD MORE COURSE
SECTIONS BECAUSE AS WE NEED TO
DO.
AND SO CAMPUSES ARE ARE ARE HAVE
PLANS IN PLACE TO REALLY PUT
MORE AND MORE MONEY IN STRATEGIC
AREAS.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY IF THE LEGISLATURE
OR THE GOVERNOR DECIDE THAT YOU
KNOW ALL THIS MONEY SHOULD BE
THIS WAY AND ALL THIS MONEY
SHOULD BE THAT WAY.
THE CHALLENGES THAN THAN
CAMPUSES CAN'T PAY THAT THEY
HAVE TO SPEND MONEY.
POR BUNCH MONEY INTO SOMETHING
THAT MIGHT BE GOOD BUT AT THE
COST OF SOMETHING ELSE THAT MAY
BE A CHALLENGE SO WE ARE ALWAYS
ADVOCATES FOR ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY.
THANK YOU SO.
THEY AGAIN I I I I KNOW YOU
TALKED ABOUT -- ON THIS IS SAME
POINT ABOUT -- TO DIRECTING THE
FUNDS FOR CORPS FOR CORE FUNDING
TO PROVIDE THEM THAT MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY -- I KNOW YOU
INDICATED THAT THAT YOU KNOW.
PART OF THAT FLEXIBILITY WOULD
BE TO ALLOW THE CSU CAMPUSES TO
TAP INTO EXISTING COUNTY OR
OTHER.
POTENTIAL SOURCES OF OF OF OF
FUNDING -- TO TO SUPPORT AND
ADDRESSES HOUSING AND FOOD AND
SECURITY ISSUES WITH HOW WOULD
WE BE ASSURED THAT THAT THE THE
THESE NEEDS ARE BEING ADEQUATELY
ADDRESSED.
WHILE THE SEE THROUGH REPORTING
AND WE HAVE -- DONE -- A LITTLE
BIT OF THAT TO BEGIN WITH WITH
OUR EXISTING LIST OF OUR BASIC
NEEDS SHOULD OF THERE ALSO IS
ADDITIONAL.
WORK BEING DONE NOW THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME THIS YEAR THERE'S A
BASIC NEEDS -- I GUESS FOR LIKE
UBER WORD -- CONFERENCE THAT WE
HOSTED -- IN SO WHAT YOU'RE
HAVING IF YOU'RE HAVING A LOT OF
ACTIVITY WHERE YOU'RE CONNECTING
THE UNIVERSITY WITH THOSE OTHER
ENTITIES BUT THEN ALSO -- THERE
IS ALREADY ESTABLISHED IN BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE REQUIREMENT TO
REPORT ON ON WHERE WE ARE AND
THINGS SO WE SUBMIT A REPORT
EARLY THIS SPRING.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT IF THERE IS --
CONTINUED -- FUNDING FOR THIS
THAT YOU WOULD PROBABLY CARRY
THAT REPORTING LANGUAGE GOING
FORWARD WE'RE HAPPY TO REPORT
HOW HOW WE'RE DOING ON THINGS.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
IF YOU I LIKE TO MOVE ON TO TO
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COMMUNICATIONS
.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE NEW IN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE ME REVISION CONTINUES THE
REVISED IMPLEMENTATION PLAN FOR
THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA PROPOSED THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND ALSO
PROPOSES TO EXTEND THE HOLD
HARMLESS.
OF THE PROVISION OF THE FORMULA
TO A FOURTH YEAR OR FISCAL YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO THE ADMINISTRATION PLANS TO
WORK WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
COMING MONTHS TO EXPLORE
REVISIONS THE FORMULA TO IMPROVE
THE ACCURACY OF THE DATA
REPORTED BY DISTRICTS.
ADDRESS THE FORMULAS LONG TERM
FISCAL STABILITY AND HELP
FURTHER THE GOALS OF THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS.
THE INTENT IS THAT THE REVISIONS
BE CONSIDERED AS PART OF NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET CYCLE.
FOR TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OTHER ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE
MAY REVISION INCLUDE A PROPOSED
THIRTY NINE POINT SIX MILLION
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO LARGELY
REVERSES A GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ADJUSTMENT THAT SWAPPED SEVENTY
SEVEN MILLION IN ONGOING
RESOURCES FOR ONE TRUCK ONE TIME
FUNDS TO SUPPORT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM.
THE TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
MILLION IN FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM IS NOW MADEUP OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX POINT SIX
MILLION.
ON GOING FUNDS AND ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION ONE TIME FUNDS.
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO PROPOSES
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND FOR THE FOSTER CARE
EDUCATION PROGRAM TO SUSTAIN THE%
PROGRAM'S CURRENT LEVEL OF
FUNDING.
BASED ON PROJECTED DECREASE IN
FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS FOR THE
PROGRAM.
AND AS IS THE CASE FOR K. TWELVE
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES A
DECREASE OF TWENTY POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES. TO
REFLECT THE CHANGE IN THE COLA
FROM THREE POINT 46% TO THREE
POINT 26%.
THIS CHANGE AFFECTS A PORTION
MEN'S AND VARIOUS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAMS.
SIMILARLY THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A CHANGE FOR THE CAL
STIRS SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION
PAYMENT TO DECREASE THE
CONTRIBUTION RATE FOR EMPLOYERS
FROM EIGHTEEN POINT 13% TO
SIXTEEN POINT 7% WHICH IS A ONE
POINT 43% DECREASE.
THE PROPOSED SUPPLEMENTAL
PENSION PAYMENT IS NOW THREE
POINT ONE FIVE BILLION NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND OF WHICH TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION
IS ESTIMATED TO GO TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. FOR STATE OPERATIONS
THE MAYOR VISION PROPOSES THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING ON PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND FOR THREE
NEW POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICES STATE
OPERATIONS.
THESE INCLUDE TWO POSITIONS FOR
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICES
ACCOUNTING SHOP AS WELL AS ONE
POSITION TO MONITOR DISTRICTS
FISCAL HEALTH AND TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
DISTRICTS AND NEED.
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
VERY MUCH -- THE HELLO.
EDGAR CABRAL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
WE HAVE SOME COMMENTS ON TWO OF
THE OF THE PROPOSES MOMMY
REVISION.
FIRST REGARDING THE PROPOSAL TO
EXTEND THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION FOR A FOURTH YEAR.
AND WE WOULD RECOMMEND REJECTING
THIS PROPOSAL WE DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY NEED TO EXTEND THE
PRISON RIGHT NOW.
THE THE AS THE ADMINISTRATION --
NOTED THAT THEY ARE NOT --
PURSUING ANY MAJOR CHANGES TO
THE FORM OF THAT THIS TIME AND
MOST OF THE CHANGES THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE MIRROR VISION.
WE WOULD ARGUE ARE ACTUALLY
CREATE MORE STABILITY IN IN IN
THE FORMULA SO WE WE DON'T THINK
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY A
REASON TO EXTERNAL HARM IS AT
THIS TIME.
THAT THE EXTENDING IT DOES
CREATE SOME COST PRESSURE IN
THAT FOURTH YEAR.
AND SO -- IT'S PROBABLY BECAUSE
PRESSURE BUT PROBABLY IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS SO
WE DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
REASON TO DO THAT NOW IF IN
JANUARY WITH THERE IS A PROPOSAL
FOR A BIGGER FORMER BIGGER
CHANGES WE THINK AT THAT TIME
YOU COULD CONSIDER.
WHETHER YOU WANTED TO EXTEND
THAT.
IN TERMS OF THE STATE OPERATIONS --
WE HAVE NO SPECIFIC CONCERNS
WITH THE PARTICULAR POSITIONS
BUT WE DO CONTINUE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THAT WITH TRANSPARENCY
FROM THE CHANCES OF AND HOW IT
HAS.
SPENT MORE RECENT AUGMENTATIONS
THE OFFICES RECEIVED TWO POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
AUGMENTATIONS OF THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS.
OF THE DATE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CáC.
CLEAR INDICATION OF HOW THOSE
POSITIONS HAVE BEEN USED AS A
WITH OTHER INFORMATION WERE
CONCERNED THAT ANY FURTHER
AUGMENTATIONS MIGHT NOT BE USED
FOR THE INTENDED PURPOSES SO --
OUR RECOMMENDATION -- WOULD BE
TO TO FIND A NEW POSITION TO
REQUIRE HAVE THOSE POSITIONS BE
FILLED WITH EXISTING RESOURCES --
WHETHER REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
YOU TAKE OUR APPROACH OR YOU DO
PROVIDE THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
IN THE MIRROR VISION WE WOULD
RECOMMEND ADDING PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE -- THAT SPECIFIES
EXACTLY WHAT THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IS TO BE USED FOR IT TO
SPECIFY BOTH POSITIONS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A CLEAR
EXPECTATION OF HOW THE FUNDING
SHOULD BE USED.
AND WE ALSO -- THE LEGISLATURE
ALSO MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
REQUIRING THE CHANCES OFFICE TO
REPORT I ALWAYS SPENT THESE MOST
RECENT BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS.
I'M JUST SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS A BETTER SENSE OF HOW FUNDS
OF IN SPENT AND HOW I CAN BETTER
ASSESS FUTURE OF BUDGET
PROPOSALS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHRISTIAN US WHEN IF
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE MAY
REVISION -- WITH REGARD TO THE
STUDENTS UNDER CENTER FUNDING
FORMULA AGAIN WE THANK THE
GOVERNOR.
OF FOR THE PROPOSAL'S HE'S MADE --
TO CONTINUE IMPLEMENTATION --
JUST TO BEGIN FOR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WE WOULD ARGUE.
THAT WE REALLY SHOULD BE HOLDING
IT -- COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HARMLESS -- FOR ANY CHANGES IN
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
KAREN T..
BOTH YOU KNOW I THINK THE
PARTICULAR ISSUE THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT A RECENT HEARINGS
WAS AROUND PROPERTY TAXES -- WE
ALSO THINK THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SHOULD BE ABLE TO PLAN
FOR THE AMOUNTS.
THAT THE FORMULA HAS GENERATED
TO DATE FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN UNDER CURRENT LAW.
YEAH THE FISCAL YEAR ENDS I
BELIEVE FORTY FIVE DAYS FROM NOW
IF I GOT MY DATES CORRECT AND SO.
YOU KNOW I THINK WHAT WE'RE
ARGUING IS THAT -- THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR WOULD
MAKE NO CHANGES TO THE FORMULA
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR -- PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL APPROPRIATIONS.
POTENTIALLY ONE TIME FUNDING --
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN FIND
DISTRICTS FOR WHAT WE'VE -- BUT
THE FORMULA HAS GENERATED
420-181-9420 EIGHT NINETEEN
TWENTY AND BEYOND -- WE ARE
COMFORTABLE -- WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETY OR EXCUSE FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY WERE
COMFORTABLE BUT THE PROPOSAL
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL. TO CHANGE
THE RATES IN THE FUNDING FORMULA --
TO TO GENERATE ABOUT EIGHT
SEVENTY TWENTY TEN SPLIT WE ARE
ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO EXTEND
THE EXISTING HOLD HARMLESS.
THREE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO WITH
REGARD TO OTHER PROPOSALS THE
GOVERNOR CONTINUES IN THE MAYOR
OF FISH AND WE WOULD REQUEST
SOME ALTERNATIVE SPECIFICALLY
RELATED -- TO THE STUDENT
SUCCESS ALLOCATION ONE THAT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE INCLUDING BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
COUNT ONLY THE HIGHEST AWARD AS
PART OF THE STUDENT SUCCESS
ALLOCATION.
WE SPECIFICALLY REQUEST THAT --
AS PART OF THE FUNDING FORMULA
MOVING FORWARD WE WOULD HELP THE
HIGHEST OF THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE
FOR CHANCE FOR THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE THE BACCALAUREATE DEGREE
OTHER CREDIT CERTIFICATE.
I THINK THIS IS -- YOU KNOW
RESPONSIVE TO CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED IN THIS COMMITTEE --
EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT THE
FUNDING FORMULA COULD GENERATE --
COULD.
HAVE INCENTIVES THAT WOULD --
EXPECTED STREAKS TO GENERATE AS
MANY CREDENTIALS AS POSSIBLE.
WITH REGARD TO WE YOU KNOW I
THINK CAN KERR WITH THE INTEREST
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS WITH
REGARD -- TO THE DEFINITION OF A
SUCCESSFUL TRANSFER TO A FOUR
YEAR UNIVERSITY WE THINK THAT
THERE IS AN ALTERNATIVE
DEFINITION THAT ACCOMPLISHES THE
GOVERNOR'S GOALS BUT IS
PREFERABLE WITH REGARD TO
INCENTIVES.
ACCOUNTING STUDENTS -- COUNTING
STE -- THE OUTCOME IN ANY
DISTRICT WHERE STUDENTS HAVE
ATTAINED A MINIMUM NUMBER OF
UNITS WE SUGGEST TWELVE UNITS BE
THAT THRESHOLD -- IN ORDER TO
GENERATE THE TRANSFER OUTCOME
AND THEN THERE'S AN EXISTING
MEASURE IN THE FUNDING FORMULA
WITH REGARD TO COMPLETION OF
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION UNITS.
WE CONTINUE TO RECOMMEND -- THAT
THAT OUT CAN BE.
ACCOUNTED ONLY IF THE STUDENT
HAS ATTAINED THOSE IN A SIMILAR
PROGRAM AREA A SIMILAR
DISCIPLINE SO THAT WE ARE
ENCOURAGING THOSE PATHWAYS
TOWARDS CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION OUT COMES.
UP WE HAVE A SET OF TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS WE'VE SHARED WITH
THEIR STAFF HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT
THOSE -- IN FURTHER DETAIL --
JUST MAKE MORE BROADLY WE HER
SUPPORT OF AN THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR HIS PROPOSALS -- TO EXPAND --
THE CAL SISTERS RELIEF IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AGAIN THAT --
WILL PROVIDE OUR DISTRICTS WOULD
SOME SHORT TERM RELIEF FUND THE
COST PRESSURES THAT THEY FACE
FOR A RISING PENSION COSTS.
AS YOU KNOW OUR PRIMARY
OBJECTIVE THIS YEAR'S TO MAKE
PROGRESS ON AFFORDABILITY FOR
STUDENTS WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
YOUR PROPOSALS AROUND FINANCIAL
AID -- WE APPRECIATE THE
RECOGNITION OF THE GOVERNOR
PLACES IN THIS BUDGET IS MAYOR
VISION AROUND RAPIDLY HOUSING.
YOU KNOW WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
RAPID RE HOUSING PROPOSALS ARE
FOR UC AND CSU OUR STUDENTS FACE
SIMILAR ISSUES AND SO WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE A FURTHER CONVERSATION
ABOUT THAT.
AND THEN -- LASTLY THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS -- STATE
OPERATIONS -- BUDGET --
PROPOSALS WE HAD REQUESTED A
TOTAL OF SEVENTEEN AND A HALF
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS IN THE
BUDGET -- WE ARE VERY THANKFUL
FOR THE FOR POSITIONS BUT YEAH I
THINK WE WOULD JUST.
WANT TO POINT OUT BE BOTH SIDES
OF THE SYSTEM THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS THE CONTINUED AND RAPID
PACE OF CHANGE IN THE SYSTEM.
AND SO WOULD LOVE TO HAVE --
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT OUR
OFFICES CAPACITY.
WITH THAT HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
SHE GALLAGHER -- ON THE SO FOR
THE A MINISTRY IS THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERING A
PERMANENT HOLD HARMLESS LIKE
KATE TWELVE HAS WITH THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
THE MAYOR VISION OF PROPOSES TO
EXTEND THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION THAT'S IN CURRENT LAW
FOR THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA RIGHT NOW THAT.
PROVISION IS OVER THE FIRST
THREE YEARS OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA SO.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAT HOLDS DISTRICTS HARMLESS AT
A LEVEL OF THEIR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN TOTAL COMPUTATIONAL
REVENUE ADJUSTED FOR COLA FOR
EACH SUBSEQUENT YEAR.
IN THE MAYOR VISION WE ARE
PROPOSING TO EXTEND THE HOLD
HARMLESS FOR AT THE A FOURTH
YEAR. TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO OKAY SAYS AN ADDITIONAL YEAR
THEN RIGHT -- I THINK THAT'S ALL
I HAVE.
OKAY A COUPLE QUESTIONS SO ON
THE FUNDING FORMULA FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR IS IS THERE -- SOME
SHORTFALL THERE THAT WE NEED TO
BE AWARE OF OR ADEQUATE
RESOURCES TO TAKE CARE THAT.
OF THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES
THERE IS NO CURRENT YEAR
APPORTIONMENT SHORTFALL.
OKAY.
CONSIDERS TO PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT.
HOUSE OF OUR CURRENT.
YOU KNOW OUR FIRST PRINCIPLE
PORTION IT'S HOW WE GET MONEY
OUT.
WE DO.
STILL BELIEVE THAT.
WE RECOGNIZE THE GOVERNOR --
WOULD ADDRESS PART OF THAT
PROBLEM MOST OF THAT PROBLEM
WITH REGARD TO ADDITIONAL
REVENUES THE GOVERNOR -- PROVIDE
SOME GENERAL FUND -- TO TO BACK
FILL LOWER PROPERTY TAX
ESTIMATES ASSUMES THAT --
PROPERTY TAXES WILL CONTINUE TO
INCREASE WE'VE SEEN THAT IN A
HISTORICALLY AND SO -- WE ARE
LESS CONCERNED ABOUT THE REVENUE
DIFFERENCES NAIL WE STILL DO YOU
SEE A DIFFERENCE IN THE TOTAL
COST OF THE FUNDING FORMULA.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- IT
WOULD BE IN THE CURRENT YEAR --
TO TO AMENDED THE DEFINITION OF
A TRANSFER STUDENT AND SO
COMPARED TO WHAT WE'VE TOLD
DISTRICTS THEY WOULD RECEIVE --
WE WOULD BE REDUCING
APPORTIONMENT STE TO DISTRICTS
BASED ON THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
OUR PREFERENCE WOULD BE TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION -- FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY AND THEN TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO BACK FILL BOB WHAT WE BELIEVE
IS ABOUT A FORTY NINE MILLION
DOLLAR DIFFERENCE -- FOR
EIGHTEEN NINETY OKAY THANK YOU --
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THESE -- THESE
ISSUES OPEN THERE'S JUST ONE
THING I JUST WANT TO NOTE FOR
THE RECORD THAT [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
A LOT OF DIFFERENT OPINIONS ON
THE FUNDING FORMULA.
WHAT WE SHOULD DO GOING FORWARD --
AND WILL HAVE SOME TYPE OF
PROPOSAL TO PROBABLY GUESS A
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE AND WHERE
NOW WE HAVE RESOLUTION THIS YEAR
BUT OF COURSE ONE OF THINGS WE
NEED -- TO ADDRESS IS TO FIGURE
OUT THEIR PERFORMANCE PERCENTAGE
AND WHAT'S THE APPROPRIATE
AMOUNT TO THAT SO -- THEY'LL
ONGOING -- DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THAT.
SO WITH THAT WILL HOLD IS HOLED
UP IN THE IT COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
MAY REVISED PROPOSALS AND
PROCEED NOW WITH.
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION.
MAY REVISED PROPOSALS
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR -- SO
I'M GONNA BEGIN BY GIVING YOU
HAVE A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW THAN
DISCUSS THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISION.
AT ITS HIGHEST LEVEL THE MAYOR
VISION PROPOSES TOTAL FINANCIAL
AID EXPENDITURES OF TWO POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S APPROXIMATELY SHARED 50%
BETWEEN GENERAL FUND AT 50%
BETWEEN TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE FOR
NEEDY FAMILIES FEDERAL FUNDS.
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF ONE TIME PROPOSALS AS
YOUR AGENDA NOTES THE LARGEST OF
WHICH IS THE CREATION OF A
TEACHER SERVICE CREDIT
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM.
OF EIGHTY NINE POINT EIGHT
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
AND THAT PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE
LOAN FORGIVENESS GRANTS TO
TEACHERS MEETING CERTAIN
CRITERIA AND WHO TEACH IN
SPECIFIC SUBJECTS AT CERTAIN
SCHOOLS AS IDENTIFIED BY --
TRAILER BILL THAT WAS
TRANSMITTED WITH THE MAYOR OF
VISION.
IN ADDITION TO THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES THAT THE
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR CHILD SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
BE ADMINISTERED BY THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION.
AND THAT PROGRAM WILL FOCUS ON
LARGELY SEATING NEW PROGRAMS IN
AREAS THAT ARE IDENTIFIED IN
TRAILER BILL LEGISLATION ALONG
WITH SOME MONEY TO ENHANCE
EXISTING CHILD SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
PROGRAMS.
BEYOND THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
ALSO TRANSFERS THE STUDENT LOAN
AWARENESS INITIATIVE THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
TO THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION.
AND THEY WILL WORK IN CONCERT
WITH CERTAIN NON PROFITS TO
DEVELOP A PLAN.
TO SEND THAT MONEY OUT INTO THE
FIELD TO HELP STUDENTS AND
BORROWERS WITH UNDERSTANDING
THEIR STUDENT LOAN OBLIGATIONS.
LASTLY THE MAY REVISION ALSO
EXTENDS THE TIME LINE FOR
PRIVATE NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS
TO MEET THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER REQUIREMENT IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN THEIR MAXIMUM CAL GRANT
TUITION AWARD.
AT NINE THOUSAND EIGHTY FOUR
DOLLARS BY ONE YEAR SO ALL THE
DEADLINES HAVE BEEN SHIFTED BY
ONE YEAR FOR THAT.
IN ADDITION JUST BROADLY THE
MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF CHANGES TO ESTIMATES
FOR THE STATE'S FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THOSE
AS WELL.
OKAY THANK YOU LA OF THANK YOU
THE SECOND WITH LA L..
WISCONSIN THREE OF THE PROPOSALS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
INTRODUCED.
I'LL TAKE THEM IN THE ORDER THEY
LISTED IN YOUR AGENDA AND PAGE.
TWENTY THREE STARTING WITH THE
TOP SAVINGS ACCOUNT GRANT
PROGRAM.
THE RECALL THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAD
DECIDED IN MARCH WHILE PROGRAM
DETAILS FOR UNDER DEVELOPMENT.
THE PROPOSED PROGRAM IN THE
MAYOR REVISION DOES RESEMBLED
ADVOCATE COUNTS INITIATIVE WHICH
THE LEGISLATURE CREATED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO
PROVIDE LOCAL GRANTS FOR CHILD
SAVINGS ACCOUNT PROGRAMS.
EVEN THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
JUST RECENTLY ANNOUNCED THE
COUNTIES FOR EVERY KID COUNTS WE
CAN GET COULD BE CONSIDERED
PREMATURE TO CREATE A NEW
INITIATIVE BEFORE WE HAVE SOME
SHORT TERM OUTCOMES AND LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE EXISTING.
ONE IF LEGISLATURE DOES WISH TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS PROPOSAL
HOWEVER WITH YOU MAY ALSO WISH
TO CONSIDER STRENGTHENING ITS
OPPORTUNITIES TO FIGHT OVERSIGHT
OF THE NEW PROGRAM.
BY INCLUDING SOME REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND POTENTIALLY BY
HAVING A LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE PROPOSED
PROGRAM ADVISORY COUNCIL.
AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE TWENTY
THREE YOU'LL SEE A SUMMARY OF
THE PROPOSED STUDENT LOAN
AWARENESS INITIATIVE WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCES ALSO
INTRODUCED.
AS NOTED THE MAYOR VISION
TRANSFERS THIS INITIATIVE FROM
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH TO THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION.
THE ACTIVITIES CURRENTLY
PROPOSED FOR THIS INITIATIVE
APPEAR TO DUPLICATE SOME CURRENT
EFFORTS THAT ARE CONDUCTED BY
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WHICH IS THE PRIMARY LENDER OF
STUDENT LOANS.
THE SEGMENTS WHICH PACKAGE STATE
LANDS OF THE CAMPUS LEVEL.
IN A SEVERE OF PRIVATE FOR
SECONDARY EDUCATION WHICH
CONDUCTS OUTREACH TO STUDENTS
CONSIDERING ARE ATTENDING
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS.
IN LIGHT OF THIS DUPLICATION
RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL.
FINALLY TURNING THE PAGE TO SEE
A DESCRIPTION OF THE TEACHER
SERVICE CREDIT SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES LOAN
FORGIVENESS GRANTS TO TEACHERS
AND SPECIFIED SHORTAGE AREA.
AS AN INCENTIVE AVAILABLE FOR A
LIMITED TIME WE DON'T THINK THIS
PROGRAM IS LIKELY TO RESULT IN A
SUSTAINED INCREASE IN THE SUPPLY
OF TEACHERS IN SHORTAGE AREAS.
IF DESIGNED WELL HOWEVER IS AN
INCENTIVE IT COULD POTENTIALLY
ASSIST WITH SHORT TERM TEACHER
RECRUITMENT RETENTION NEEDS.
WE DON'T ONE CONCERN REGARDING
THAT CURRENT DESIGN OF THE
PROGRAM.
WHICH RELATES THE TIMING OF THE
INCENTIVE.
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT UNDER
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE PRIORITY
SCHOOLS WOULD PROMOTE THE LOAN
FORGIVENESS GRANTS TO TEACHER
CANDIDATE STRING HIRING AND
RECRUITING PROCESS.
OUR CONCERN HERE IS THE TEACHERS
WOULD BE LEARNING ABOUT THIS
INCENTIVE IN APPLYING FOR BEING
SELECTED FOR IT.
AFTER THEY'VE ALREADY MADE A
DECISION ABOUT WHICH SUBJECT
AREA DOWNTURN POTENTIALLY WHAT
TYPE OF SCHOOL TO WORK ACT.
WITH THAT IN MIND WE THINK THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
LEGISLATURETO IMPROVE THIS
PROPOSAL PERHAPS BY REACHING
TEACHERS EARLIER IN THE PIPELINE.
LEGISLATURE MAY ALSO WISH TO
DIRECT THE STATE NEED COMMISSION
REPORT ON SOME PROGRAM OUTCOMES
AS THIS TYPE OF INFORMATION
COULD GUIDE FUTURE DECISIONS
ABOUT THE USE OF FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO TRUST EACH
WORKFORCE ISSUES.
THANK YOU CAPITA [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COMMISSION STAFF.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR DAVID O'BRIEN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION -- WE JUST ONE
ANOTHER WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
AND FINANCIAL AID AND COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY.
WE'RE STILL WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION -- AND OUR STAFF
INTERNALLY TO ANALYZE HOW SOME
OF THESE PROPOSALS WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED BUT THERE ARE SOME
VERY PROMISING ITEMS IN THIS
BUDGET -- DRESSING TEACHER
SHORTAGE WHICH WE HAVE
EXPERIENCE WITH THROUGH OUR
ASSUMPTION PROGRAM ALONE FOR
EDUCATION.
THE CARD JING INCENTIVIZING
FAMILIES TO OPEN COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS WHICH ARE WE DISCUSSING
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE THROUGH OUR
EVERY KID COUNTS PROGRAM.
AND PERFORMING OUTREACH IN
INCREASING AWARENESS AROUND --
CALLED FINANCING OPTIONS WHICH
IS ONE OF OUR TOP PRIORITIES AND
HAS BEEN FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
SO -- JUST WANT TO REITERATE
THAT WE APPRECIATE HIS
INVESTMENTS AND OF COURSE WE DO
APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU THE ADMINISTRATION IS
STAKEHOLDERS.
ON A SYSTEMIC OVERHAUL OF OUR
STATE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM --
BUT IN -- CERTAINLY IN THE
INTERIM -- APPRECIATE THESE
INVESTMENTS IN THE MAY REVISE
AND ALSO JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT
ON PAGE TWENTY FOUR THE
COMMISSION IS STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW MOANS PROPOSAL WHICH IS
INCLUDED HERE IS A AS A
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET REQUEST TO
CREATE ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL AID
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR A. B. FIVE
FORTY AND DREAMER STUDENTS THIS --
SOMETHING LEGISLATION THAT OUR
COMMISSION -- COSPONSORED LAST
YEAR AND WE APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE MONTH LEADERSHIP ON
THAT ISSUE.
DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU JUST A FEW QUESTIONS
GOING GOING FORWARD -- ONE AS
FAR AS THE CHILD A SAVINGS
ACCOUNT -- PROGRAM -- I'M A BIG
SUPPORTER THAT WOULD TALK ABOUT
FOR THE PAST FEW YEARS AS AS WE
NOW -- I THINK THIS IS
APPROPRIATE TO PUT THIS IN A
COMMISSION WEEK WE HAVE SPOKEN
TO THE GOVERNOR'S -- TEAM ABOUT
THIS AND OBVIOUSLY IT'S PARTY'S
PROPOSAL I THINK YOUR YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE GOOD ONES
WILL LOOK TO INCORPORATE THOSE
FROM THE ANALYST NOT GETTING RID
OF IT BUT MAKING IT BETTER -- AS
FAR AS THE THE THE CAL GRANT
AWARDS FOR STUDENTS PARENTS WERE
STILL EVALUATING THAT AND THE
WHOLE FINANCIAL AID -- PACKAGE
OF PROPOSALS FOR REFORM THAT
WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT SO I
COULD HAVE A PROPOSAL -- FOR
NEXT.
WEEK I DO WANT TO SPEND SOME
TIME.
ON THIS -- TEACHER ISSUE THOUGH --
SO THIS IS THIS IS OBVIOUS IS A
KIND OF A HYBRID ISSUE WITH OUR
K. -- TWELVE WE HAVE WE'VE WE'VE
FOCUSED ON THE TEACHER --
SHORTAGE AND YOU KNOW DEALING
WITH THE NUMBER OF TEACHERS WHO
ARE AND CREDENTIALED IN
CLASSROOMS ABOUT SIX THOUSAND SO
IT'S REALLY NOT CAPE.
HIGHER AT THINGS MARKET TWELVE
THING BUT THIS IS A FINANCIALLY
PROGRAM SO I THINK IT THING HERE
TO TO REALIZE IS IS TWO THINGS.
ONE THERE'S TEACHERS WHO
GRADUATE WITH A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT.
OF OF DEBT.
AND HAVE THAT JUST A TOUGH TIME.
ENTERING THE WORK FORCE AND YOU
KNOW MAKING A GO OF IT THERE IS
THIS -- YEAH.
I OPENING REPORT I THINK IN ONE
OF THE EAST BAY NEWSPAPERS A FEW
WEEKS AGO WHAT ALL THESE
TEACHERS WHO ARE.
FRANKLY LIVING WITH THEIR MOM OR
GRANDMA OR TRIPLING OR
QUADRUPLING UP IN AN APARTMENT
AND JUST.
YOU KNOW HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME
LEADING NORMAL LIVES WITH
FRANKLY A GREAT JOB A GOOD
PAYING JOB -- WHEN THE MOST
IMPORTANT JOBS IN SOCIETY IT OUT
OF A TEACHER?
AND SO THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO ADDRESS AS FAR
AS THE FINANCIAL PIECE OF THAT.
BUT THE OTHER THING AS FAR AS
THE NEED TO GET MORE TEACHERS IN
THE WORK FORCE AND FRANKLY
WORKING IN.
SCHOOLS WHERE WE NEED THE MOST
HELP BECAUSE YOU KNOW FRANKLY IF
THERE WERE SIX IF THEY'RE A
BUNCH OF AN CREDENTIALED
TEACHERS IN THE SCHOOL OR MY
KIDS GO TO SCHOOL.
NOW THE PARENTS WOULD HAVE A
REVOLT AND THEY'D BE IN THE
DISTRICT OFFICES WILL THAT
HAPPEN BUT THE T. TO SCHOOLS IN
OUR IN A FIVE MILES SOUTH OF
HERE LOWER INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS
IS JUST THAT IT IS WHAT IT IS
AND I THINK THAT'S AN ABSOLUTE.
DISGRACE SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE -- QUALIFIED TEACHERS SO
I GUESS THE ISSUE THAT I'M WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
IS THAT.
THIS SOUNDS LIKE AT A REASONABLE
PROPOSAL BUT YOU KNOW IS THIS
THE BEST ONE TO ADDRESS THOSE --
TWO THOSE ISSUES -- THAT THEIR
DUAL ISSUES THERE -- IMPORTANT
ONES I KNOW WE'VE HAD.
THESE TEACHER RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
OVER THE YEARS WHICH HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL TO KEEP PEOPLE IN THE
WORKFORCE NOT JUST MONEY GETTING
IN -- BUT SUPPORT TO KEEP THEM
IN THE CLASSROOM -- AND AND THAT
IS IS AN ISSUE AND I THINK WE
TAKE A LOOK AT AND THEN. FOR THE
OVERALL FINANCIAL AID IS WE'VE
HAD AS YOU MENTIONED THE LOAN
FORGIVENESS THE APPLE WHICH I
THINK IS AN INTERESTING --
NOTION TO BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
PERFORM YOU HAVE TO YOU CAN'T
JUST GET THE MONEY.
ON THE LOAN FOR FORGIVENESS AND
GO AWAY YOU GET IT EVERY YEAR
YOU STICK AROUND.
A CLASSROOM SO.
I THINK THIS.
ON THE RIGHT -- THE POINT HERE
BILLION TO EVALUATE YOU KNOW
THAT LOGISTICS OF THIS.
AND WHAT MAKES -- WHAT MAKES THE
MOST SENSE SO WILL CERTAINLY?
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND WITH THAT.
NOBODY HERE TO ASK QUESTIONS BUT
ME SO -- I'M GOOD SIR GONNA HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN AND PROCEED NOW
WITH PUBLIC COMMENT.
I SEE THIS BAKER IS ALREADY LINE
DEATHS IS A PRO.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION -- I JUST WANTED TO
KNOW TO FEW ITEMS UNDER THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES -- WE LIKE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE HAD
OPPOSED -- FUNDING FORMULA LAST
YEAR BECAUSE OF THE PERFORMANCE
SPACE OPTION IT WOULD IT WOULD
HAVE HAD SO WE ARE PARTICULARLY
PLEASED WITH WHAT THAT THE
GOVERNOR AND IS PUTTING FORWARD
AS FAR AS PUTTING A PAUSE WE
WOULD ASK THAT THE RATIO FOR THE
FORMULA.
STATE IN NOT MODEL IN PERPETUITY
OR WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE
PERFORMANCE SPACE ASPECT COME
OUT HOW WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT --
TRYING TO GARNER INCREASE FUNDS --
TO HIRE MORE FULL TIME FACULTY
SO THEY MEET WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
TO WHAT WE ARE INITIALLY WERE
TRYING TO GET UNDER AB --
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FIVE WE'RE ALSO
SEEKING ADDITIONAL PARITY AN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR THREE THE
PART TIME CATEGORY CATEGORICAL
AS WERE PRESELI A PRE
PARTICULARLY APPRECIATIVE -- OF
THE INCREASE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
PROVIDING MORE FUNDING FOR PART
TIME OFFICE HOURS IN PARTICULAR
AS WE NOTED YESTERDAY WE ALSO
SUPPORT.
THE GOVERNOR'S INCREASED GENERAL
FUNDS TO HELP DISTRICTS PAY FOR
THEIR CAL STIRS COST -- AND WE
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT IN
THAT REGARD THANK YOU.
AND AGAIN IF YOU CAN KEEP THIS
TO AT ONE MINUTE OR LESS THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF CHRISTY THEM
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
INDULGENCE TO IDENTIFY THIS IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AGENDA.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF SEE IF T.
FOR THE COMPTON COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT REQUEST.
OF FOR TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO
RESTORE THE PERSONAL COMMISSION
OF THE ALLOCATION WOULD
REPRESENT FULL FUNDING OF THE
PERSONAL COMMISSION OVER THE
REMAINING COURSE OF THE LOAN SO
THIS GRANT WOULD.
OF PAY THROUGH THAT OBLIGATION
ALLOW THIS OF THIS COMMISSION TO
CONTINUE OPERATIONS AS YOU KNOW
AND SUBSEQUENT A PREVIOUS
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS THAT
PERSONAL THE COMMISSION DUTIES
WERE GIVEN.
UP TO REALLY A NON PERSONAL
COMMISSION NOW CURRENTLY RESIDES
OF THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES SO
THESE CLASSIFIED MEMBERS VOICES
HAVE BEEN SILENCED.
AND THEY WOULD LIKE OF THAT
VOICE REINSTATED THE PERSONAL
COMMISSION REINSTATED SO WE
COURAGE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS ITEM.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION WE WANNA AYE AYE CAR
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBBER'S REQUEST FOR A HUNDRED
MILLION FOR INVERSION DOLLARS
FOR CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES THE CSU.
THESE WORKERS HAVE NOT RECEIVED
STEPS FOR OVER TWENTY THREE
YEARS THERE ARE SALARIES ARE
BELOW MARKET RATE THIS WOULD
HELP BRING THEM TO MARKET RATE
AND RECOGNIZE THE HARD WORK THEY
DO.
WE ALSO WANT TO REITERATE THINGS
BEEN SAYING THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
WE SEE MONEY FOR THE UC FOR
MENTAL HEALTH WE ARE SUPER
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT PRIORITY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE PARITY UP THE CSU THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ASSOCIATION FOR OCCUPATIONAL
EDUCATION WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
STATE'S CONTINUED SUPPORT OF
KERR EDUCATION AND THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE WHICH
PROVIDES FOR TWO HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE MILLION AN ON GOING FUNDING
FOR STRONG WORK FORCE.
HOWEVER WE'D LIKE TO SEE THE
ENTIRE TWO HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT
MILLION STRONG WORK FORCE
DOLLARS BE ON IT GOING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MAY WASHINGTON WITH CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THE TERM
CARTY IS DONE ON FINANCIAL AID
REFORM AND URGED THE LEGISLATURE
TO COMMIT TO MAKING A
SIGNIFICANT DOWN PAYMENT ON
REFORM.
SPECIFICALLY SO THAT THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE IS ADDRESSED --
ADDITIONALLY WE WERE EXCITED TO
SEE THAT SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
FOR RAPID RE HOUSING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE -- AND TO
CLARIFY AN EARLIER POINT ON MOST
CAMPUSES IT IS -- IT IS THE
STUDENT GOVERNMENT PAYING FOR
BASIC NEEDS RESOURCES NOT THE
INSTITUTIONS WHICH IS WHY IT IS
SUCH A NECESSITY THANK YOU.
HELLO LARA'S ABA CUBA'S AT THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO STRENGTHENING
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY AND THE ON
GOING WORK THAT YOU IN OTHER
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS ARE DOING TO
CRAFT BROADER FINANCIALLY REFORM
BUT AS YOU KNOW TODAY'S STUDENTS
NEED A DOWN PAYMENT.
ON THAT REFORM RIGHT NOW WITH
MORE ELIGIBLE STUDENTS CURRENTLY
TURNED AWAY THEN SERVED BY THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM AND MANY OF
THOSE WHO DO RECEIVE AWARDS
STARKLY UNDERSERVED WE URGE YOU
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS MANY OF
WHICH GO TO STUDENT PARENTS.
AS WELL AS THE SIZE OF THE CAL
GRANT THE ACCESS AWARD IN THE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
STATE BUDGET.
DOING SO WILL ENSURE MORE
STUDENTS ACROSS ALL TYPES OF
COLLEGES GET THE ASSISTANCE THEY
NEED TO COVER TOTAL COLLEGE
COSTS AND SUCCESSFULLY EARN A
HIGHER EDUCATION CREDENTIALS
THANK YOU.
HI JAKE BREMNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
WE APPRECIATE YOUR FOCUS AND
THAT OF THE COMMITTEE ON SERVING
MORE CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
STUDENTS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND HOPE WE CAN IDENTIFY
RESOURCES IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET --
TO ENROLL MORE A CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AT THE UNIVERSITY ABOVE --
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S PROPOSAL --
WITH REGARDS TO THE STUDENT
SUCCESS PROPOSALS THAT ARE PUT
FORTH FOR BOTH UNIVERSITIES WE
SUPPORT THOSE INVESTMENTS BUT
HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN --
IDENTIFY SOME GOALS FOR THOSE
FUNDS -- AND THAT ARE BEING
UTILIZED AT THE UNIVERSITY AS
WELL AS ASK FOR GREATER DATA
TRANSPARENCY FROM THE UNIVERSITY
SO WE CAN REALLY.
ASSESS -- OUR PROGRESS TOWARDS
CLOSING THOSE PERSISTENT EQUITY
GAPS THAT OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR
FACE AT BOTH UNIVERSITIES AND
THEN FINALLY WITH RESPECT TO
FINANCIAL AID.
ECHO MUCH OF THE COMMENTS FROM
OUR PARTNERS AT TI GUESS WE
APPRECIATE.
YOUR WORK TO TRY TO OVERHAUL AND
EXPAND FINANCIAL AID AVAILABLE
FOR STUDENTS HOPE THAT WE CAN
BUILD ON GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
PROPOSALS AND FINALLY ON BEHALF
OF OUR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT
COALITION -- IN THE CONTEXT OF
FINANCIAL AID -- HOPE THAT WE
CAN FIND THE DREAMER SERVICE
INCENTIVE GRANT PROPOSAL -- THAT
WAS REQUESTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEON THANK YOU.
HI AM DEBBIE RUSHER WITH JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH WE
WERE APPRECIATIVE TO SEE FUNDING
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR
RAPID RE HOUSING FOR CS USING
UC'S.
I'D LIKE TO ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT ANY
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT DIRECTS THAT MONEY
SPECIFICALLY FOR ACTUAL PROVEN
RAPID RE HOUSING STRATEGIES AND
NOT DIVERTED TO EMERGENCY
HOUSING.
OF SOLUTIONS IN ADDITION WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT THE
SYSTEM WITH THE GREATEST LEVEL
OF NEED THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WAS NOT ALLOCATED ANY FUNDING
FOR RAPID RE HOUSING AND WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE ASSEMBLY.
TO INCLUDE FUNDING FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR RAPIDLY
HOUSING THINKING.
MR MEMBERS BRIAN HOW THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE IN A PLOT THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING --
IMPROVE -- INCREASING THE
FUNDING FOR FULL TIME FACULTY
HIRING AS WELL AS A PART TIME --
TO A COLLEGE FACULTY OFFICE
HOURS -- AND WE CONTINUE TO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AS
IT RELATES TO THE FUNDING
FORMULA AND THE ON MY COLLEGE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AND WHEN FROM SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK TO A PROJECT
REBOUND AND WE ARE INCREDIBLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE MAY REVISE
MILLION DOLLAR.
GRANT TO PROJECT REBOUNDS -- IT
DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH.
AND HERE'S WHY.
AT A TIME WHEN AT THE SAME TIME
IN THE MAY REVISE WERE SAYING
OVER FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS IN TOTAL -- YOU
HAVEN'T.
BUT I SPOKE IN THE BACK -- TO
QUITE A LITTLE BIT I CAN'T HEAR
THE SPEAKER THANK YOU.
I'M YOU HAVE IT WITHIN PROJECT
REBOUND PERHAPS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE ANTI RECIDIVISM
PROGRAM IN THE STATE.
AND IF YOU COMPARE THE
RECIDIVISM A PROJECT REBOUND
STUDENTS WHICH IS. 0%. TO THE
RECIDIVISM OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION MOVING THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS WHICH
IS ABOVE 60%.
AND INVESTMENT IN PROJECT
REBOUND.
IS AN INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
SAFETY.
AND INVESTMENT IN ANTI
RECIDIVISM NOT TO MENTION HOPE.
SO WE ASK THIS COMMITTEE TO DO
WHAT IT CAN TO MEET THAT
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION AND THE THREE
POINT THREE MILLION THAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO SCALE PROJECT
REBOUND.
FROM THE EIGHT CAMPUSES THAT SIR
CURRENTLY SERVES TO THE
POTENTIAL FIFTEEN CAMPUSES SEVEN
CAMPUSES ACROSS THE STATE ARE
READY AND WAITING TO COME ONLINE
IN IN BOWL PROJECT REBOUND
STUDENTS.
THANK YOU FOR HELPING US MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ALSO WAS
FROM BEHALF THE COAST
COMMUNICABLE DISTRICT RANGER
SANTIAGO COMMUNIT COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN THE ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEGISLATIVE
TASK FORCE -- WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE LEGISLATURE
MINISTRATIONS CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA --
AS MENTIONED IN THE STAFF
COMMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS -- DID
WANT TO SAY THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE CERTAIN THINGS ADDRESS
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER
ESPECIALLY WITH REGARD TO
INSTRUCTION SERVICE AGREEMENTS --
ALSO APPRECIATIVE OF THE ON
GOING FUNDING FOR THE STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM AND ENCOURAGE
THE ASSEMBLY TO ADOPT THAT --
FULL FUNDING AS AN ON GOING
BASIS THANKS MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AMY
HIND SHANK WITH UP THE CW A
LOCAL NINETY ONE NINETEEN I'M
ARE SORRY THAT MR O'DONNELL IS
NOT PRESENT AT THIS TIME BECAUSE
HE HAD MENTIONED TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
ASKING THEM IF THE DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN THAT THEY'RE
INSISTING UPON.
DOES A ROW THE ACTUARIAL
STABILITY AND IT IS OUR
ACTUARIES AND OUR OPINION THAT
IT DOES IN FACT DO THAT 37% OF
FOLKS ARE.
NOW CHOOSING THE DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN WHICH DOES
DESTABILIZE THE PLAN SO WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY FIVE MILLION
WE IT WOULD LIKE YOU.
TO ACTUALLY MIRROR WHAT YOU DID
LAST YEAR OF A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION AND MAKING IT
CONDITIONAL ON NOT A READING THE
ACTUARIAL STABILITY OF THE
PENSION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING -- CHAIR MCCARTY --
MARVIN MARTINEZ HOW PRESIDENT OF
EAST LOS ANGELES COLLEGE.
I'M ALSO SERVING AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER BOARD THIS YEAR.
THAT'S MY PLEASURE TO BE HERE
MOST OF MY COMMENTS ARE GONNA BE
FOCUS ON THE ON THE STUDENT
ENTERED FUNDING FORMULA.
FIRST REQUEST WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
IS A ONE TIME APPROPRIATION OR
FORTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS TO
FULLY FUND.
THE STUDENT CENTER FUNDING
FORMULA WITHOUT THIS FORTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS TO LOOKING AT A
FORTY NINE MILLION DOLLAR CUT
THIS YEAR.
OF ALL COLLEGES FOR THIS CURRENT
BUDGET YEAR.
SECONDLY TO SECURE THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TOTAL COMPUTATIONAL
REVENUE.
PLUS COLA AS THE NEW BASS FOR
DISTRICTS.
WITHOUT THIS NEW BASE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IT YOU WON'T BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN OUR DISTRICT
OPERATIONS.
IT CAN HELP WAS BUILT
INSTITUTIONAL CAPACITY AND OF
COURSE PROPERLY IMPLEMENT GUIDED
PATHWAYS.
WE FULLY SUPPORT EXTENDED THE
HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION TO
FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO WE NEED
THIS IN ORDER TO DETERMINE IN
MEDICAID DATA INTEGRITY.
AND TO INCREASE TRUST IN BETA.
OUR LAST MINUTE LEAST TO WE WANT
TO BE SURE THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT PROGRAMS LIKE -- THE
SPECIAL ADMIT STUDENTS WHO ARE
FORMALLY CARCERI TO STUDENTS OR
STUDENTS WHO ARE PART OF THE
PUBLIC SERVICE ACADEMIES THE
MANY MORE CALLING TO SERVE.
AND IN THIS IN UNDER THIS
FUNDING FORMULA DID NOT FULLY
FUNDED.
AND WE WOULD REQUESTED THERE
FULLY FUNDED LIKE CDC P. AND
OTHER PROGRAMS LAST BUT NOT
LEAST -- TO FUND -- CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS AND WE WILL BE
SUPPORT YOUR YOUR YOUR SUPPORT
IN REGARDS TO THAT AREA THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MCCARTY LIZ
AT EVERITT WITH THE COMING
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
WANT TO THANK YOU FIRST AND
FOREMOST FOR YOUR EFFORTS TO
PERFORM FINANCIAL AID AND ASK
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO EMPHASIZE
THE NEEDS.
OF STUDENTS WITH ME COLLEGES TO
SERVE -- THE MOST STUDENTS OF
COLOR IN LOW INCOME AND HAVE
THAT -- GREATEST DEMONSTRATED
NEED ALSO AND I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE ACTIONS YOU'VE
ALREADY TAKEN TO SUPPORT CAPITAL
OUTLAY WITH REGARDS -- TO THE
FUNDING FORMULA WE URGE THAT YOU
REJECTED THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES
PROPOSAL -- TO IT WOULD CHANGE
THE DEFINITION AROUND TRANSFER --
TO ONLY ACCOUNT WHERE THE
STUDENT LIVES AND INSTEAD
CONSIDER A PROPOSAL -- TO
ACTUALLY COUNT OF THE POINTS
TOWARDS WHERE STUDENTS ACTUALLY
ATTENDED AND COLLEGE -- AND THEN
WE WANNA LINER COMMENTS A WITH
AND THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICERS
AND THANK THE JOHN BURTON
FOUNDATION FOR HIGHLIGHTING THE
INEQUITY THAT WAS.
ESTABLISHED BY NOT INCLUDING
RAPID RE HOUSING OPTIONS FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE ARE
GONNA ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S ME REVISED PROPOSAL
FOR THE CHILD'S SAVINGS ACCOUNT
PROGRAM.
AND WOULD RECOMMEND ADOPTING THE
LANGUAGE IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
HIS ARIENS BILL AB FIFTEEN FOR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR THIS
PROGRAM WITH THE STUDENT EIGHT
COMMISSION AS THE ADMINISTRATOR.
THANK YOU.
DALE SHIMAZAKI REPRESENTING OF
LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE PASADENA
CITY COLLEGE IN SANTA MONICA
COLLEGE OF WE URGE US SUPPORT OF
THE ADDITIONAL YEAR OF THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISIONS AND IN
ADDITION WE ALIGN OURSELVES WITH
THE LET'S ITS COMMENTS.
REGARDING THE DEFINITION OF
TRANSFER STUDENTS.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF THAT
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALLIANCE OF
VENTURA COUNTY VENTURA AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTIES HERE TO SUPPORT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR WINS REQUEST
FOR FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
CHILD CARE.
CENTER IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION CENTER AT CHANNEL
ISLANDS -- STATE UNIVERSITY --
CHANNEL ISLANDS A IMPORTANT PART
OF THE ECONOMIC VITALITY OF THE
GREATER REGION AND WE SUPPORT
THE REQUEST THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THERE ARE TO REMAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES WE
WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR THE
LEGISLATURE FOR FOCUSING ON
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
AT THE THREE PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
AND ALSO FOR FOCUSING ON THE
GRADUATION GAPS EXIST ALL THREE
SEGMENTS WE NEED TO CLOSE THOSE
THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE WALKING
OUT THE DOOR HOLDING A DIPLOMA.
WE ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT THE
LEGAL IMMIGRATION SERVICES AS
WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE
MONTHS REQUEST FOR SERVICE
LEARNING GRANT -- DO YOU SEE ARE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AS AT A
HISPANIC SERVING INSTITUTION IN
AN AREA THAT IS TRADITIONALLY
UNDERSERVED AND SO WE SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR THAT.
AND FINALLY WHAT WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR FOR THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR FINANCIAL AID WE DO
HOPE FOR COMPREHENSIVE REFORM.
THAT TREATS STUDENTS EQUITABLY
ACROSS ALL THREE PUBLIC SYSTEMS
AND THE PRIVATE NOT FOR PROFITS
AND ADDRESSES TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- CHAIRMAN MCCARTY --
MARK MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES SAN DIEGO YUBA SAN
FRANCISCO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS -- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ON GOING SUPPORT FOR FINANCIAL
AID AND LOOKING AT THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE -- WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPERTY TAX BACK FILL WE'D LIKE
YOU TO LOOK AT A PERMANENT FIX
FOR THAT THAT'S SOMETHING.
THAT HAS BEEN AN ONGOING ISSUE
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS --
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
ALLOCATE THE SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT
BY COLLEGE SO THAT WE'RE NOT
LEAVING SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS BEHIND --
AND ALSO SOME IDEAS FOR ONE TIME
MONEY TO SUPPORT SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS WOULD
BE FOR DREAM CENTERS AND LBGT
CUES CENTERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN MISTER
DALI KING.
HIS MERE -- HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES --
WE JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED COLA CAT AND CASTERS --
CONTRIBUTIONS AND IS WILLING TO
EXTEND THE YEAR HOLD HARMLESS
VISIT -- PROVISION OF THIS THAN
STUDENT CENTER FUNDING FORMULA.
HOWEVER WE CONTINUE DOES HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PERFORMANCE SPACE METRICS.
WHICH WILL DELIVER UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES TO CREATE A SYSTEM
OF WINNERS AND LOSERS -- IF WE
TRULY WANT TO SEE OUR STUDENTS
BECOME MORE SUCCESSFUL WE HAVE
TO THEN WE NEED TO INVEST IN
FACULTY THAT ACTUALLY CHANGED
OUR LIVES -- WE'RE ALSO DEEPLY
TROUBLED BY THE FULLY ONLINE
COLLEGE AND DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
IS THE BEST INVESTMENT FOR
STUDENTS -- THE FACULTY WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE ON LINE BECAUSE DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THEY'VE BEEN PUTTING
IN WORK -- FOR FOR ONLINE
ACCESSIBILITY FOR STUDENTS FOR
LIKE THE WHAT PASSED TWO DECADES --
THE COLLEGE IS SUPPOSED TO BEGIN
IN REALLY STUDENTS IN THE END OF
SUMMER BUT HAS YET TO ADDRESS --
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING OR AN
ACADEMIC SENATE.
AND ULTIMATELY GIVEN THE LIMITED
RESOURCES OF AN OVER BUDGET AND
REDUNDANT COLLEGE IS NOT A GOOD
INVESTMENT WHEN THERE ARE SO
MANY OTHER PRIORITIES THAT I
NEED FUNDING -- DESPITE ALL THAT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE.
ON THESE ISSUES MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU.
HELLO -- MY NAME IS OUT JUNE
WILLIAMS I'M AN INSTRUCTOR AND A
COMMA JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
AT SIX STATE.
ALSO THE PROGRAM COORDINATOR FOR
A PROJECT WE BILL.
A LOT THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
PARTY AND ALSO SAY AT THE
PROPOSED AMOUNT -- THAT WOULD
LEAVE US -- UNDERSTAFFED AT A
TIME WHERE -- AND ROMAN IS
TROUBLING.
AND ALSO LED PROPOSED AMOUNT.
WE WANT IT WILL SEVERELY CRIPPLE
AMOUNT OF DIRECT FINANCIAL A WE
CAN OFFER OUR STUDENTS IN TERMS
OF SCHOLARSHIPS AND TRAVEL
VOUCHERS AND FOOD VOUCHERS
ETCETERA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN HI MCCARTY --
MY NAME'S ANDREW WHEN I'M
DIRECTOR PRIDE RE NOT CHECKING
THE STATE UNIVERSITY.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE
POINTS -- ONE IS.
THE EXPANSION -- WOULD BE HALTED
AT THEIR KERN AMOUNT TO THE
OTHER SEVEN CAMPUSES INCLUDING --
MEMBER I O'DONNELL'S CAMPUS OF
LONG BEACH -- AND THEN ALSO THE
FUNDING LEVEL DOES INCLUDE ANY
ROOM -- FOR PROGRAM ASSESSMENT
WHICH IS IN AT THAT CRITICAL
TOOL TO BE ABLE TO DETERMINE.
HOW -- TO MOVE FORWARD INTO THE
FUTURE WITH PRIDE REEBOK THANK
YOU.
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY I LANDED ON
WITH THE WEDDING GROUP HERE ON
BEHALF OF NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
FIRST OF ALL WANT TO THANK YOU
AND STAFF ON YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
DISCUSSIONS AROUND AND FINANCIAL
AID REFORM.
ALONG THOSE LINES WE THINK THAT
STUDENT LOAN AWARENESS IS HIGHLY
IMPORTANT SO NEXT AND DEFINITELY
SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S RIPPLES
OVER THE FIVE MILLION.
A ONE TIME A PREPARATION FOR THE
STUDENT LOAN AWARENESS
INITIATIVE -- IN THE WHOLE
CONVERSATION AROUND FINANCIAL
AID THERE'S ALWAYS THOSE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE GRADUATED OR
MY HAVE EVEN EVEN DROPPED OUT
DUE TO STUDENT LOANS SO WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION -- A BROADER
CONVERSATION OF HOW THOSE TWO
CAN TIED TOGETHER THANK YOU.
CHRIS FOR SIGNS OF THE TRAILER
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AMOUNTS ARE
PRESENT IN OUR YOUTH
ORGANIZATION THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM NETWORK -- WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT'S ON THE BOTTOM
OF THE KNOWLEDGE STOCK ANALYSIS --
WITH THE DISCUSSION OF I MISS
THE MANTRA OPPOSE ALL FOR
SERVICES ON A GRANDER WHICH
WOULD BE AN ADDITIONAL CAL GRANT
FOR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ARE
THIS ISN'T GOD CRITICAL TIME
ESPECIALLY AS DOCTOR HAS BE
RESEND IT AND SO NOW.
THE TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ARE
GRADUATING FROM A CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOLS BOB SO THE NEED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO FINANCE
THEIR EDUCATION.
AND ARE ALSO TO PRO PUT IN A
PLUG FOR OUR ONGOING EFFORTS FOR
DURING THE DAYS ON IS AN ODD
DREAM CENTERS AYE CAMPUSES.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAPPEN TO
BE ONE OF THE LARGEST SCIENCE
ARE.
GROUP SYSTEMS THAT SERVE OUR
STUDENTS BUT TO SEE ISSUES IN
THE UC'S I'VE BEEN -- ON ALREADY
WOULD DO IN A MUCH OF THIS WORK
SO WE WOULD JUST ASK THAT ALL
THREE SYSTEMS I HAVE THAT AND
THEN LASTLY FOR A LEGAL SERVICES.
APPRECIATE OF THE GOVERNOR'S OUR
PROPOSAL AND FOR LONG WHEN
SUPPORT FOR THE WILL SERVICES
FOR A DOCUMENT STUDENTS.
GOOD MORNING ALEX GRAZE THE
ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES JUST WANT TO THANK
THE MINISTRATION -- FOR THE ONE
YEAR EXTENSION ON OUR SECTOR
MEETING IT'S AT T. TARGETS ARE
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO MEETING
THOSE -- BUT IT HAS BEEN A BIG
LEFT THERE'S A LOT OF WORK DONE
SO FAR THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THE
REMAINS TO BE DONE AND I'M TO
ENSURE THERE ARE ROBUST.
OFFERINGS -- THOSE PATHWAYS FOR
COMMUNICATES TRANSFER STUDENTS
AND ALSO REGARDING THE STUDENT
PARENT PROPOSAL -- WE RECOGNIZE
MAYBE INTEREST IN RE PURPOSING
THAT MONEY FOR OTHER FINANCIAL
AID -- REFORM PURPOSES BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT PROPOSALS BEING
CONSIDERED WE REMAIN INTERESTED
IN SEEING OUR STUDENTS PARENTS
AND INCLUDED AS WELL THANK YOU.
YOUR MCCARTY -- MISTER MARTIN --
DAVID BELL HAWKINS WITH THE CSU
EMPLOYEES UNION -- ASKING
SUPPORT FOR DOCTOR WEBBER'S
REQUEST THE ONE TIME MONEY ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP
WITH INVERTED.
SALARIES FOR THE SEE IF YOU
SUPPORT STAFF WE CURRENTLY HAVE
OVER -- TEN THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AS SUPPORT
STAFF THAT HAVE INVERTED
SALARIES.
THAT MEANS ON AVERAGE -- NEW
HIRES ARE EARNING OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DOLLARS A
MONTH.
MORE SO THAN -- EMPLOYEES ARE
WORKING IN THE SAME POSITION ON
THE SAME CAMPUS THAT HAVE BEEN
THERE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS --
WE THINK THIS BE A GOOD FIRST
STEP THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GABRIEL
GARCIA WITH THE SOUTHEAST ASIA
RESOURCE ACTION CENTER WE
REPRESENT AB.
FOLKS THAT CAME OVER FROM
SOUTHEAST ASIA AS REFUGEES
CAMBODIAN LAOTIAN AMONG
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
COLLEGE READING THIS BLOCK GRANT
WHICH WAS SUBMITTED BY THE A. P.
I. LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
THIS WOULD DEVOTE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO K. THROUGH
TWELVE DISTRICTS THAT WOULD
CREATE COLLEGE GOING AND COLLEGE
READINESS PROGRAMS FOR THE THEIR
STUDENTS THAT ARE LOW INCOME --
FOSTER YOUTH AND ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AS WELL AS
TWENTY MILLION ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS FOR THE UC SYSTEM TO
CREATE CRITICAL PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT THEIR STUDENTS ONCE THEY
GET ON CAMPUS -- IN ADDITION
ALSO STANDING IN SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING REQUEST FOR THE PROJECT
REBOUND FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING USE ALEX BEFORE YOU
SEE STUDENTS ASSOCIATION -- ON
BEHALF OF THE UC STUDENTS SO WE
ARE EXCITED TO SEE THE MAY
REVISE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
RAPID RE HOUSING AND IMMIGRATION
LEGAL SERVICES AND FULLY SUPPORT
THOSE.
IN ADDITION WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
PARTIES THAT STILL NEED FUNDING --
IN REGARDS TO THE COLLEGE
READINESS BLOCK GRANT -- TERMS%
OF MAY REVISE WE A REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY MILLION AS
PART OF THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING --
TO BE PUT TOWARDS THE ARE RICH
AND OUR RETENTION PROGRAMS AT
THE UC -- NEXT THE THOUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES SOME
FUNDING FOR MENTAL HEALTH IT
FALLS SHORT OF THE NEED FUNDING
BY FOUR POINT A MILLION SO WE
REQUEST THAT THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING BE ALLOCATED TO ENSURE
SERVICES ARE.
SUFFICIENTLY FUNDED LASTLY I WE
WOULD LIKE TO AIR SUPPORT FOR
THE PRIME PROGRAM EVERQUEST
ALLEGES LEGISLATURE TO FUND
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SINCE THE MORNING GOOD MORNING
SIR MCCARTY MARIO -- ON THE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION ONE OF OYSTER
SUPPORT FOR THE FULL REQUEST AT
THREE POINT THREE MILLION FOR
THE POP PROJECT REBOUND.
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
SENATE BUDGET SUB ONE COMMITTEE
I AM JUST PROVED THIRTY FIVE
MILLION FOR TENURE TRACK WE
WOULD LIKE -- TO ASK THAT THIS
COMMITTEE ALSO DO THAT THEY ALSO --
INCREASE -- INCREASED.
THE FULLY FUNDED THE THE CS USE
GRAD INITIATIVE OP BY THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS SO THAT -- MAYBE
YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL SOURCES OF
FUNDING -- WE BELIEVE THAT --
MENTAL HEALTH THAT IS THAT WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING ON MENTAL
HEALTH -- WE CONSIDER CONTINUE
TO REITERATE THAT THAT'S A
POTENTIAL -- FUNDING SOURCE FOR
A OF THE SOMETHING ON MENTAL
HEALTH IN THE CSU THANK YOU FOR
TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN A BY
ROS YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE CFA US FOR A MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELORS.
AND A TENURE TRACK FUNDING AND
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVEN'T ASKED
FOR THE UC BERKELEY LABOR CENTER
A STUDY ON THE FUTURE WORK AT
THE SMALL ASKONE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS.
A CURRENTLY A LOT OF THE DATA
THAT WE USE IS FROM OF THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND WE REALLY NEED SOME
NEW INFORMATION THAT CAN HELP.
INFORM OTHER DECISIONS THAT WE
MAKE ON FOREIGN WE THINK IT'S A
SMALLER HOSPITAL GO A LONG WAY
WITH HER SUPPORT.
LOS NOT LEAST MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU JUST MULLIN I'VE IN
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE ON THE
OTHER SIDE SEVEN MEMBERS.
PROPOSAL TO PUT ANOTHER THREE
MILLION DOLLARS INTO THE COAST
PROGRAM -- THAT IS SO COASTAL
RESEARCH TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM
THAT'S ESSENTIAL FOR ESPECIALLY
ADVISING I'LL POLICY DECISIONS
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE ON HOW
TO DO THE RIGHT THING THIS SO
MANY COASTAL ISSUES AT STAKE.
WE HAVE FOR THE PACIFIC
SHOWPIECE GROWS CLEAN CITIES
COALITION OTHER GROUPS I'D LIKE
TO SEE THAT MUCH MONEY FUNDED
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OFFER YOUR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY WITH THAT WE
ARE ADJOURNED